[Musique]
François lin bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle seriew nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement succintement je suis né le
14 septembre c'est le jour de la Sainte
Croix ça fait penser à cette parole vous
savez de Churchill qui avait dit de
toutes les croix que j'ai porté dans ma
vie la plus lourde a été la croix de
Lorine bienacent je suis 14 septembre
1957 c'était l'année de du traité de
Rome voilà donc pour moi c'est assez
facile de voir quelle est la durée du
traité de Rome puisque c'est c'est la
c'est l'année de ma naissance et j'ai
créé l'uppr l'Union Populaire
Républicaine pour sortir du traité de
Rome et sortir de l'Union européenne le
jour de mes 50 ans enfin l'année de mes
50 ans en 2007 c'était le 50e
anniversaire du traité de Rome
entre-temps bon j'étais un bon élève
j'ai fait
HC j'ai fait ensuite quelque chose qui a
beaucoup compté dans ma vie c'est mon
service national comme coopérant au
Japon dans des conditions très
extraordinaires qui m'a permis pendant
un an et demi de vivre à l'époque en
1981 c'était vraiment il y avait pas
d'internet il y av pas possibilité de
téléphoner pas possibilité de revenir en
France et cetera donc c'était une espèce
de bannissement soft si jeose dire mais
c'était quelque chose qui était vraiment
et ça ça m'a ça beaucoup compté pour moi
euh et puis ça m'a tellement compté pour
moi que j'ai décidé de préparer le
concours de Lena parce que mon rêve à
l'époque était de devenir un jour
ambassadeur de France au Japon puisque
je travaillais dans les services
commerciaux de l'ambassade et à l'époque
l'ambassadeur c'était Xavier d'aufren de
la chevalerie qui avait été chef de
cabinet de de de gaaule et qui était
pour moi je voyais ça c'était un rêve en
fait de venir un jour défendre mon pays
au Japon j'ai beaucoup aimé le Japon et
c'est un peu comme candide vous savez de
Voltaire qui finalement après avoir
beaucoup voyagé ben veut cultiver son
jardin vous savez c'est en fait ce que
j'ai découvert au Japon c'est l'amour de
mon propre pays
c'est-à-dire j'ai toujours aimé mon pays
mais bon vous savez quand on est
étudiant déjà il y avait l'attrait de
l'étranger moi j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
des m parents mon père qui nous a fait
beaucoup voyager dans l'Europe en
voiture on on avait pas les moyens de
voyager en avion mais en voiture on est
allé en quand j'étais enfant en Espagne
au Portugal en Italie en Allemagne en
Suisse en Belgique en Angleterre et ça
m'a ouvert beaucoup l'esprit et a très
envie de de de de voyager donc j'étais
parti comme coopérant au Japon en 1980
fin 80 à l'époque d'ailleurs on pensait
que que giscar serait réélu bon
et puis j'ai vécu l'élection de mitteran
au Japon et c'est très intéressant parce
qu'en France a été la nuit était
remplacé par par par le soleil enfin
c'était la les paroles de de Jack Lang
vous savez ça a été vécu comme un
tremblement de terre politique quelque
chose
extraordinaire vu du Japon il y avait un
entreopilet comme ça page 13 du
yomirumun et du
maichi donc ça permet de relativiser
j'avais parents qui m'appelaient parce
que j'avais pas les moyens d'appeler à
l'époque le téléphone était extrêmement
cher euh donc mon père m'avait appelé en
pleine
nuit était 3 4h du matin pour m'annoncer
que mit Teran était élu donc je sentais
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'agitation en
France à cette époque-là mais vu de loin
vu de vu de 14000 km ça permettait de
relativiser et puis surtout ce que j'ai
découvert aussi c'est des petites
anecdotes mais j'étais dans les services
commerciaux de l'ambassade de France et
puis un jour un Japonais qui un
importateur japonais qui voulait
importer des produits euh donc nous le
travail c'était de voir des importateurs
de voir des exportateurs français qui
venaient au Japon en fa de les mettre en
relation il y avait quand même beaucoup
de travail en fait mine de rien euh et
euh il y avait un importateur japonais
qui me pose la question comme ça tout à
traque euh o où est
rquefort et je savais pas c'est non non
je savais pas bon j'avais 23 24 ans
j'étais pas de la région je savais pas
où c'était Rockfort comment il s'appelle
le pont qui est très célèbre à côté de
rock c'est le pont de le viuc de mot qui
est juste à côté je suis allé après à
Roquefort j'y suis allé et le Roquefort
est fait avec quoi comme lait c'est du
lait de brebis et qui est avec les dans
des infractuuses enfin vous connaissez
c'est d'accord non mais comment coupe le
Rockfort françoisg est-ce que le le
Rockfort se coupe ou est-ce que le
Rockfort se frotte bah en général on le
met sur une meule et puis avec un un fil
comme ça pour le couper vous savez avec
rofor se frotte se frotte c'est-à-dire
avec le fil comme ça
non on le frotte avec délicatement avec
son couteau pour mélanger le myélium
ouis avec le
blanc on
continue bref on s'égare
et et ça ça m'a ça a été c'est c'est
c'est marrant la vie he comme ça une
petite je me suis dit en fait je connais
bien le Japon j'avais voyagé dans tout
le Japon je en fait je sais pas où ROF
je savais pas non plus il y avait des
affiches sur des abayes en provenceabay
de Silvacane je n'y étais jamais allé je
savais pas où c'était les abayes ici
tercienes de Provence donc en fait j'ai
j'ai découvert comment dirais-je l'amour
de mon pays à l'étranger je me suis dit
en fait je suis de cette terre là
surtout qu'en plus de ça à
l'époque le le
Japon enfin la France avait une une côte
au Japon comme dans beaucoup de pays du
monde mais encore Japon c'était il y
avait des portraits absolument partout
de Catherine Deneuve et d'Alain Delon
voilà moi j'avais évidemment j'avais 40
ans de moins 30 ans de moins 35 ans de
moins et non 40 43 ans de moins j'étais
j'avais des cheveux je pisais 30 kg de
moins j'avais des rides en moins j'avais
les yeux bleus donc c'était cétait
vraiment les Japonais il y avait un
succès pour la France qui était très
très très significatif et donc je suis
revenu en me disant je vais préparer le
concours de Lena pour devenir
ambassadeur voilà donc ça a été la
première bifurcation par rapport à HC
c'est de travailler pour le service de
l'État avec cet objectif et puis puis
c'est ce qui s'est passé bon j'ai pas
fait Science Po j'ai fait ça en candidat
li ça a bien marché puis je suis entré à
Lena et puis j'ai bien travaillé parce
que je VO je suis je suis je suis un
bosseur en fait je suis quelqu'un qui je
je j'ai une particularité quand même
surtout à notre époque où il y a quand
même énormément de gens qui alors dans
le milieu politique n'en parlons pas
parce que les gens ne travaillent
absolument pas mais l'idée d'approfondir
un dossier d'aller au fond des choses
comme le recommander de Gaulle c'est
vraiment quelque chose que depuis que je
suis petit j'avais des parents qui
étaient très très à cheval sur
l'éducation euh mais mon père comme ma
mère qui n'aimait pas qu'on fasse
semblant de travailler voilà an que
cétait il fallait que j' posséder son
sujet ça c'était c'est quelque chose qui
a toujours été important dans ma dans
dans ma vie et et donc j'ai beaucoup
travaillé aussi quand j'étais à Lena
parce que Lena c'est difficile d'y
rentrer mais il faut aussi en sortir
parce que pour sortir au Kor il fallait
bien bien sortir bon tout ça ce sont des
problématique qui échappe un peu à la
population générale mais quand vous vous
êtes fixé un objectif dans la vie voilà
et puis puis en fait ça a un peu trop
bien marché puisque je suis sorti
vismajor et là bon la deuxième
bifurcation dans ma vie c'est qu'au lieu
de prendre le cadorcet pour lequel
j'avais préparé les j'ai pris
l'inspection générale des finances qui
était plus en conformité d'ailleurs avec
les études que j'avais faites par avant
HC ensuite j'ai passé 2 ans de mob j'ai
fait les 4 années de tournée à
l'Inspection Générale des Finances qui
c'est une école de rigueur c'est c'est
enfin c'est comme ça que je l'ai perçu
puisque il faut aller vérifier sans
arrêt on un peu comme de l'audit on va
vérifier en permanence des agents vérifi
mais à la différence peut-être de minse
ou de je ne sais pas quoi notre
employeur c'est l'état et surtout on
donne la parole à l'agent vérifié
c'est-à-dire que il y a ce qu'on appelle
la première la deuxème colonne la 3ème
colonne et cetera la première colonne
c'est qu'on fait un rapport de
l'inspection quand on est dans ce qu'on
appelle la tournée quand on est un jeune
inspecteur des finances on va voir un
percepteur un trésorier et cetera et
puis on
on doit faire un rapport le plus
inquisitorial possible pour pas passer à
côté de de si on passe à côté d'un
détournement de fond on on a l'air d'une
bille si on découvre un détournement de
fond quelques années après donc il faut
faire des observations qui sont
numérotées c'est ce qu'on appelle la
première colonne et puis après ce
document est envoyé à l'agent vérifié
qui évidemment est attaqué dans ce
rapport et donc il se défend point par
point et donc c'est ce qu'on appelle la
deuxème colonne et dans ce qu' si
l'inspecteur des
finances se trompe si l'agent vérifi que
ce soit dans le service des impô service
d'assiette comptabilité publique mais
aussi dans une dans une
société prix public ou dans une dans un
établissement public si on se rend
compte si l'agent vérifié se rend compte
enfin montre que le l'inspecteur s'est
trompé on appelle ça dans notre jargon
un
clacage alors c'est une c'est une et
donc en 3è colonne l'inspecteur doit
éventuellement si si l'agent vérifié
prouve queon s'est trompé et bien
l'inspecteur des finances doit mettre à
observation rapporté et alors tout ça
est sous la supervision du chef du
service de l'inspection des Finances qui
regarde avec attention les jeunes recrus
sortis de l'enat et on se taille très
très vite une réputation en bien ou en
mal en fait voilà alors ça c'est quelque
chose ça paraît un peu un détail
peut-être aux gens qui nous écoutent pas
du tout en fait est-ce que je peux vous
couper oui bon vous nous avez lancé sur
la diplomatie le kéorset et les finances
oui ça fait très donc je rebondis
exceptionnellement parce que c'est notre
petite interview de fin d'année on va on
va la faire en mode détente l'inspection
générale des finances vous avez vous
avez suivi un petit
peu l'actualité de Bruno Le Maire de la
commission des
finances vous êtes en train de me dire
qu'il y a des gens qui travaillent à
l'établissement de rapport il y a leur
nom dessus oui est-ce qu'on peut trouver
la la chaîne de responsabilité sur ceux
qui ne sont pas capables
d'anticiper le grand désarois de la
France que nous sommes en train de vivre
en ce moment
alors est-ce qu' y a des cellules de
prospective où vous travaillez non non
non non si vous voulez le problème qu'il
y a c'est que l'inspetion des Finances a
été créé par par le baron Louis sous la
Restauration 1815 je crois donc c'est
devenu un grand corps de l'État
normalement c'est des grands serviteurs
de l'État qui ont été sélectionnés et
qui sont amenés à dire des choses dés
agréable au ministre qu'il servent c'est
comme ça en tout cas que j'ai conçu mon
travail mais l'être humain est en ce
qu'il
est si c'est pas forcément la meilleure
façon de progresser du point de vue de
sa carrière professionnelle que d'entrer
en choc frontal avec un ministre voilà
même si ça doit rester dans un monde
feutré donc il y a quand même un peu une
tentation évidemment c'est comme dans
toutes organisation humaines a des gens
qui ont tendance un petit peu à
édulcorer un rapport alors quand il
s'agit d'agent vérifiés de base ça c'est
pas un problème mais lorsqu'on nous
demande dans 3e ou 4e année de tournée
de réfléchir ou de penser à des
politiques publiques la réalité qui est
cruelle c'est un c'est un il y a une une
dérive qui a été qui a été qui s'est
fait jour depuis des des années des
années des années c'est que on est
quasiment sommé de de conclure on sait
déjà quelles sont les conclusions auquel
le cabinet du ministre souhaite que nous
parvenions donc ça c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas bien euh c'est pas bien parce
que je pense que effectivement le rôle
d'alerte du d'un ministre ne fonctionne
pas par ailleurs je voudrais dire que
deux trois choses aussi qui me semble
important c'est la première chose c'est
que là vous m'avez inter je reviens
parce que je voulais pas perdre c le fil
cette normalement quand on travaille
avec conscience à l'inspection on prend
l'habitude en 4 années d'être rigoureux
dans ce que l'on dit et depuis que j'ai
créé l'uppr donc bien des années après
je crois que je me suis illustré sur la
scène politique française en faisant des
articles dans sur sur notre site
Internet ou dans des revues en faisant
des des conférences en faisant des
vidéos qui sont toujours très précises
et toujours extrêmement sourcé est-ce
que vous pensez être à la hauteur de vos
idéo oui je pense c'est un peu immodeste
mais je pense je pense en tout cas que
honnêtement
honnêtement je pense que je suis à un
âge où je suis en parfaite maîtrise de
de mes
dossiers c'est je à chaque âge a ça ses
vertus mais je pense qu'il faut avoir un
certain âge par exemple pour être
président de la République mais ça c'est
peut-être une une conversation qu'on
aura plus tard on peut pas être
président de la République à 38 ans
enfin on peut Macron c'est un désastre
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça je pense
que l'âge je pense que l'âge pour
optimal pour pour être Premier ministre
chef du gouvernement il faut à mon avis
il faut avoir 50 ans pour être Premier
ministre 50 5 5 ans euh et pour mener la
politique de la nation c'estarticle 20
de la Constitution pour être président
de la République pour chef d'État il
faut avoir 60 65 75 ans ça paraît
beaucoup mais c'est comme ça regardez
d'ailleurs les grands chefs d'État de
notre époque question internet c'est
quoi votre petite broche votre petit
pins ti c'est le on touche pas le micro
c'est le le ramoau d'Olivier c'est c'est
une épinglette que l'on que l'on
commercialise dans notre boutique UPR
qui est une épinglette alors c'est pas
de massif c'est du c'est doré mais c'est
j c'est pres que du pierre bellmard là
attention oui je sais je sais on qu'
écoute pire il a pire il a pire il y a
pire sarcasme ça représente le logo de
notre mouvement et en fait c'est le logo
qui avait été dessiné par Oscar roti Ry
qui était le CELI qui a designé votre
médaille de 2007
non ça c'était pierre Turin c'est ça non
Oscar r c'est celui qui a fait c'est en
fait c'est la pièce de 1 franc
rappelez-vous la pièce deun franc il y
avait le RAM d'Olivier dessiné par Oscar
anti en 1897 et au revers vous aviez la
Semeuse vrais que vous me parliez
d'intelligence économique et de
renseignement économique là on parle on
parle dans tous les sens hein c'est fait
exprès c'est fait exprès bon euh on a du
temps ce soir oui ben justement alors
c'est donc j'ai pas tout à fait terminé
mon propos mais
bon je vous laisse terminer alors non
oui je disais simplement je pense en
conscience qu'un chef d'État à notre
époque je sais qu'il y a des gens qui
disent mais non regardez Napoléon mais
on est pas à l'époque de Napoléon on
n'est pas on n'est pas au moment du 18
brumè non on est on est au 21e siècle
les sociétés sont extrêmement complexes
il faut avoir pour arriver pour diriger
un état très complexe comme la France il
faut avoir de l'expérience il faut avoir
connu des échecs s'être pris des bafes
avoir réfléchi à ces échecs avoir
compris la difficulté aussi de la de la
tâche voilà les les Yaka faom le coup du
petit génie qu'on nous a vendu le le
Jupiter là où le Mozart de la finance
vous avez vu comment ça se termine c'est
un désast grosse tar comment c'est quoi
votre plus grosse
tarte alors c'est pas
forcé c'est peut-être
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident non
c'est c'est je pense c'est d'avoir fait
confiance euh ça çaallais dire c'est un
peu comme à la fin d'un amour de Swan
vous savez de de prou tout ça pour des
chens qui n'étaient pas mon genre avoir
fait Macron non jamais ah non non non
non non non non j'ai quand même de de du
discernement non j'ai non ma plus grosse
c'est par exemple d'avoir cru dans des
gens euh qui en fait ne méritaent pas
que je que je leur fasse confiance voilà
euh et puis de de de me rendre compte
que les choses sont plus compliquées
qu'il n'y paraî et puis de découvrir
aussi que voilà le le le le monde de la
politique c'est un monde infernal en
fait voilà c'est horrible voilà il y a
vraiment des coupbas qui sont des
diffamation des trucs comme ça qui sont
affreux voilà ça c'est et si vous voulez
c'est pas normal que quelqu'un comme
Macron soit arrivé président de la
République comme ça comme une fleur il
se présente pour la première fois une
élection et puis voilà il a il est élu
président de la République ça marche pas
ça veut dire qu'il y a eu quelque chose
quelque part c'est il a bénéficié en
fait il a eu même pas une fusée au
derrière il a eu c'est c'est il a eu
toute la mis à disposition tout
l'appareil de propagande français et de
tous les médias c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé non mais c'est important ce
que je dis donc moi par exemple les
bffes c'est par exemple quand j'ai étaé
candidat à l'élection présidentielle en
2017 honnêtement je savais que je serais
pas au deuxème tour je suis pas pas bête
mais honnêtement je pensais quand même
on avait su un enthousiasme et tout je
pensais quand même pensais honnêtement
que je ferais 3 4 % et on a fait
0,92 après coup quand j réfléchi ça
porte bonheur oui après coup j'ai
découvert que quelqu'un comme Jean-Marie
Le Pen par exemple je me compare pas à
lui mais en 74 il était beaucoup plus
connu que moi parce moi quand j'étais
candidat en 2017 j'ai eu un mois pour me
faire connaître la grande écrasante
majorité de gens me connaissaient pas
même encore maintenant vous avez encore
au moins 2 tiers des Français qui ne
savent pas du tout qui je suis hein
parce que je ne passe jamais dans les
médias non non non non je vous assure je
vous assure je vous assure il y a
maintenant 30 40 % des gens qui me
connaissent et puis il y a connaissance
et connaissance ce que l'on appelle la
connaissance spontanée la connaissance
assistée donc il y a des gens dans la
rue qui me regardent qui certains
m'abordent vous êtes pas un homme
politique mais voilà quand je dis assino
ah oui ah oui assino c'est le frexit oui
c'est ça alors il y a de plus en plus de
gens qui me connaissent mais ça reste
encore si je vous assure pour arriver à
99 % de notoriété c'est considérable et
donc ça le handicap de ne pas passer
dans les grands médias est un handicap
extraordinairement puissant c'est très
très puissant donc ça je l'avais
sous-estimé et malheureusement il y a
quand même beaucoup de gens qui nous
avaient suivi en 2017 il y en a qui ont
été horriblement déçu voilà et donc ça
qui il y a des gens qui parce que ce qui
manque aussi alors ça aussi ce que j'ai
découvert dans notre société c'est que
des vertus que j'ai peut-être
naturellement et qu'on m'avait enseigné
quand j'étais jeune ne sont plus
vraiment d'actualité les vertus de de
ténacité d'opiniâreté voilà ça existe
toujours ça il y a des gens T et
opiniâre mais on est quand même dans une
société du zapping de l'ff minimal ah ça
marche pas le nombre de gens qui m'ont
dit oui non mais vous in vous avez vous
avez fait zéro allez vous coucher ça
vintéresse personne et cetera quand je
leur dis mais comment c'est si j'y a
réfléchi après coup mais si vous voulez
sur en 2017 au premier tour de 2017 j'ai
quand vous voulez pour parler de
maintenant comment si vous voulez qu'on
parle de maintenant parler maintenant
oui d'accord mais en 2017 par exemple
j'avais fait 0,92 % il y aurait eu 95 %
ou 98 % des Français qui m'auraient
connu c'était pas bien mais combien de
gens me connaissaient au premier tour
combien de gens avaient regardé j'ai eu
0,8 % du temps de parole donc il y avait
énormément de gens qui sont allés à
l'élection présidentielle c'est un des
grands sujets qui pas seulement qui me
concerne en parfaite mes connaissance de
cause il il y a pas eu le consentement
éclairé comme pour le vaccin vous aviez
pas le le le bon spin doctor le bon
directeur de campagne avec vous mais
c'est pas ça c'est que nous j'étais
barré j'étais barré qu'est-ce qu'on fait
dans ces cas-là bah qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on essaie de faire ce que je fais
c'est-à-dire c'est s'il y a s'il a je
suis preneur de tous les conseils je
suis pas tout seul on est on a été
rejoint par beaucoup de gens j'ai eu
j'ai épuisé des des responsables de
communication g c'est votre budget de
fonctionnement comment votre budget de
fonctionnement oh ça dépend des années
mais on a un budget limité c'est en quoi
1 million 100 1 million entre 1 et 2
million d'euros quoi en gros c'est à peu
près ça vous êtes rémunéré oui je me
fais rémunérer par l'UP oui oui quel
volume combien je gagne 4000 € après
impôt ce qui c'est moins important qu'un
fonctionnaire non ah oui je gagne
beaucoup moins que lorsque j'étais
inspecteur général des finances et par
ailleurs si j'avais pas fait ce que j'ai
fait
euh vous savez j'avais un une
connaissance un camarade de l'inspection
Frédéric oudea le mari de Madame oua
ctera bon Frédéric oudea il était de
l'inspection à une année près donc je le
connaissais il a fait lui pas fait je la
Félix après il a fait l'en l'inspection
donc lui il est allé dans la banque et
il est devenu il a été à la tête de la
Société Générale et je me rappelle
j'avais vu c'était il l'avais pas dit
mais je l'avais vu dans Capital ou dans
challenge c'était a une bonne dizaine
d'années euh il gagnait quelque chose je
crois comme 270000 € par mois sans
compter les stock options brut oui j'ai
plus de brut net enfin sans compter les
stock options
ça fait des salaires à 3 4 5 millions
d'euros donc euh ça c'est quelque chose
j'aime pas trop parler de ça j'en parle
jamais mais puisque vous me posez des
questions puis c'est une interview
vérité pu autant dire la vérité parce
que j'ai pas à en rougir mais je trouve
que c'est quelque chose que les gens
devraient se poser comme question en
regardant tel ou tel en disant ce
monsieur ou cette dame qui brigue mes
suffrages s'il faisait pas ça qu'est-ce
qu'il ferait moi je peux dire en
conscience et tout le monde le sait
c'est que si j'avais pas fait de la
politique j'aurais été beaucoup moins
emmerdé dans ma vie j'aurais pas eu des
des des des des des des des trucs
horduriers qui me sont tombés dessus
j'aurais pas eu j'aurais gagné mais
infiniment plus mais incroyable vous
auriez fait quoi avec tout cet argent ça
c'est autre chose ça c'est une bne vous
savez c'est un proverbe Rome je crois
qu' dit on n jamais vu un homme ilant
trop d'argent Mo j'aurais trouvver
sonement à le dépenser mais au passage
c'est quand même aussi une bonne
question parce que peut-être financé
sview d'ailleurs on en profite pour
demander à not communauté soutenez-nous
sur tipi c'est grâce à vous qu'on est
indépendant qu'on peut faire une
interview avec qui on veut quand on veut
le temps qu'on veut François c'est ça fa
c'est une petite une petite incise
puisque l'occasion se présente on l'
fait en décontracté ce soir alorsou
ouais je considère d'accord je considère
je suis pas contre la l'enrichissement
des gens ça fait partie de la société
bon les ça motive les gens donc je pense
que dans une société humaine l'effort
individuel doit être récompensé les gens
doivent pouvoir gagner d'argent même
beaucoup d'argent je ne suis pas je fais
pas la chasse au riches c'est quoi
beaucoup mais c'est ça le problème
c'est-à-dire
que quelqu'un qui gagne mettons 2 3
millions d'euros par an 5 millions
d'euros tout net arrêtez bon 2 3
millions d'euros par an c'est énorme
c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus que ce que
je gagne c'est quelqu'un des desisé
c'est quelqu'un qui peut avoir je sais
pas qui peut s'acheter un château qui
peut s'acheter un une une belle une
belle voiture qui peut s'acheter une
villa en Grèce et qui peut acheter à sa
femme une rivière d'avement ou si c'est
une femme elle peut acheter à son mar
Lamborghini ne faisons pas de sexisme
bon c'est des gens c'est des gens très
riches qu'est-ce qui veut ce genre de de
chose les gens très riches mais ce que
je voudrais vous dire c'est que il y a
les gens très riches et puis y a les
gens ultra ultra riches vous en
connaissez écoutez je regardais vous
savez en France il y a à peu près 45
personnes qui ont une fortune supérieur
à 1 milliard
d'euros sur 65 million d'habitants et
vous avez
euh une quinzaine de personnes qui ont
une fortune supérieure à 10 milliards
d'euros et là je pense qu'il y a un
problème je pense qu'il y a un problème
parce que là on a plus à faaire à
quelqu'un de très très riche on a
affaire à des personnes qui ont une
richesse tellement colossale un Bernard
Arnaud qui est l'un des hommes les plus
riches du monde et cetera que ils ont un
patrimoine alors je sais qu'une grande
partie de ce patrimoine c'est des
immobilisations dans des pas d'accord je
le sais mais enfin ils ont quand même
voilà ils se servent des des dividendes
je crois que c'est la les propriétaires
de de de de de groupe Casino qui se sont
servis un milliard d'euros de dividendes
pour l'année enfin quelque chose comme
ça donc il se servent quand même des
dividendes absolument considérables qui
sont taxés oui qui sont taxés mais ce
que je veux dire c'est quelqu'un qui a
une fortune qui se chiffre en dizaines
et dizaines de milliards d'euros vous
êtes jaloux non je suis pas jaloux je
suis je suis inquiet sur les
conséquences de ça c'était la la la la
veuve de Mao Chang Ching qui était la
qui était une une actrice maoong avait
été son 4e mari et et elle ça avait été
sa 4e femme pierre
détends-toi et Chang Ching avait été
incarcéré après la après la mort de Mao
après la chute de la M DESC je sais pas
si vous connaissez cette histoire de
l'époque de de la Chine
contemporaine parce qu'elle était hie en
fait par la population C était des
espèce de gauchiste voilà et le peuple
chinois voulait en finir avec la
l'utopie maoïe et a massivement
approuvver la prise de pouvoir par
l'équipe de de denging de Deng saoping
euh et changing il avait dit qu'il y
avait trois choses dans la vie qui qui
étaient les trois choses les plus
importante de la vie c'était euh le sexe
l'alcool l'argent non non non c'était le
sexe l'argent et le pouvoir et et elle
avait dit la seule chose entre ces trois
tonton se lasse jamais c'est le pouvoir
c'est drôle voilà vous connaissez la
maladie du pouvoir c'est quoi la maladie
du pouvoir je pose la question mais ce
que je veux dire laissez-moi terminer
mon raisonnement c'est que quelqu'un qui
a énormément
d'argent il y a un moment à partir
duquel bon si vous voulez imaginez que
imaginez que demain vous gagnez au loto
avec 150 million d'euros un riche pauvre
voilà vous ach 150 millions d'euros
voilàah vous vous achetez vous achetez
un château vous achetez
nontera pas de Château V à sa on fera on
fera ni la ville à Saint-Bart on fera
retaper le pressoir qui est au centre
duage on fera refaire les bordures des
champs on va soutenir toutes les les les
familles en difficulté du villageou si
vous voulez ça ça ça ça sera ça sera
rien par rapport à ce que vous aurez ça
sera très peu de choses si vous
dépenserez peu de chose oui mais si vous
avez non pas 100 millions comme comme au
loto si vous gagnez le grand le gros lot
mais si vous avez
même pas 100 million ni même milliard ni
même 10 milliards si vous avez 100
milliards il y a un moment à partir
duquel vous ne savez plus comment
utiliser votre argent si ce n'est que
prendre le pouvoir et c'est un une
grande problématique du monde
contemporain c'est que regardez ce qui
s'est passé en
Russie avec Poutine Poutine il a été
obligé de casser les
oligarques qu'est-ce qui se passe de
prendre un peu sa commission
je suis pas poutini les gens qui me
reprochent d'avoir les valises de
Poutine c'est bien c'est c'est c'est ça
c'est bien sûr c'est Poutine c'est bien
je sais bien que c'est quelqu'un qui a
la main ferme bon
mais ce qui m'énerve aussi là-dedans
c'est que bon c'est la Russie he vous
savez vous lisez le livre de astolf
astolf c'est joli comme pr astolf de
Custine le marquis de Custine la Russie
en 1835 allez lire il est allé en Russie
en 1835 ou 1839 enin c'est une des deux
dates il décrit la Russie sous Nicolas
1er on lit cet ouvrage on a l'impression
que c'est la l'URSS de
Staline vous avez des vous avez des des
fondamentaux dans les peuples voilà la
Russie ça a toujours été le pays du knou
pays d'Exar c'est c'est pas une
démocratie c'est comme ça de même que la
Mésopotamie c'est le pays de
nabucodonosaur et de Saddam Hussein ça
n'a jamais été une démocratie il faut
quand même se retirer de la tête l'idée
que les peuples serait interchangeable
et que la démocratie serait quelque
chose qui s'appliquerait naturellement à
tous les pays du monde même en France
d'ailleurs on a des particularités la
France est un pays qui est resté dans
son tréfond éminemment monarchique
éminemment monarchique c'est c'est
quelque chose d' on a absolument pas du
tout la même conception du pouvoir que
ce que l'on va trouver dans chez les
Vikings eux qui sont des sociétés
extrêmement démocratiques hein vous êtes
en Suède vous êtes au Danemark vous êtes
en Norvège le ministre il est dans un
bureau paysagé vous avez un ministre je
plus céit le cas en Suède ou je qui
avait acheté une barre chocolatée avec
une carte du ministère elle a été obligé
de démissionner ce qui est normal mais
Ben en France c'est pas considéré du
rendez compte rendez compte vous avez
écouté la la la viceministre la vice-
première ministre suédoise qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit qui rabrouer un petit peu la
politique énergétique allemande oui elle
est extraordinaire cette FO oui elle
elle elle invoqua les lois de la
physique pour faire comprendre aux
Allemands oui leur mauvais chemin oui il
y a il y a il y a une chaque peuple assz
pr nous en France on a regardez un des
échecs de Barnier par exemple que je
pense que Barnier oui Michel Barnier je
pense qu'un de ses é une des raisons de
son échec c'est qu'il a été trop
respectueux vis-à-vis de
Macron je pense je pense qu'il était là
tétanisé il faut être il faut être
respectueux de notre président non mais
c'est notre homme charismatique notre
homme providentiel non mais vous voyez
ça c'est vraiment un état d'esprit
regardez ce qui s'est passé en Corée du
Sud en Corée du Sud vous avez un
président la République a décrété l'état
d'urgence l'armée n'a pas suivi il l'a
rapporté
si 12h après il vient d'être dtitué par
le Parlement y compris ses propres
députés là en Corée du Sud mais nous
vous croyez pas que ça serait le grand
temps de destituer Macron depuis nous on
a fait un dossier sur moi j'ai fait un
dossier qui je peux faire l'avocat du DI
allez-y pourquoi vous voulez embêter
notre cher homme providentiel il nous a
offert 7 ans de vacances bon ça nous a
coûté un peu de
950 milliards h oh il a créé quelques
entreprises zombes mais c'était des
vacances c'est grand frais pourquoi vous
voulez nous ennuyer avec notre homme
providentiel qui flatte la caste des
boomers
ouais en tout cas moi ce que je vois
c'est que là aujourd'hui même où on
parle c'est vraiment en train de partir
dans le décor vraiment vraim pourquo
vous pensez ça parce que on a eu un
ministre de l'Économie extraordinaire
arrêtez arrêtez fait l'avoc ou oui c'est
du diable c'est l'avocat de enfin
j'allais dire un gros mot non non c'est
pas l'avocat du diable mais c'est non
non non ce que je je suis j'ai été
éberluer moi par la déclaration de
Madame Le Pen moi je suis un homme libre
moi je dis ce que je pense moi je trouve
que Madame Le Pen elle a eu raison de
censurer Barnier pourtant j'avais dit
lorsque Barnier était arrivé
laissons-lui sa chance il y a des gens
qui m'ont volé dans les plumes ouais
quoi vous encensz bar jamais on sensé
Barnier Barnier il éta arrivé il y avait
un moyen de le de le coincer c'était ça
que je voulais
c'est que au moment de la recherche des
investitures des républicains en 2021 il
avait fait cette déclaration
inimaginable il avait dit que pour
régler les problèmes migratoires on ne
pourrait pas régler les problèmes
migratoires en France qui posait tant de
problèmes à 75 % des Français sans
sortir des articles 67 77 et 78 du
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne plus de la jurisprudence de
la C juu plus de la jurisprudence de la
CEDH rappelez-vous ça avait fait un
énorme scandale cudh c'est la cour
européne des droits de l'homme et la CGU
c'est c'est cour justice de l'Union
européenne à Luxembourg le cdH est en
n'étant pas une institution de l'Union
européenne c'est au-delà ça a fait un
énorme scandale rappelez-vous le
lendemain ou sur lendemain le journal
Libération a
titré Barnier de points ouvrez les
guillemets l'Élysée vaut bien un
frxit reprenant vous savez la la parole
prêtée à Henri Paris vaut bien une messe
voilà c'est-à-dire que Barnier qui était
considéré à l'p comme un européiste
grandtin il avait été commissaire
européen vice-président de la Commission
européenne négociateur du brexit d'un
seul coup il était on l'a accusé de
vouloir le frexit et il lui est arrivé
ce ce qui m'arrive depuis 18 ans bientôt
c'est-à-dire d'un seul coup les crucifis
les pattes de lapin il a été diabolisé
et cetera tout monde Touré d est-ce que
vous avez cartographié les gens qui vous
diabolise bah je pense que les
gens vous savez je d'abord je j'ai l'âge
d'être il y a encore 20 ans j'aurais été
très embêté angoissé avez quel âge
comment vous avez quel âge ben je finis
en 57 je l'ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai
l'âge du traité de Rome donc j'ai 67 ans
et euh c'est le Bel Âge d'ailleurs pour
devenir président de la République hein
vous savez de Gaul il avait 68 ans en
1958 c'est là où il avait dit est-ce que
vous croyez que j'ai je vais je vais
devenir j'ai une vocation de dictateur à
68 ans voilà euh mais là on retombe sur
la conversation précédente
pour diriger un état il faut avoir de
l'expérience de l'ancienneté de la
connaissance des hommes il faut il faut
avoir du sang froid le sang froid il
vient aussi avec avec l'âge on sa on on
a tellement vu regardez les grands chefs
d'État de notre époque regardez je
considère que Trump il est un peu
fantasque mais c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui possiblement on va voir ce
qui va se passer mais possiblement est
en train de modifier le cours des
événements d' l'histoire mondiale
regardez Poutine il a 70 ans Trump pass
78 si Jin ping en
7 bien sûr qu'il a des des
contreexemples mais moi si vous voulez
Nicolas Sarkozi oui ben qu'est-ce que
vous voulez Nicolas
Sarkozi alors là je n'ai pas la le seul
critère bien sûr je suis je suis
d'accord mais l'idée que l'on va
avoir ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a qui
me désole en fait quand je vois le débat
public et aut c'est que les lesécrasante
majorité de nos compatriotes sont quand
même encore très fascinés par les médias
les les médias il y a une espèce de
d'ambivalence vis-à-vis des grands
médias ce qu'on appelle les mainstream
c'est que à la fois il y a de plus en
plus de gens qui considère qu'il sont
qu'on leur m que ces médias leur mentent
et cetera et qu'il n'y croi plus mais à
la
fois voilà il vous savez c'était une
psychanalyste américaine je crois Alice
Miller qui avait écrit un truc qui
s'appelait je sais bien mais quand même
je sais bien que le Père Noël n'existe
pas mais quand même il existe croyz en
Dieu oui oui vous avez un ami imaginaire
un comment un ami imaginaire un ami
imaginaire vous vouz dire un ange
gardien quelque chose comme ça je sais
pas vous parlez à quelqu'un non à
moi-même non j'ai ma petite voix
intérieure comme tout le monde enfin
comme beaucoup de gens je pense non je
suis quelqu'un de je suis quelqu'un de
très consciencieux revenons à François
Hollande mais m'en fou m'en fout de
François Hollande François Hollande il a
été c'est un type qui qui a été euh fin
non mais François c'était pas lui qui
était prévu celui qui était prévu
c'était dominiic stroskanan
rappelez-vous et puis il y a eu
l'affaire de la de Nafiatou Dialo de
l'affaire de la de la de la de la douche
dans le dans le sopitel New York on ne
sait pas très bien qui est derrière
toute cette opération c'est dominiic
stroscan quand même hein il est pas
tombé tout seul hein oui oui sans doute
mais bon bref non parce qu' il y a des
théories du complot derrière tout ça bon
je n'en sais rien en tout cas ce ce qui
est certain c'est que il a été écarté et
qu'il a fallu trouver en urgence
l'oligarchie avait prévu que ce soit
Dominique stroscan d'ailleurs on on en
profite dominique je t'ai envoyé un sms
pourquoi tu ne nous réponds pas François
continue donc euh il a c'est c'est
Hollande qu'on a sorti d'un chapeau euh
pour succéder rappelez-vous comment ça
s'est passé mais Hollande tout le monde
sait qu'il était pas pourquoi n'a pas
sorti Françoise
Linot vous savez je suis connu
maintenant comme le loup blanc dans tout
ce petit monde la légende peut-être une
légende
euh on par un pe dans tous les sens mais
je puisque vous me tendez la per je vais
vous dire une
anecdote quelque chose qui m'a convaincu
vraiment qu'un jour tout ceci exploserai
c'est que j'ai servi des ministres j'en
ai servi plusieurs
euh Gérard Longuet j'étais quand je dis
service et que j'étais à leur cabinet
Gérard Longuet Ministre de l'Industrie
des Postes et Télécommunications et du
commerce extérieur
du gouvernement baladure j'ai ensuite
été directeur de cabinet de Madame
Françoise de panafieux ministre du
Tourisme sous le gouvernement jupéen et
ensuite j'ai été conseiller pour les
affaires internationales sur toute
l'Asie l'océan l'Amérique latine et les
questions économiques der de charrette
aux Affaires étrangères et puis j'ai
connu quelques autres responsables
politiques il y a quelque chose qui m'a
toujours frappé c'est
que au début connaissait pas moi j'avais
beaucoup évolué avec mon passage au
Japon etuis les années 80 et cetera de
telle sorte que la première fois que
j'ai voté en 1979 j'étais étudiant à
CHUS j'avais voté pour Simon veille
j'étais très proeopéen ce qui prouve bon
j'étais mainstream voilà moi je croyais
que c'est de l'Europe c'était de la paix
c'était sympa des cheveux longs non j'ai
jamais eu les cheveux longs mais j'ai eu
des cheveux mais non j'ai jamais eu les
cheveux longs mais non moi j'étais j'ai
voté pour de Simon ve en 1979 parce que
parce qu'avec mes parents je le disais
tout à l'heure on avait voyagé en Europe
j'étais allé dans des familles j'avais
apprendre l'allemand à Regensburg en
Bavière j'étais allé à chantam dans les
Coast walls au Royaume-Uni pour parler
l'anglais et cetera dans les familles
voilà ça me paraissait naturel c'était
j'étais vraiment totalement victime de
la de la propagande et puis mon passage
au Japon et puis la suite des événements
et puis la campagne de Maastrich où j'ai
vu quand même comment tout ça était
manipulé d'une façon extraordinaire il
faut relire lire et relire le livre de
Serge Alimi dans les les nouveaux chiens
de garde où on faisait débattre pour le
référendum pour ou contre mrich on
faisait débattre des gens de droite qui
étaient pour le oui avec des gens de
gauche qui étaient pour le oui moi je
trouvais ça hallucinant j'ai compris que
la droite et la gauche était de façon
peut-être provisoire mais en tout cas ne
voulait plus rien dire en fait le vrai
débat c'était plus en c'était pas entre
la droite et la gauche cétait entre ceux
qui acceptaient que la France
progressivement devienne vassale d'un
état continent sous la domination
américaine et ceux qui le refusaient bon
si avvez vu une architecture ù vous avez
vu une une convergence d'intérêt ben je
pense qu'on est dans la même situation
que que dans les années que dans les
années
40 c'est c'est une vieille histoire en
fait c'est les historiens du 19e siècle
qui avaient montré qu'il avaient bien
distingué entre le Parti national et le
parti de l'étranger comme on disait sous
la 3e république et c'est une histoire
queonrouve toujours vous avez come comme
en 1940 vous avez quand même eu une
partie de la droite
française avec qui se retrouvait avec
avec deg ou avec quelqu'un comme
destiendorve qui était un aristocrate de
de droite et puis vous aviez une partie
de la gauche française qui sont entrés
en résistance qui étaient patriotes qui
voulaient se rentrer en résistance mais
vous avez vous avez le reste bon qui a
collaboré bon je rappelle quand même que
ceux qu' on donn les plein pouvoirs à
Pétin à Vichi c'est quand même la la
chambre du Front populaire hein voilà
c'est c'est quand même les socialistes
qui ont majoritairement donné le et des
gens comme d'orot et cetera ou la Val
étaent des gens d'origine radical
socialiste ou de gauche
bon donc c'est la gauche et la droite
c'est et et et qu'estce qui s'est passé
au moment de Maastricht c'est que ceux
qu'on voté non c'était la droite incarné
par le rassemblement national plus enfin
le Front national à l'époque plus une
partie des des des gens qui avaient
appelé à voter NON à Maastricht
comme Philippe ségin Charles pasquis et
à son âme à leurs âmes contre contre
Chirac et puis de l'autre côté vous
aviez le Parti communiste français qui
avait appelé aussi à voter non on
retrouve en fait la même alliance qu'il
y a eu en 1954 entre le l'goliste et le
Parti communiste français pour faire
échouer la Communauté européenne de
défense voilà et je pense qu'à notre
époque c'est encore la même chose voilà
c'est pour ça que j'ai créé un parti
politique d'ailleurs on on y reviendra
tout à l'heure qui prend un soin jaloux
à ne pas à essayer de tout faire pour ne
pas être classé à droite ni à gauche
d'ailleurs nous sommes classés en divers
par le ministère de l' intérieur et nous
avons parmi nos adhérentss et nos
militants on a des gens qui viennent
absolument de partout de la droite mais
aussi de la gauche hein ça je le dis je
le dis je le dis toute tout tout de
suite mais laissez-moi terminer parce
que ce que j'avais dit était quand même
intéressant c'est que je n'ai pas
terminé mon histoire c'est que les
minist si tu me redis que je ne te
laisse pas terminer ça va ber non non
mais parce que j'aime bien
terminer mon
propos quand j'étais avec des ministres
qu par on partait on partait on faisait
un vol euh j'étais à côté de mon
ministre pendant 12h 14h de vol pour
aller en première oui avec notre argent
ah alors c'était le le billet d'avion
était payé en première pour le ministre
et pour les membres de cabinet il était
en en classe affaires et pour les
membres des administrations en classe en
classe
Économie
et vous vouz rentrer dans les détails
moi c'était comme ça de mon temps je ne
sais pas ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui ils
sont Falcon pour aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
à l'époque à l'époque il y avait
l'officier de sécurité censé protéger le
ministre qui protègeit le ministre qui
était de tous les déplacement qui lui
avait donc un siège en première à côté
du ministre voilà sauf que les ministres
que j'ai servi en règle générale bah il
demandait à l'offici de sécurité si
pendant la durée du vol il voulait bien
avoir la gentillesse de passer en en
classe en classe àire et moi de faire
venir parce que ils aimaient bien
discuter avec moi et pourquoi d'ailleurs
ils aimaient bien discuter avec moi
parce que je leur disais des choses que
personne nousait leur dire c'est ça qui
était qui m'a vraiment fasciné c'est que
je leur disais moi j'ai toujours conçu
le fait que j'avais réussi les concours
difficiles je pensais que la noblesse
d'un haut fonctionnaire d'un inspecteur
des finances c'est quelqu'un qui doit
dire à quelqu'un à un ministre dans le
secret de son cabinet pas le clamer sur
les toits mais de dire un ministre
monsieur le ministre vous avez tort
monsieur ministre là ça va pas ça ça là
on va on va c'est comme ça que j'ai
toujours conçu mon truc bon et y compris
de dire de dire tous les mé faits de la
construction européenne de dire que
l'euro parce que j'avais quand même déjà
beaucoup réfléchi à ça j'étais quand
même dans dans des cabinets de ministre
qui savait que j'étais que que ce que je
pensais et je leur disais ça mais ce qui
m'a
vraiment convaincu d'avoir
raison parce qu'au début je développais
des idées je m'attendais à ce queon
m'explique mais non pour tel tel état
moi je suis un être rationnel donc on
j'aurais trouvé des gens qui trouvaient
qui m'expliquaient par A + B que ce que
je disais était une hnerie mais j'aurais
dit bon d'accord oui j'urais réfléchi
mais j'urais dit oui parce que je suis
capable de changer la vie il y a pas il
y a que les imbéciles qui changent
jamais la vie mais moi je dis je dis
fondais des
idées et j'avais face à moi
rien j'avais des ministres qui était qui
trouvait que ce que je disais était très
intéressant mais on arrivait on
descendait de l'avion il y avait laass
press AFP et cetera monsieur le min et
paf il prenait le masque de du ministre
européiste et donc c'est c'est ce que
j'ai découvert si vous voulez dans les
années 90 du 20e siècle j'ai acquis la
conviction absolue que vous avez une
idéologie d'État et lorsque les classes
dirigeantes en fait n'y croi même pas
elle-même elles font semblant d'y croire
parce que vous avez c'était je crois
qu'il y avait un proverbe en URSS qui
disait si tu veux pe si tu veux pas
avoir de problème P ta cotisation voilà
il fallait être comme Conseil de l'Ordre
voilà voilà c'est exactement ça
c'est-à-dire que les les les dirigeants
français ont engramé l'idée que il faut
se dire pro-européen d'ailleurs c'est ce
que shirac avait c'est ce que mit avait
dit à shirac que shirac d'ailleurs avait
rapporté parce que c'est pas quoi qui me
l'a raconté en tête à tête qui m'a dit
miteron a dit rendre des compte François
mit Teron il a dit à Chirac qui me l'a
rapporté on ne peut plus être cand on ne
peut plus êtrelu président de la
République si on est contre l'Europe
c'est ce que miteran avait dit à shirac
en 1984 parce que Chirac 1978 vous savez
l'appel de de Cochin rappelez il fait un
appel qui était rédigé par euh comment
s'appelle-t-il pierre juyet qui était la
la la le le l'oncle de d'Alain Juillet
aujourd'hui mais Pierre juillet qui
était vraiment un vrai égoliste avec la
petite main qui était à l'époque
marieance garot bon et son voilà et et
et mariefance garot qui nous a appris un
mot le mot
forfaiture oui et on a eu l'étymologie
de du mot
forfaiture pai à son âme euh Marie
France garot qui était je l'ai bien
connu enfin assez bien connu mais elle
était elle éit très intelligente elle
était très très méchante aussi elle
était ça va de per souvent non oui mais
il faut avoir alors puisque si on croit
en Dieu faut aller au-delà faut avoir
l'intelligence de pardonner il faut être
un petit peu plus mais elle a dit elle a
eu des choses m'autorisé à vous
recentrer un petit
peu oui quand j'aurais terminé mon
propos parce que mon propos c'est que
quand vous avez une classe
politique qui qui a une idéologie d'État
et euh en fait qui n'y croit pas vous
pouvez être sûr que l'idéologie est
morte voilà c'est aussi simple que ça
donc ça prendra le temps que ça faut
mais en fait ils n'ont pas d'argument
contre ce que je dis et surtout que j'ai
affuté mes arguments depuis des années
voilà et face à quelqu'un qui je pose un
vrai problème si je disais des conneries
si j'étais que si j'étais le je sais pas
ce que je disais c'était du Cendrine
Rousseau des des trucs comme ça c'est
gratuit elle est pas là pour se défend
Nathalie l'oiseau non plus elle est pas
là pour se défendre non plus non non on
nattaque pas les gens qui sont pas là
bon d'accord alors on nattaque pas mais
enfin disons si ce que je disais était
bête VO si je faisais rigoler tout le
monde bah on m'inviterait largement pour
discréditer mais le problème qu'il y a
c'est pas moi qui c'est un un
journaliste célèbre qui m'a dit ça il y
a nombreux a quand même pas mal
d'annéesant une bonne dizaine d'années
j'avais créé lupère depuis quelques
années un jour il m'a dit en tête à tête
il m'a dit vous savez pourquoi on vous
on vous pas on vous invite pas alors je
m'attendais à ce qu'ils me disent vous
comprenez parce que l'Europe c'est quand
même la paix c'est quand même enfin les
les les les les comment dirais-je les
moulin prière tibétains habituel de
l'européisme l'Europe c'est la paix
alors qu'on voit le contraire on voit
que l'Europe est en train de nous
entraîner dans la trème guerre mondiale
et donc il me dit vous savez pourquoi
vous invite pas j'ai mais non je lui dis
vous allez me le dire il m'a dit parce
qu'on ne sait pas quoi vous
répondre c'est CIT qui ce journaliste
beaucoup qui sont morts hein donc non il
est pas mort il a même il fait même plus
en fait il ne fait même pas de euh il
n'est plus journaliste il fait de la
politique c'est il est assez connu dans
le sud de la France du côté de Bézier
Robert
Ménard c'est sourcé ça ah ben il l'a dit
c'est c'est moi qui vous le dit revenons
revenons on essaie de se vous avez fini
ah ben oui mais je suis là pour répondre
à vos questions d'accord revenons à vous
êtes assistant de ministre vous servez
votre
Ministre prenons la situation actuelle h
on a un trou de 100 milliards dans notre
budget h on a perd du pied en Afrique on
a perdu pied dans les relations
diplomatiques on a une Europe où ça
commence à se tirer dans les pattes non
ça commence pas ça continue ça ça n'a
pas arrêté de se tirer dans les PES
depuis depuis 67 ans retire donc là on
voit qui est-ce qui est à poil oui bon
disons que le phénomène comme disaient
des marxistes jadis les contradictions
sagrav
voilà si vous étiez en en charge de la
fonction suprême vous feriez quoi et
d'abord je ferais je serais élu sur un
programme très clair vous ran Branco
serait dans votre équipe mais j'en sais
rien moi je ne connais pas d'ailleurs
j'ai vu il y a des gens en ce moment
c'est pour ça que je vous pose la
question bah oui mais je ne le connais
pas il y a des gens qui euh me parle
beaucoup de de Dominique de Villepin que
je connais euh de Ran Branco que je ne
connais pas VO et donc j'ai dit ben
est-ce que vous vouriez faire alliance
avec CR Branco je d mais je connais pas
mais je dis mais qu' moi je veux bien
l'inviter sur pr TV et puis j'ai vu
qu'il a répondu d'accord donc là est en
train de prendre contact avec son équipe
et puis on va essayer d'organiser un
truc début début janvier mais moi je
suisors si il y a des gens qui m'ont
fait la réputation d'être le type qui
était enfermé dans sa tour d'ivoire mais
c'est tout le contraire Florient
Philippo il serait dans votre équipe
arrêtez avec ce truc là
pourquoi parce que j'en ai un peu assez
qu'on fasse toujours une espèce de du
qu'on me mettre dans un
duo j'ai créé un parti politique il y a
18 ans j'ai appelé tous les gens à me
rejoindre qui étaient d'accord et puis
depuis 10 ans après vous avez monsieur
Filippo et puis après toute une série on
en est au 32e personnage qui crée un
parti qui s'inspire du bienen chacun
disant que le prédécesseur à la melon ne
veut pas et cetera et créant son propre
truc mais c'est une histoire de dingue
voilà arrêtez de me parler de Philippo
demandz à Kuzmanovic tiens ce qu'il
pense de Philippo demander à Philippe
Murer ce qu'il pense de Philippo
demander à à Juvin Brunet ce qu'il pense
de de Philippo enfin je dire il y a pas
qu' y a pas que moi non tout ça c'est
c'est c'est du c'est du il
faut vraiment je pense comprendre que la
situation elle est extrêmement grave
quels sont les dangers que vous avez
identifié à court moyen et long terme
ben le moi je n'ai pas arrêté de le dire
j'ai fait des vidéos là-dessus euh il y
a un risque vraiment précis et qui n'est
pas immédiat mais qui est à à moyen
terme et même court moyen terme qui
d'explosion du pays oui parce que euh
c'est l'Europe des régions est une arme
fatale d'ailleurs vous avez peut-être vu
que là euh il y a euh j'ai vu que Beyrou
euh a été approché par la je sais plus
quoi la la Fédération euh de je sais
plus quoi des des il y a des gens qui
disent qu'il faut que Beyou relance les
langues
régionales actuellement la France est en
pleine dégringolad c'est Stéphan
séjourné qui va présider non le
président de ça c'est un qui s'appelle
alphonsie je crois que j'ai j'ai vu et
la France est en pleine dégringolade on
a des problèmes d'unité nationale alors
c'est quoi des gringolad B des gringolad
économique dans tous les domaines
industrie recherche agriculture langue
et rayonnement international présence en
Afrique présence dans le
monde la dignité même de la fonction
plus personne n'écoute la France hein
plus personne n'écoute la France c'est
devenu un tu peux me faire l'avocat du
diable
difficile tout va bien il y a pas de
sang dans les
rues ça vous pouvez pas dire ça il y a
toujours de l'électricité dans les
lampadaires non il y en a pas à Mayotte
ah vous êtes dur il y a plus d'aut
ni nourriture ni et puis puis on leur
sert une bouteille d'eau une boîte de
thon une BO je sais pas quoi bout de 2
heur mais le scandale c'est pas qu'il a
eu qu' a eu un cyclone à
Mayotte le scandale c'est pas qu'il a eu
un cyclone à Mayotte le scandale c'est
que depuis des années et des années moi
je suis allé à Mayotte il y a plusieurs
années o ça hein où ça où ça à baotte où
ça bah à mamouzou partout j'ai fait le
tour de l je suis allé à la plage des
des baobab je suis allé et vous y avez
été en vélo en voiture vous dormiez où
non non mais c'était pas c'était que
j'étais allé c'était dans le cadre de à
l'occasion ça-être des européennes de
2019 je pense que j'étais allé à l'île
de la Réunion pour pour faire notre
campagne parce que la Réunion c'est
quand même le 12e département le plus
peuplé de France maintenant c'est
quelque chose de très très important et
j'en avais profité pour aller à pour
aller à à Mayotte que je ne connaissais
pas et que c'était intéressant et je me
rappelle très bien d'avoir beaucoup
circulé j'ai passé 4 5 jours j'avais été
hébergé par un nos adhérentss
et j'avais été sidéré par par la
situation voilà parce que c'est un pays
qui
est ENF dans dans l'outrem français on
est quand même en France là on est quand
même dans une situation presque de
nature coloniale il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ne parlent pas le français à Mayotte
alors que à la
Réunion dans dans dans tous les
départements d'outremer à peu près on
parle le français en plus de la langue
vernaculaire mais on parle le français
alors que à Mayot vous avez des ma il y
a deux langues à Mayot a le Nord et le
Sud et surtout il y a cet afflux
permanent de de de adimiré et j'avais
été reçu j'avais rencontré le colonel de
gendarmerie qui m'avait qui m'avait fait
un tableau très sombre de la situation
il m'avait dit officiellement alors
cétait à l'époque je en 2019 il m'avait
dit il y a officiellement 250000
habitants officieusement il y en a
500000 et il m'avait dit c'est affreux
il m'avit dit on voit arriver tous les
jours les les des immig des immigrants
clandestins avec les quoia quoiss ça
voilà il m'a dit que lui il avait été en
en hélicoptère et parfois c'est vous
savez c'est des trucs qui mettent 70
personnes dans un truc qui a un tir en
dos de 3 cm au-dessus de de de de
l'océan c'est le canal de Mozambique a
des fonds de 3000 m je crois donc il a
d'une houle extraordinaire il faut faire
traverser entre enent qui est l'île la
plus proche de Mayotte et donc vous
mettez 70 personnes là-dedans il y a un
risque de chavirer à très très important
vous discuté avec ces gens-là oui enfin
j'avais oui j'étais allé voir le CAD
est-ce que vous avez été à la campagne
il y a pas vraiment de campagne en c'est
petit quand même ouais un petit peu déjà
allé chercher des petits piéments à la
campagne un petit peu non j'étais allé
voir le
cadi le cadi c'est pas un cadis de
supermarché c'est le CAD cadi c'est un
un un juge musulman parce que il y a une
espèce de justice rendue de façon
traditionnelle par par des on est dans
le monde de l'Afrique de l'Est hein des
Comoriens et cetera et et donc je
reviens à mon propos connais le
gendarmerie il avait vu de ses yeux vus
des pauvres gens mourir sous ses yeux et
il m'avait dit mais vous savez est-ce
que vous savez que ce qu'il y a
derrière ben je lui dis comment ça ce
qu'il a derrière la misère économique ou
les passeurs oui oui mais il me dit il
me dit il me dit que le c'est les
command oui mais le problème c'est que
les command c'est un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde bon à mon avis la
France une responsabilité c'était une de
ses anciennes colonies mais vous savez
qu'il y a eu j'ai eu l'occasion de d'en
parler dans mon direct hier donc en fait
il faut connaître l'histoire des Comores
hein c'est même géographiquement je suis
pas sûr que ça soit exactement le même
archipel d'ailleurs parce que Mayot
c'est un c'est en fait une île basse
comme BoraBora par exemple avec un avec
un lagon alors que les îles avec la
grande commore enjoint et moie c'est
c'est des îles hautes avec il y a pas de
il y a pas de lagon il y a ou très peu
enfin en tout cas moins de lagon que
qu'à maotte mais surtout ils ont pas la
même histoire Mayotte ça a été un sultan
qui s'est donné en fait le sultan s'est
vendu quasiment à la France de
Louis-Philippe en 1800 dans les années
1840 je crois quelque chose comme ça bon
donc c'est devenu français à partir de
1840 alors que les autres îles sont
deevenue françaises sous la 3è
République 50 ans après donc c'est pas
du tout du tout du tout la même histoire
bon bref et donc ce colonel de
gendarmerie me dit mais comment est-ce
que vous savez comment ils font pour
venir ben j'ai dit viens en bateau mais
j'ai dit il me dit mais est-ce que vous
rendez compte mettre 70 personnes femme
et enfant à bord d' quissa quissa pour
traverser je sais plus combien 80 km du
Canal de Mozambique
avec des des des houles extraordinaires
ils font comment benah je dis je ne sais
pas mais il me dit ils ont il faut qu'il
met un très gros moteur Yamaha je dis ah
bon et me dit mais vous savez quand ils
arrivent à Mayotte on saisit le le
quissa quissa on saisit le moteur bah
oui mais dit mais vous savez ça coûte
très très cher un moteur donc c'est one
way c'est un seul un seul il s'est saisi
à l'arrivée je dis
oui il me dit mais mais qui c'est qui
paye je dis oui c'est pas bête ça c'est
un des pays les plus pauvres du monde
qui c'est qui fait venir à Mayotte des
moteurs Yamaha flamban neuf qui sont
peut-être pas fabriqués au Japon mais
peut-être je sais pas au Vietnam sous
licence japonaise ou j'en sais ou j'en
sais rien mais ça coûte très c'est des
trucs c'est pas c'est pas des
petitsbains c'est des gros trucs qui
est-ce qui paye qui est-ce qu' fait g
chemine ça qu'est-ce qu'il aimet alors
j'ai dit ben je sais pas et il me dit on
a envoyé des équipes vous avez à rjoint
des plages où il y a les qui ça quoi ça
comme ça qui sont rangés part je dis
mais c'est qui mais on le sait je dis
c'est qui ça
disait l'émirat du
Qatar il était sûr de ça ah bah c'est ce
qu'il m'a
dit mir du Qatar qui finance les
islamiste qui est notre grand copain qui
a payé le divorce de Sarkozi saufreur de
ma part
vous avez des sources ah bah allez
regarder taper sur internet que vousa du
Qatar qui a racheté le PSG qui a racheté
les les grands hôtels à Paris revenons
au mais c'est important ce que je dis
c'est très important le double jeu joué
comme par par un pays comme l'émirat du
Qatar qui bénéficie de son géant de
pétrole pour avoir qui a des ressources
énormes l'émirat du Qatar qui a sans
doute financé la la chute
de de Bachar alAssad pour ouvir
l'islamisme l'mirat du Qatar on été
hébergés les responsables du Hamas au
mois d'octobre dernier ils ont arrêté
leur coopération qui le Qatar avec le
Hamas
oui vous savez en 2017 pendant la
campagne présidentielle tout le monde
parlait de daesh de Isis et cetera et il
y a eu un jour il y a eu un débat avec
je crois qu'il y avait Laurence Ferrari
et comoutel CRIF il me semble de mémoire
et on était les 11 candidats
à un moment la la question est arrivée
sur daesh et cetera don tout le monde
fulminait contre les
islamistes et j'ai j'ai dit j'ai pris la
parole j'ai j'ai dit mais attendez qui
est-ce qui est derrière
daesh quelles sont les armes d'où ça
vient ce sont des armes occidentales et
qui sont financées notamment par le
Qatar il y a des preues de ça vous avez
des preuves de ça oui oui enfin des
preuves mais allez chercher et donc j'ai
dit mais allez prenez c'est quand même
drôle c'était dans cette c'est le moment
où j'ai fait rigoler là tout le monde
c'est que je me suis tourné vers Macron
on est en 2017 j'ai dit j'ai dit que
Monsieur Macron pourquoi vous ne dites
pas que derrière daesh il y a les
Américains d'ailleurs qui est-ce qui a
cassé daesh c'est la Russie et Isis faut
pas se tromper hein j'ai fait une vidéo
récemment pour montrer derrière les
Frères musulmans c'est les États-Unis
vous connaissez l'accord du quini entre
Roosevelt et le et le et et le fondateur
du roi habit c'est les Américains qui
tiennent à bout de bras l'Arabie
Saoudite qui est un qui est bref donc
j'ai dit à Macron à l'époque j'ai dit
mais monsieur Macron qu'est-ce que vous
entendez pourquoi vous ne dites pas ça
et Macron à l'époque sans doute
impressionné je sais pas par mon attaque
il dit mais je suis tout à fait charisme
je sais pas si on peut parler de
charisme mais il m'a dit mais je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous et c'est
là où j'ai dit oui de toute façon vous
êtes toujours d'accord avec tout le
monde et là tout le monde a rigolé vous
rappelez pas vous le trouverez
facilement sur internet ce petit passage
ça a été bon un petit moment de petit
moment de de de de de show sur le sur le
sur sur sur la télévision voilà mais ce
qui était drôle d'ailleurs c'est que
quand on est sorti de là pour la petite
histoire quand le les les l'émission
s'est arrêtée on avait on nous avait pas
encore retiré les
microcravates on commençait à sortir à
se lever à se diriger même pas vers la
sortie voilà on parlait on avait des
équipes chacun était avec ses équipes on
a vu s'afficher sur les écrans sondages
auprès des téléspectateurs le grand
vainqueur Emmanuel
Macron c'est incroyable il avait été
honnêtement il avait été très mauvais en
c'est incroyable j'avais pas été le
meilleur hein le meilleur je trouve je
trouve que celui qui avait qui avait été
le meilleur honnêtement Jean-Luc
Mélenchon oui honnêtement c'était
Mélanchon je trouve qu'il avait une
maîtrise c'est pas que je suis d'accord
avec lui avec tout tout ce qu'il est je
suis pas je suis pas en désaccord non
plus avec tout ce qu'il dit mais il y a
des choses qui dis Mélenchon qui sont
exact il en autres qui ne le sont pas
puis Mélenchon je rappelle qu'il veut
pas sortir de l'Union européenne
Mélenchon il a dit que ceux qui
voulaient sortir de l'euro étaient des
maréchalistes il a dit ça en 2000
maréchaliste pas Marion maréchal
maréchalist maréchal Pétin il a dit des
mots très très durs he Mélenchon donc le
programme de Mélenchon il ne peut pas
l'appliquer c'est là c'est ça que je que
que que pourquoi je lui en veux mais il
avait honnêtement il avait été il avait
été bon il y avait quelqu'un qui avait
qui avait fait son petit succès c'était
c'était poutou poutou avait pas il avait
eu il y avait pas d'immunité ouvrière
parce qu'on parlait des immunités
parlementaires il avait fait il avait
mis les pieds dans le PL en disant je
sais pas s'il y a une immunité
parlementaire en tout cas il y a pas
d'immunité ouvrière c'était pas mal
envoyé c'était c'était bien donc il y
avait des
euh voilà bon Fillon j'avais pas trouvé
très très extraordinaire moi je trouvais
j'avais pas été le meilleur mais j'avais
pas été le plus mauvais je trouvais que
j'avais été parce que c'est quand même
impressionnant quand vous faites ça la
première fois j'avais trouvé que j'avais
quand même pas été si mauvais que ça que
ça c'était pas mal passé mais j'avais
vraiment trouvé que Macron c'était
c'était c'était nul François quels sont
les autres dangers que vous avez
identifié à court moyen et long terme
pour la premièrement il y a l'explosion
de la France ça c'est à moyen terme
c'est la politique des eurorégions c'est
la politique vous savez c'est regardez
quelle a été le destin de de l'URSS
avant ou
après le le bilan de la construction du
socialisme qui s'étend sur l'empire
d'zar comme une marée quand il se retire
il détruit l'Empire d'zar qui a émietté
en en 1000 morceaux et ce que je crains
c'est que la construction européenne qui
a énormé ent de point commun c'est une
téléologie c'est une utopie une utopie
européenne et une téléologie c'est
téléos ça veut dire loin en grec c'est
voir un truc qui se on projette toujours
c'est dans l'avenir c'est l'horizon
indépassable de notre époque voilà mais
comme vous savez l'horizon il a une
particularité c'est quand plus vous vous
rapprochez plus il s'en va pu puis s'en
c'est le le le nom du parti d'ailleurs
de de Monsieur Édouard Philippe que l'on
veut nous vendre comme prochain
Président de la République c'est clair
l'oligarchie veut que ce soit que ce
soit Édouard Philippe donc
ce qui est à craindre c'est que lorsque
la construction européenne refluera et
qu'il y ait des vraiment des état qui se
désagrège et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'à
penser je pense les ce compenser les
élites britanniques sur le brexit parce
que il y a un point qui est très
important sur l'affaire du brexit c'est
que en France tous les dirigeants du
monde économique et cetera sont contre
le frxit bon t t ceux qui ont le droit à
la parole dans les médias tous les
dirigeants sont contre le frxit on nous
fait croire on nous fait on nous fait le
jeu vous savez le coup du violon c'est
que ce serait complètement irresponsable
de vouloir sortir de l'Union européenne
on oppose on nous oppose des
raisonnements de court terme pour inst
strucct structurel voilà c'est des gens
qui disent mais vous rendez compte si on
sortait de l'Union européenne cher ami
mais vous rendez compte les taux
d'intérêts qu'on pirait mais c'est pas
ser attaqué par les marchés non oui oui
et non on est on est attaqué par les
marchés en ce moment donc et puis si
vous voulez ça me fait penser les gens
qui me disent on peut pas faire le
frexit parce que vous rendez compte les
taux d'intérêt monrait c'est à peu près
du même niveau que quelqu'un qui serait
allé voir De Gaulle en 1943 44 en disant
écoutez arrêtez avec vos hisires de
résistance on peut pas sortir de là des
Allemands parce que si les Allemands
s'en vont ils font tourner le business
avec les l'armée d'occupation et puis il
va y avoir des bombardements on va on va
détruire des ponts et des autoroutes et
des compar l'Union européenne avec les
Allemands là je comprends pas bien parce
que c'est une espèce d'occupation la
France est sous
occupation vous savez ce que de Gaulle
avait dit ça c'est un truc qui il y a
des mots extraordinaires de De Gaulle en
on lit ouais non c'estit quelque chose
de plus en 1900 en
1964 pour le 6 juin 1964 il était à
l'Élysée on l'appelle non 6 juin non non
c'était le 20e anniversaire du
débarquement de Normandie et vous
trouverez ça dans le CT de Gaulle de
perfide et vous avez donc des ministres
qui qui viennent de le voir il avait été
approché par l'ambassade des
États-Unis le président américain Lindon
Johnson voulait venir et qui a un grand
raout en France sur les plages du
débarquement avec je sais plus quel
était le le le le le Premier ministre
britannique de du côté ça peut-être un
travaillé je me rappelle plus enfin 1964
et de Gaulle avait refusé de célébrer
les 20 ans du débarquement alors
Pompidou était Pompidou dit à perfide
allez le voir allez voir le général moi
je suis pas arrivé à
il veut pas en démordre donc perfide va
voir de Gaul et lui dit et ben mon
général quand même on peut pas ne pas
fêter le 20e anniversaire du
débarquement et et de GA dit mais
comment ça on peut pas fêter l'histoire
du débarquement c'était le prélude à une
seconde occupation de la France a-t-il
dit c'est terrible parce que les
Américains avaient décidé de maintenir
au pouvoir
Pétin l'aval et de sortir de Édouard
herot de son placard des traces de tout
ça ah oui là vous le trouvez à la fois
dans les mémoires de guerre c'est et
donc c'était de Gaulle de Gaulle dit à
perfit que c'était une anignance qui
avait été faite avec Alen dus qui était
de l'OSS avant la création de la CIA un
des de frèrees Deus qui était à Genève
et qui avait négocié ça avec Auto abet
qui était l'ambassadeur d'Hitler à Paris
voilà et donc l'idée c'était que les les
Américains voulaient maintenir Pétin
l'aval et euh et comment s'appelle-t-il
et je viens de dire le nom là à
l'instant Édouard herot d'en faire une
un les Américains ne voulaient surtout
pas de de Gaul c'est très très important
comprend parce que de Gaul d'ailleurs le
dit il savait qu' sil débarquait et qui
maintenait Pétin il aa rien à le refuser
il faut bien comprendre le double jeu
des vichistes toujours toujours toujours
toujours Édouard herot enfin Pétin il
recevait tous les matins à l'Hôtel du
Parc à à à Vichy l'ambassadeur des
États-Unis les États-Unis avaient
reconnu l'État français ils avaient pas
reconnu la France Libre c'était
Churchill qui avait reconnu la France
libre il y avait pas d'ambassadeur du
Royaume-Uni à à Vichi mais en revanche
si vous allez à Vichi aujourd'hui si
vous faites malheureusement il y a pas
de panneau bon il faudrait qu'il y ait
des panneaux pour expliquer aux gens
mais si vous si vous allez avec un
historien local il vous montrera le le
le lieu où il y avait l'ambassade des
États-Unis qui est de l'autre côté de du
parc et en face il a l'Hôtel du Parc où
il y avait Pétin et le gouvernement et
les États-Unis c'était l'amiral Liri qui
était un proche de de rousevelt et qui
était l'ambassadeur des États-Unis et
qui allait tous les lundis rconter Pétin
et qu'est-ce que Pétin disait il disait
en substance quand vous aurez débarqué
je me rangerai derrière vous c'était ça
le double jeu d'ailleurs Hitler se
méfiait beaucoup de de Pétin c'est pour
ça qu'il voulait mettre quelqu'un comme
Laval en qui il avait davantage
confiance et donc quant à Pierre Laval
lui-même il est allé en 1931 aux
États-Unis il était président du conseil
il a été the man of the year the time
Magazine 1931 allez regarder si ce que
je dis est vrai ou faux man of theer
Pierre Laval et Pierre Laval il avait
une fille unique qui s'appelait José
José Laval qui s'était marie avec René
de Chambrin et qui était une famille
auvergate qui était le fils du comte de
Chambrin mais son son père était un
auvergat qui s'appelait le compte de
Chambrin mais sa mère s'appelait Clara
longwor cétait une Américaine qui était
apparentée assez proche de Théodore
Roosevelt le président des États-Unis de
1917- 1918 et et qui avait également des
liens un petit peu plus distant avec le
président
Roosevelt ça c'est un des un des un des
innombrables n dit de la de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale c'est que
l'aval il était assez comment dire il
était assez confiant dans la suite des
événement parce qu'il se disait qu'il
arriverait toujours à rebondir à se
trouver quelqu'un qui permettrait de le
sortir de la panade voilà et ce que
voulaient surtout pas les Américains
c'était que de Gaulle soit arrive au
pouvoir c'est pour ça que de Gaulle
refuse le 6 juin 44 célébrer le le le le
didday et aujourd'hui quand on voit le
didday et cetera mais d'ailleurs on
disait pas le dday moi quand j'étais
jeun on parlait du jourgie maintenant
c'est le maintenant on a complètement
reconstruit l'histoire moi j'avais un
grand-père quand j'étais petit et qui
m'expliquait que ceux qui avaient cassé
Hitler ce à qui on vraiment devait
c'était les Russes c'est la vérité avec
la bataille de stalingrade puis la
bataille de
kskque puis la la l'opération les TR
revenons au 21e siècle je sais que quand
on ne connaît pas son histoire on est
condamné à la revivre diton celui qui ne
connaît pas son histoire et condamné à
la revivre c'est un dicton vous
connaissez votre histoire qu'est-ce
qu'on est en train de vivre maintenant
quels sont les dangers que vous avez
identifié pour la France celui que de
Gaul disait c'est que c'est que c'était
était une seconde occupation en fait la
réalité de la situation aujourd'hui de
la France c'est que nous sommes un pays
sous domination coloniale
arrive il nous arrive d'ailleurs
colonisé par qui on est une des rus
c'est une des ruses de l'histoire c'est
que qui nous nous pourvoie qui nous ruse
mais qui est-ce qui tient les médias qui
est-ce qui nous impose sa langue sa
culture sa sous-culture qui est-ce qui
nous fait vibrer de ces événements
intérieurs constamment qui est-ce qui
nous entraîne dans la guerre en Ukraine
contre la
Russie le Portugal non cherchez bien
l'Espagne non plus qui est-ce qui nous
non plus voilà c'est encore les Suédois
voilà les Autrichiens et là vous avez
vous toucher du doigt c'est les overnien
enc vous touchez du doigt l'un des
points aveugles de du monde
d'aujourd'hui notamment dans la droite
française c'est que moi je suis
j'inscris ma ma ma pensée dans le dans
le droitfil de celle de de gaaule pas
par vénération particulière de de gaaule
d'ailleurs mes parents étaient plutôt
des é plutôt quand j'étais jeune à la
maison Mo je sais que mes parents en
tout cas avaient voté non au référendum
de 1967 voilàup de 69 pardon qui nous
occupe pour vous on est sous occupation
des Portugais mental des États-Unis
d'Amérique notamment de l'État profond
voilà c'est quoi l'état profond l'état
profond c'est le le complexe militar
industriel le le toutes les entités du
style Commission Trilatérale du style le
le comment on appelle ça le Conseil
transatlantique ou Conseil atlantique
dont d'ailleurs monsieur benjaminad
était le responsable pour pour la France
c'est quand même incroyable le le les
état profonds c'est
leén est-ce que vous avez déjà pénétré
ce type de cercle est-ce que vous avez
déjà infiltré ou été invité est-ce que
vous connaissez ces gens-là vous avez
fait leur pédigré leur cercle 1 2 3
est-ce que vous avez vu qui fait quoi
qui les finance avant de donner de dire
VO ça c'est l'état
profond je peux pas dire que j'eni fait
parti parce que les gens m'ont connu
assez vite mais j'en ai vu j'en ai vu
des j'en ai vu des des des exemplaires
euh en live si vous voulez j'étais au
cabinet d'Hervé de charrette aux
Affaires étrangères et au cabinet
d'Hervé de charrett
euh qui savait très exactement ce que je
pensais des questions européennes
d'ailleurs mais il m'avait dit ça ne le
dérangeait pas puisque de toute façon je
m'occupais pas de ça dans son cabinet je
m'occupais de l'Asie l'Océanie
l'Amérique latine et des et des
questions économiques bon mesure bon ben
j'ai dis très bien parfait donc au moins
je je n'ai pas menti sur ce que je pense
mais dans ce cabinet il y avait parmi
les membres du cabinet il y avait une
jeune femme enfin une jeune oui elleait
ENF elle avait pas si jeune que ça mais
elle devait avoir dans les dans les 38
ans quelque chose comme ça JEE oui oui
c'est pas 25 bon et comme 67
et elle était elle était elle était
sympathique éta intelligenteelle avait
elle était raffinée elle était élégante
elle avait de la classe elle s'appelait
Salomé Zourab V
elle est aujourd'hui présidente qui
refuse de sortir de son poste de
présidente de
geéorgie on se tutoyait on se faisait la
bise et je je je je comprenais pas en
fait mais en fait cette femme j'ai
découvert ens suite donc elle elle
s'occuper des dossiers transatlanties
mais c'est quand même incroyable à la
réflexion parce qu'elle avait fait une
partie de ses études à Colombia
University elle sétait marié avec un
américain puis après ça plus son mari
est décédé je ne sais plus elle s'est
remarié en tout cas avec un geéorgien
qui travaillait pour Radio
radio Voice of America c'està-dire la
CIA en fait non mais vous pouvez pas
dire parce queelle elle a épousé un
Américain
queous les Américains ne travaillent pas
pour la CIA oui mais celui qui travaille
un geéorgien qui qui est sper de Voice
of America si vous voulez pour à
l'époque de l'URSS pour balancer les
informations contre un bon accent oui
oui vous voyez le mal partout oui oui
non c'est non non vous trouvez des
logiques vous trouvez les faisceau de
présomption quand je vois honnêtement
c'est une femme que que que qui vraiment
que je je voilà je crois qu'elle
étaitelle était d'une d'une ascendance
elle était vous savez la la nièce je
crois de caros c'est la même famille
est-ce qu'elle travaillait
bien écoutez moi je m'occupais pas des
questions transatlantiques voilà ce que
je sais en tout cas c'est que la France
on n pas on avait pas des déjà sshira
qu'il avait déjà abandonné un certain
nombre de joyaux de la couronne
qu'est-ce qu'attend le reste du monde
pourquoi la France elle a pesé du temple
de Gaulle qu'on avait la bombe nucléaire
pas seulement c'est parce que la France
était un autre Occident c'est-à-dire que
ce qu'end les restes les autres peuples
du monde ils savent que la France c'est
plus la France 2014 qu'on a plus lené
mais ce qu'ils attendent de la France
ceux qui lui donnent du poids dans le
monde c'est que nous avons nous avions
je malheureusement on est presque obligé
de parler à l'imparfait maintenant nous
avons cette capacité à dire merde oui et
puis que nous sommes des Français
c'est-à-dire que nous avons on n pas du
tout la même vision du monde que les
Anglo-Saxons on a vraiment on n'a pas
les mêmes intérêts regardez ce qui est
passé au 19e siècle les histoires de
colonisation sont quand même importante
les pays que la France n'a pas conquis
c'est les Anglais qui l'ont conquis
réciproquement c'est une espèce et vous
savez c'est comme les Marquet tribou en
partie contrepartie oui ça c'est les
Portugais les Espagnols mais ça c'est
les colonisations antérieures mais il y
a eu cette lutte fchoda il y a eu la
lutte comme ça entre la France et
l'Angleterre et et vous avez donc des
vous avez aussi le fait que RoyaumeUni
c'est quand même une une puissance
maritime alors que la France bon la le
conflit du temps des guerres
napoléoniennes donc on a et puis on a on
n'est pas pareil on n'est pas pareil il
y a des il y a des fondamentaux sur
lesquels il faut revenir la langue la
langue maternelle une fois j'étais avec
charrette on était allé à Singapour le
Premier ministre de Singapour il
s'appelait gotchok tong bon mais il y
avait le Seigneur ministère c'était le
père fondateur de Singapour et qui lui
était très célèbre liquanu qui a été le
le père fondateur de Singapour et là il
s'était retiré il était plus Premier
ministre il avait pris la stratégie
chinoise très très ancienne ce qu'on
appelle l'empereur derrière le rideau ce
qu'avait fait dengoping lorsqu'il avait
laissé la la le la première place dans
les années 90 mais il avait pris le
poste de commission à la tête de la
commission militaire c'était en fait
l'empereur derrière le rdau qui fait qui
fait et donc on avait on était à all
voir l'quan avec avec Hervé de Charret
et Hervé de Charret nous avait avait eu
ce propos qui qui est trs intelligent il
avait dit que la chose la plus
importante au monde en fait disait-il
c'est la langue
maternelle parce que c'est c'est ce qui
formate l'opinion je vais vous prendre
la vision du monde un petit
exemple la langue française comme les
langues latines est une langue très
sexuée
masculin et féminin tout est masculin ou
féminin en français voilà en anglais
tout est neutre à part les avions et les
bateaux qui sont féminins mais tout est
neutre a man a woman a girl a boy a
plane donc vous avez un vous avez un
comment dirais-je un une
langue je dire l'actuel W culture
transgeun et cetera va très bien la
langue anglaise
é pose un vrai problème pour les pour
les peuples latins François quel était
ma question c'est exemple quelle était
ma question les problème de la France à
court moyen long terme à court terme la
mise sous tutelle en matière financière
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
calamiteuse ça va se matérialiser
comment benah ça va se matérialiser vous
avez vu comm m FMI troka et oui je pense
P vend des bijou de famille oui je pense
je pense il va falloir rééchelonner des
dettes alors il y a des gens qui disent
on a qu'à prononcer le concept de dette
odieuse bon en gros en gros qu'il faut
pas rembourser mais c'est répudié sa
dette oui mais le problème c'est que
répudier sa dette il y a deux de deux
conséquences énormes la première c'est
qu'après ça on est on est on est coincé
pendant regardez même les soviétique on
était obligé de donner un petit quelque
chose en
1993 je crois pour avec les empreuns
Russes ça avait duré depuis 1917 donc
ben vous avez des gens qui sont tenaces
même si ils ont remboursé un tout petit
peu de ce qu'il mais quand même ça ça a
perturbé les relations de la de l'URSS
puis de la Russie avec le monde
occidental pendant des années pendant
des décennies euh ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que bah il
va y avoir des gens spoliés parmi les
gens spoliés il y a à peu près 55 % de
notre dette extérieur qui sont possédés
par des noms nationaux de notre D
publicique sont possédés par des noms
nationaux mais il y a 45 % qui sont
possédés par des nationaux tous les gens
qui ont des une assurance vie par
exemple qui ont placé les Français qui
ont placé rentré dans une assurance vie
l'assurance vie en question elle a
souvent acheté des obligations
assimables du Trésor français donc ça
veut dire c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
vous comprenez c'est c'est c'est
extraordinairement difficile c'est même
impossible donc ça veut dire que il va
falloir euh avoir moi ce que je crains
beaucoup c'est en effet un scénario à la
grecque avec la être forcé de vendre des
des des du patrimoine de l'État on peut
même se demander d'ailleurs mais vous
allez dire que je suis complotiste compl
insirationnist mais on peut même se
demander d'ailleurs si ça n'est pas en
fait un des objectifs secrets qui avait
été fixé à Macron on s pas appisser les
yeux quand vous me dites ça là pour pour
parce que faire 900 milliards d'euros de
dettes en c'est délirant surtout pour ne
rien faire c'était des vacances oui non
c'est dingue on a m on a maintenu la
paix sociale on a maintenu la la note de
la France bon on a fait quelques petits
emprunts voilà mais regardez la Suède ou
la Biélorussie ce sont des pays d'Europe
la Suède oui mais pas très bien oui
pourquoi cette question en fait je
voulais continuer ma propre question que
je vous ai posé vous savez à court moyen
long terme je reviens alors à court
terme les questions financière question
financière votre épargne il est caché où
j'ai pas beaucoup d'épargne vous savez
il est en euro oui il est en Bitcoin non
j'aurais dû mais en action non non j'ai
justement tiens j'ai le fond d'assurance
vie un petit peu donc vous pensez que
euh euh on va on va taper dans lesépes
des
Français rien n'est impossible mais
quand même là je pense que la situation
est tellement Macron il Macron on est
dans
un on vit on est sur un volcan hein
Macron il est il est Oni vous avez vu à
Mayotte là Mayotte il s'est fait huer
siffler à Mayotte et et en France il
peut pas sortir sans avoir une carapace
de de de 30 m de gens autour de lui et
même vous avez eu les dernières
nouvelles c'est que Alexis CER le
secrétaire général et même Brigitte
Macron paraî-il disent que ça va plus du
tout dans sa tête c'est c'est des
signaux mais c'est des sign comportez
pas la calomnie mais non c'est c'est
c'est les dépêches de presse c'est les
dépêches de presse qui sont sorti
aujourd'hui ou hier il allez voir j'ai
fait un tweet d'Urs sur mon compte
twitter ti j'en profite allez sur mon
compte Twitter il j'ai repris cette
dépêche de presse c'est sorti dans le
point ou dans je sais plus quoi ou dans
l'Express P que ça va ça va s venimé ben
écoutez en ce moment en tout cas c'est
la catastrophe Beyou c'est je veux dire
c'est beou depuis qu'il a été nommé
c'est un sans faute mais sans faute cent
hein c'est-à-dire
oui bon il ne fait mais c'est incroyable
il ne fait tout est faux tout il a tout
faux depuis qu'il a été nommé c'est
incroyable première décision qu'il prend
alors que tout le monde sait sa que la
France le budget est subclaquant qu'on
est on est absumement endetté et cetera
que il prend un Falcon à 12000 € les 52
minutes de vol pour aller à à peau en
disant qu'il va rester maère de peau qui
va cululer les mandats mais c'est ce que
les jeunes appelle un combo quoi il fait
d'un seul coup il se met à dos tout le
monde les gens ne supportent plus qu'on
nous empêche de de de de prendre paril
qu'il faut plus avoir de voitures à à de
voitures comment dirais-je à moteur à
moteur et à essence et cetera ou
parce que sinon la planète va crouler et
paf il prend c'est dingue il 12000 € les
et puis pourquoi il et la première
priorité c'est de faire une loi pour
revenir sur le non cumule des mandats
mais c'est dingue et depuis lors tout
est faux et là aujourd'hui vous avez vu
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui même il a
sorti d'un chapeau brutalement qu'il
proposait il a fait venir tous les chefs
de partis politique présent au Parlement
donc évidemment je personnellement je ne
suis jamais mais donc tous les chîns de
partis politiques représent au Parlement
sauf le RN et LFI il les a fait tous
venir en disant je vous propose à tous
un poste dans le
gouvernement pas de programme rien donc
ça veut dire ils sont aux abois vous
avez lu le programme des autres les
propositions des
autres est-ce que vous avez lu ce qu'on
fait les communistes sur l'énergie mais
je vais vous dire j'ai la j'ai
l'honnêteté je suis quelqu je crois être
quelqu'un d'honnête intellectuellement
il y a des choses
bien dans beaucoup de trucs il y a des
choses que au rassemblement national des
choses avec lesquelles je suis d'accord
et avec le avec le PC il y a des choses
avec lesquelles je suis d'accvec
Renaissance c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle non Renaissance là c'est vrai
que là je coince beaucoup mais avec avec
LFI il y a des choses qui sont justes
avec ENF à mon avis bon part tout mais
il y a des choses qui sont exactes moi
je pense par exemple en ce moment il y a
une vrai un vrai vrai vrai problème
social en France non non mais c'est vrai
il y y a d'ailleurs on le voit la
consommation il a plus de consommation
donc là vous avez vu Lain vient de
prévoir au lieu de 1,2 % de croissance
en 2025 ce qui est déjà très très faible
on tombe à 09 parce qu'il y a plus de
croissance la consommation ne marche
plus les gens n'ont plus d'argent c'est
c'est la vérité et depuis des années
donc la priorité c'est d'abord de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat au français
on fait comment et ben on augmente le
SMIC mais le problème on augmente le
SMIC avec quel te je sais bien mais bah
ça c'est les entreprises qui payent mais
je sais bien ce qu'on non je sais bien
ce que vont me dire les chefs
d'entreprises
oui je sais bien ce qu'ils vont me dire
ils auront raison d'ailleurs ils vont me
dire qu'il y a trop de
chargeoci de cotisation ils vont me dire
qu'ils ont trop de paperasserie ils vont
me dire aussi qu'ils ne peuvent ils sont
pas concurrentiels face à l'étranger
vous avez déjà été chef d'entreprise non
enfin sauf si on peut dire que le parti
politique que j'ai créé est est une
entreprise c'est une petite entreprise
quand même on a créé 5in emplois et qui
est qui a 0 € d'emprunt 0 € de dette
voilà qui ne fonctionne qu'avec les
cotisations DEES ses adhérents avec un
budget je vous dis de l'ordre de 2
million d'euros par an quoi c'est ça
voilà combien d'adhérents ah ça c'est
toujours la la est-ce que vous avez
dépassé la fédération de
boule je sais pas combien il y a
d'adhérents à la Fédération de boule
mais il est c'est une question qui est
toujours difficile à répondre pour deux
pour plusieurs raisons la première
raison c'est
que les gens adhèrent à un parti pas
seulement chez nous ils adhèrent à un
parti politique qui versent l'gisation
quand il y a des élections
donc par exemple en 2017 quand j'étais
candidat à l'élection présidentielle on
était on est passé de 14000
adhérents au début de l'année à jour de
cotisation c'est même pas les
statutaires à 32000 35000 à la fin de
l'année céta c'estd qu'on avait mis on a
fait en en 8 mois ce que j'avais mis
depuis 2007 jusqu'à 2017 en 10 ans on a
fait en 10 mois plus d'adhésion que nous
en avions fait en 10 ans grâce à la
participation àélection présidentielle
voilà donc les gens ils adhèrent quand
il y a une élection quand il y a pas
d'élection les gens ont tardent à verser
leur cotisation ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est
que il y a il y a un vrai problème de de
bah de d'argent voilà c'est il y a des
gens qui tirent un peu le diable par la
queue et ils font des économies bon il y
a ça le troisième point c'est que vous
avez des catégories de la population les
militaires notamment qu' on pas le droit
d'adhérer à un parti politique alors ils
font des dons mais ils n'ont pas le
droit d'adhérer à un parti le 4rième
point c'est que parfois vous avez des
adhérents nous on a quelques adhérents
heureusement d'ailleurs qui qui sont
généreux parfois très généreux voilà et
on a vous savez que la limite annuelle
c'est 7500 € par
an dont les 2/ers sont déductible de
l'impôt sur le revenu donc pour
quelqu'un qui gagne quand même très bien
très bien sa vie il donne 7500 € à l'UP
en fait il paye 5000 € de de d'impôt sur
le revenu en moins ça revient à prendre
5000 € sur le budget de l'État pour les
donner à l'UP il lui reste quand même
2500 € à payer donc cette personne là
par exemple on en a quand même un
certain nombre pas 7500 des gens qui
donnent 6000 des gens qui donnent 5000
3000 et cetera bah si c'est quelqu'un
qui pendant un an ou deux ne paye pas sa
cotisation on va pas on va pas gueuler
on va pas dire attendez ça du temps où
on a notre adhésion l'adhésion de base é
30 € par an 7500 € c'était 250 années
d'anné d'adhésion donc on donc il faut
faire preuve de de souplesse alors tout
ça pour dire que comme tous les autres
partis on considère qu'il a les
adhérents strictement à jour de
cotisation où là on doit être aux
alentours de 17000 les adhérents
statutaires c'est-à-dire les gens qui
ont versé une cotisation sont un peu en
retard sur une année ou l'autre mais
voilà qui vont revenir ou qui ont donné
7500 et puis voilà et là on est pas très
loin des 40000 et au total l'ensemble
des gens qui dans leur vie au moins une
fois donner de l'argent à luupère que ce
soit sous forme d'adhésion ou de non on
est à pratiquement 95 ce qui est pas mal
mais il y a eu des gens qui ont fait des
dons puis ils sont pas revenus on a eu
aussi des périodes de de on a eu le PCH
on a eu des gens qui sont il y a eu il y
a eu l'énorme déception de 2017 je vous
ai dit il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui avaient cru c'était c'était gentil
c'est moi aussi je suis un peu vraiment
on avait une telle dynamique euh on
avait un peu oublié les pesanteurs les
pesanteurs sociologiques des des et et
donc il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont été
extraordinairement déçus du 0,92 % de de
de suffrage que nous avons fait à la
présidentiel risque à court moyen et
long terme alors court terme problème
financier avec risque de mis sous
tutelle en effet en tout cas d'être
obligé de négocier avec la troïc c'est
FMI commission Banque centrale
européenne
et et Commission européenne et donc d'un
plan à la à la grec avec des
privatisations et cetera pour vendre ça
ça c'est vraiment un premier risque
risque à court court terme aussi c'est
le risque de trème guerre mondiale qu'il
faut quand même pas euh moi je suis
absolument sidéré de voir à quel point
on on fait comme si c'était irréel vous
êtes colonel de réserve non vous faisiez
quoi l'armée déjà quand vous je vous ai
dit j'ai fait mon service national comme
coopérant ah d'accord donc je serai
enfin maintenant j'ai passé l'âge mais
j'aurais été soldat de de 2e classe quoi
mais la trème guerre mondiale mais la
trème guerre mondiale mais c'est quand
même pas c'est pas de la gnotnotte vous
vu qu'on a envoyé enfin c'est pas vous
c'est pas moi il y a un missile scalpe
français qui a été tiré par les
Ukrainiens la nuit dernière
français qui pense quoi les Russes les
missile rechnque là c'est dire noisette
oui c'est la noisette une petite
noisette si nous envoie missile sur le
coin du museau il prent tris gros M51 et
ils font moins les malins bon après nous
on s'est un peu vitrifi aussi mais non
mais vous rendez compte le rapport le
rapport des forces entre la France et et
la Russie c'est dé Mor et moi je suis
absolument sidéré de voir que c'est
n'est pas dans le débat national moi je
considère que là il y avait une priorité
c'était de censurer Barnier parce que
moi j'avais cru que Barnier il allait
mettre l'épil de l'autre côté puisqu'il
l'avait dit qu'il ferait donc je l'ai
mis au pied enfin je l'ai mis à mon à
mon échelle avec les gens qui me suivent
on voulait qu'il soit au pied du mur
qu'il fasse ce qu'il avait dit qu'il
ferait c'est-à-dire qu'il
propose de sortir de la France des
traités des article 67 77 et 78 du tfu
comme je le disais tout à l'heure et
d'ailleurs je l'ai dit et je le redis si
Barnier avait eu du sens politique c'est
ça qu'il faisait il prenait ses
fonctions la première chose il se
faisait inviter au TF 20h et il disait
voilà je vais m'attaquer au vrais
problème des Français problème numéro 1
c'est le problème de l'immigration il y
a 75 % des Français qui considèrent
qu'il a trop d'immigrés c'est pas c'est
pas le le problème numéro 1 c'est pas la
pauvreté en France il il y a beaucoup de
problèmes numéro 1 il y a la pauvreté il
y a l'insécurité il y a l'immigration il
y a mais là il y avait l'éducation il a
l'éducation nationale service de la sé
mais tout est problématique si vous
voulez tout est en train de partir à
Volot je vous rappelle que tout à
l'heure vous vous pensiez preniez l'air
étonné quand je vous le le
disais mais il fallait bien prendre un
bout un truc par un bout et il se trouve
qu'il avait parlé de ça j'ai l'air
étonné Françis non il avait l'air il
avait parlé de ça en
2021 donc c'était très facile pour
Barnier il disit écoutez monsieur Macron
m'a nommé Premier ministre en parfaite
connaissance de ce que j'ai dit en
2021 c'est-à-dire que j'ai dit qu'il
fallait que pour qu' commence à rgler
les questions migratoires il fallait
sortir la France de l'article 67 77 78
du tfu ainsi que la jurisprudence de la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
j'aurais c'est ça qu'il aurait il aurait
imaginé qu'il ait fait ça il va au t il
dit voilà Monsieur Macron m'a nommé en
parfaite connaissance de cause
deuxièmement je suis cohérent avec
moi-même donc il faut mettre ça
simplement il s'agit de ne pas respecter
les traités européens bon il y a pas de
clause de sortie d'ailleurs donc on tort
un peu le bras mais pour prendre une
mesure qui soit quand même un temps soit
peu valide du point de vue du droit
international il faut que ce soit le
peuple souverain qui en décide parce
qu'un peuple souverain peut toujours
décider de c'est dans le droit
international positif le droit
inaliidable des peuples à disposer
d'eux-même on ne peut pas liigoter un
peuple par un traité un un peuple a
toujours le droit s'ilexprime
majoritairement par exemple par
référendum de sortir d'un traité et donc
Barnier disait il faut donc faire un
référendum où je proposerai aux Français
de sortir de ces
articles bien ça c'est point 3 point 4
il disait je ne suis que Premier
ministre je me tourne donc vers le
président de la République puisque c'est
lui qui décide et donc je demande au
Président de la République en parfaite
transparence d'organiser un référendum
sur ces points qui sont absolument
fondamentaux et que souhaite une grande
partie des franç d'après les sondages 75
% il faisait ça il était le roit du
pétrole pourquoi parce que Macron il
avait deux choix premièrement je peux
poser une petite question franis terine
je termine le le le choix Macron soit
Macron déférait à la demande de barniier
il a organisé un référendum il y aurait
eu 70 ou 75 % de oui Macron
déféré bah il a déféré à berou hein
semble-t-il soit et berou a déféré à qui
je sais pas so soit soit Macron refusait
d'organiser le référendum que demandait
Barnier et Barnier faisait une
déclaration en disant je n'ai pas les
moyens de mener la politique que
souhaitent les Français donc je présente
ma démission et là là il avait 70 % des
français derrière lui alors que là il
est sorti c'est c'est minable la façon
dont il est sorti ouis François question
technique admettons là on parle de flux
migratoire on parle
d'immigration les pauvres gens on en
faisait quoi on faisait un mur on faisit
des camp de rétention
administratif on
mettait des robots avec de
l'intelligence TIF mais déjà déjà déjà
déjà on arrête la politique de l'Union
européenne vous savez que la c'est
l'Union européenne qui a fixé comme
objectif de faire entrer dans l'Union
européenne 4 millions de nouveaux
immigrants légaux par an c'est pas moi
qui l'ai dit il faut bien payer votre
retraite franis alors écoutez allez dire
ça sur les plate allez dire ça pu
présentez-vous aux élections avec ce
programme vous verrez comment vous serez
reçu tu V bien regarder donc non mais le
problème il est là le problème c'est
est-ce qu'on est en démoscratos pouvoir
du peuple ou est-ce qu'on est pas en
démocratie si on est si c'est le peuple
quand vous avez 75 % des Français qui
dis dire ça c'est mettre en danger notre
démocratie Françis ça je sais oui je
sais je sais c'est du populisme bon mais
non je dire c'est quand même et moi je
dis ça je ne suis pas du tout alors moi
je suis absolument pas enfin tous les
gens qui me connaissent qui a jamais la
moindre trace chez moi de racisme et
cetera je dis au contraire d'ailleurs
vous savez que il y a beaucoup de
Français d'origine étrangère récente qui
sont les premiers à à trouver qu'il y a
trop d'immigration maintenant parce que
ça met en ça finit par mettre en
danger la l'insertion et l'assimilation
des populations qui sont arrivées
récemment il y a y a beaucoup de gens de
bon sens vous savez voilà donc trop
c'est trop il y a un moment à partir et
là c'est en train de partir en c'est
trop trop c'est combien je ne sais pas
mais actuellement la population
française dit que c'est trop voilà vous
avez 75 % des Français dans tous les
sondage qui le montre donc moi ce que je
veux dire par là alors par ailleurs bien
sûr qu' y a de la misère mais moi
j'avais dit d'ailleurs j'en avais déjà
parlé au moment des européennes il y a
un truc qui est pas fait pour les chiens
ça s'appelle le Haut Commissariat pour
les Réfugiés c'est une structure qui
émane de l'ONU comment se fait-il que
les populations pauvres qui émanent de
zones justement en guerre ou enfin comme
se fait-il qu'on ne les oriente pas vers
des pays vident d'hommes très riches et
qui ont qui relèvent de la même zone
géoculturelle le Portugal non l'Arabie
Saoudite les Émirats Arab Unis le Qatar
le Bahrein le sultan
adoman pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que
c'est l'Europe qui tous les ans doit
prendre 4 millions de personnes c'est
c'est très étrange comme il y a un truc
qui s'appelle le HCR j'avais pasé la
question là aux Européens en 2019
silence radio parce que personne ne sa
ce qui était le HR parmi toutes les
toutes les têtes de liste bien entendu
il faut connaître les dossiers c'est
pourquoi est-ce que et puis par ailleurs
vous savez très bien qui est-ce qui est
derrière le financement de de de de de
comment diraisje de l'océan Viking SOS
Méditerranée vous savez que derrière
gens normau qui finance ça oui vous avez
derrière vous avez l'opon Society de
George Soros vous avez la National
Endowment for Democracy la NED qui est
un des faunés de la CI al d'ailleurs
madame puisquon en est à des sources de
ça là oh bah oui ben attendez je vais
pas je vous ai dit tout à l'heure quand
on a commencé ce débat cet entretien et
que j'avais une formation
d'abord d'abord par par nature voilà je
suis quelqu'un de précisêt content
d'être là ce soir oui bah oui restez
gentil parce que sinon vous allez partir
non non mais je suis très gentil mais je
défends mon steak et d'abord pour les
gens les gens qui a moi a un truc qui me
fait rire c'est l'astrologie je crois
pas du tout dans les parce que vous
regardez les émissions sur la
géopolitique ce qu'est-ce qu'il y a
comme astrologue
ce qui m'intéresse làdedans c'est pas
c'est pas la divination ça crois pas
mais les grandes caractéristiques non
non les grandes caractéristiques en
fonction des des signes il se trouve que
je suis vierge ascendant vierge et la la
Vierge c'est le la la c'est la
méticulosité la précision le le
caractère parfois un petit peu
cassecouille un peu un peu mais
fiabilité aussi fiabilité honnêteté
sincérité ça c'est le côté et ça en tout
cas je sais pas si c'est vrai mais ça me
correspond très bien voilà et donc je
suis quelqu'un lorsque je dis quelque
chose vous savez rappelez-vous ce que
disait ce journaliste on ne sait pas à
quoi vous répondre parce que lorsque les
gens moi
m'attaquent depuis 17 ans il se cassent
les dents qu'est-ce qu'on en fait des
des gens qui veulent venir nous voir
mais déjà déjà la première chose c'est
qu'il faudrait arrêter la politique
migratoire de l'Union européenne
deuxièmement orienter ses flux vers des
pays qui peuvent les accueillir enfin
l'Arabie Saoudite ce sont des musulmans
qui viennent de la zone sahélienne enfin
pourquoi ils vont pas en Arabie Saoudite
au Qatar au sultanadoman et cetera enfin
c'est quand même qui relèv de leur zone
et puis par ailleurs pourquoi il y en a
pas dans le monde en enfin je veux dire
la l'Europe elle a fait elle a fait sa
part dans ce dans cette histoire eu et
puis par ailleurs il faut aussi il y a
aussi un problème c'est que les flux
migratoires qui ont été qui qui qui ont
submergé l'Europe au cours des dernières
années il vient il vient de la
déstabilisation du régime libien de
Kaddafi qui est-ce qui a été derrière
c'est quand même votre ami
sarkozition an non mais c'est vrai ou
pasis que je vais me fâcher dans 2
minutes c'est qui mon ami Sarco oui non
mais c'est la vérité compte d'autru
d'ailleurs non mais bon donc vous avez
eu la la qui est-ce qui qui est-ce qui a
flingué le régime le régime
syrien Jean la on avait
avait non c'était pas Jean c'est Nicolas
SAR oui on avait on avait la la France
du temps où elle avait de l'influence
dans le monde arabe au musulman c'était
en quelle année ça bah ça commence au
début enfin ça au 19e siècle déjà hein
c'est quand même c'est quand même c'est
quand même Ferdinand de l'essps qui
construit le canal de suè je vous le
rappelle ça peut-êtreel coup à quel coup
d'ailleurs ou oui encore autre chose
ouis donc revenons on a et PU et puis et
puis on a eu de l'influence avec la 3è
République enfin
l' perdu
quand je pense qu'on l'a perdu dans les
années à partir de mitteran petit à
petit parce qu'on avait une influence
colossale ave avec de gaulors de la
grande politique Arab deant r migrant
bon je vais mettre à la place des
Saoudiens des cataris ou des ce que vous
voulez nous on n pas tapé dans les
ressources de
l'Afrique et donc maintenant la misère
qu' a là-bas c'est la vôtre nous on a du
pétrole on m' jamais été tapé on a fait
peut-être quelques petites campagnes
pour aller attraper de trois esclaves à
gauche à droite mais oui non vousz pas
je sais bien c'est une passion je sais
bien on peut parler oui oui on peut
parler de la de la de toute l'histoire
de l'esclavage et cetera et C on fait
quoi ces gens je vous dis déjà la
première chose déjà c'était de ne pas
dstabiliser
pay déjà ne pas déstabiliser ses pays
première c'est trop tard bah oui mais
enfin bon ça continue ça continue donc
déjà ne pas déstabiliser ses pays alors
on fait quoi pour les restabiliser bah
déjà il faut pas envoyer quelqu'un comme
comme Monsieur Jean-Noël barraau
monsieur Jean-Noël Barau si vous voulez
qui est qui est qui est une nullité
venimeuse en fait alors ça ça n'engage
que vous bon c'est vrai c'est gratuit il
est pas là pour se défendre non mais moi
quand on vous attaque sur mon plateau
que vous êtes pas là je n'accepte pas
d'accord je retire
je ce que mais je peux dire quand
mêmesur jeanl bar c'est un leader de la
French American Foundation et alors bon
ben ça prouve oui ça prouve déjà un
certain tropisme ça ça veut rien dire
mais d'accord mais ça c'est des faau de
présomtion je sais bien qu'un truc en
soi ne veut rien dire bon mais il est
quand même French leader de la French
American Foundation deuxièmement il est
le fils de son père c'est une dynastie
politique voilà il aurait pas il serait
pas le fils de Jacques bar de la santé
du temps du Chirac je suis pas sûr qu'il
aurait été ministre d'aaires étrangères
à 38 ans voilà je ne suis pas sûr que
ses capacités personnelles le le pousser
à ça il a été nommé au cadora allez vous
renseigner vous le savez d'ailleurs tout
le monde au cadora dit que c'est c'est
une catastrophe absolue mais c'est qui
tout le monde qui est dansé c'est des
bruits de couloir des gens qui sont vous
avez vu vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
au Sael c'est des vieux au sa bon il a
fait un petit voyage puis après ça est
mal passé on s'est fait virer est arrivé
au Chad non au chchad il y a d'autres
histoires non mais quand même il est pas
responsable de tout ce oui non mais
d'accord mais en fait il va au Tchad il
a 38 ans il va voir le président du Chad
et vous avez su vu ce qu'il lui a dit il
a dit quoi change la clime non ça
c'était ça c'était Macron quelques
années auparavant c'était au Burkina
faceo avec le président rock caboré ENF
il s'est mis d'ado tout le monde c'est
du mépris constamment dans le 7e on
comprend bien bien VO alors là il va
voir le président du Tchad et il lui dit
non non il faut que vous reportiez
les élections législatives au
Tchad parce que les listes sont pas
assez inclusives inclusives dans le quel
sens W LGBT et
cetera vous êtes sûr de ça le président
du Tchad dès qu'il est parti a dit tous
les Français dégagés mais non mais parce
que ce sont des gens qui ne connaissent
pas les sociétés auxquelles on parle
allez parler de tous ces trucs de W
culture LGBT culture allez parler de ça
à des africains ou à des ou à des ou
dans le monde arabo musulman mais les
gens sont vant debout pareil en Russie
pareil dans beaucoup de pays du monde
d'ailleurs ça c'est l'Occident ne se
rend pas compte de ce de ce de ce qui
est en train de se passer avec ces
histoires là c'est c'est c'est et nous
on envoie je suis désolé c'est quelqu'un
qui n'a absolument pas d' histoire oui
bien sûr il y a toujours d'autres
histoires il y a toujours d'autres
histoires jour mdiapard va se per
dessusta oui oui oui il y a toujours
d'autres histoires mais il y a quand
même si vous voulez quelque chose d'
effrayant c'est que Monsieur bar conna
les histoires en question bon je sais
pas il en a que je connais il y en a
certaines que je ne connais pas vous
allez m'apprendre je dirais vous êtes
sûr de ça ah ouais et a il a fait aussi
enfin on vous rendez compte qu'on est en
train de perdre pied en Afrique enfin
c'est c'est faire tirer les oreilles
d'ailleurs
h donc donc alors bon pour revenir à
l'inquiétude c'est
euh alors ce qui crise financière crise
de la trème Guerre mondiale parce que
sans que ça soit nécessairement moi je
j'aimeraisre au 21 janvier pour question
les migrants oui on en fait quoi on les
laisse à la porte mais je vous ai dit on
a une politique
on on a déjà une politique avec les pays
de les pays d'origine et puis on a une
politique vis-à-vis de l'Union
européenne et on dit non non la France
maintenant c'est terminé mais il y a
qu'à faucon aussi
non en France il y en a combien de P les
octf qui sont pas reconduits à la
frontière écoutez je ne dis pas que le
problème est facile hein mais ce que je
sais aussi c'est que ces qtf pour
qu'elles soi exécuté euh il faut avoir
un moyen de levier sur les pays de
départ et plus qu'un moyen de levier il
y a aussi quelque chose qui est
impalpable en fait c'est que dans le
monde entier écoutez bien ce que je vais
vous dire dans le monde entier les
dirigeants du monde entier ont intégrer
l'idée que la France est un pays en
pleine décadence dirigé par des gens
foutres c'est ça la vérité et donc tout
ce que peut dire d'ailleurs il est plus
reçu nulle part en fait hein voilà vous
croyez que c'est malin quand il est allé
avec son espèce de caravane comme ça il
est allé au Maroc avec ses gloires fané
comme comme Jack Lang ou et cetera quand
il est allé au Maroc en fait pour et et
prendre position pour la position du
Maroc sur le Sahara mais Jacques Lang il
est pas président de l'Institut du Monde
Arab oui vous avez vu perclut de de de
de c'est un scandale financier ambulant
cette affaire des compes vient de sortir
un scandale sur le vous avez vu 4
millions d'euros de déficit il se passe
plus rien le jack il y a 85 ans il est
renouvelé qu'est-ce que c'est que c
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette république
enfin qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc
c'est quoi le problème avec jackl
pourquoi il est renouvelé à 85 ans alors
que c'est un désastre qu'est- c'est
François que c'est gérantophobie c'est
pas de la gérantophobie il faut nommer
des gens compétents des gens qui ont
fait des succès mais là vous me faites
dérailler parce que je reviens à mon
rail précédent pas un rail de coque he
moi mais
pourquoi est-ce que Macron a pris fê
écos pour le Sahara marocain il y a en
France peut-être 700000 français
d'origine marocaine et peut-être 1200000
français d'origine ou pas français
d'origine algérienne le devoir d'un chef
d'État ils viennent d'où les chiffres oh
bah c'est comme ça enfin alle vous Rense
de toute façon personne n'est au courant
mais en gros c'est ça c'est à peu près
ça les chiffres bon je compte les gens
qui sont algériens non français et les
Français d'origine algérienne de de 1è
de
SS sont s'ils sont français ils sont
français oui mais euh oui bien sûr mais
ils peuvent quand même avoir garder des
affinités c'est quand même
saloméabigvili elle était française mais
bon elle avait quand même gardé des
affinités elle a pris la nationalité
geéorgienne d'ailleurs et maintenant
elle est présente de la geéorgie donc il
y a quand même des affinités ce qui est
normal d'ailleurs c'est absolument
normal mais donc un chef d'État
raisonnable qui veut la paix civile en
France doit faire attention à ce genre
de choses il n'a pas il n'a pas sur la
faire Algérie Maroc à prendre de
position parce que il y a deux
communautés qui sont extrêmement
sourcilleuses sur ce problème comment
vous avez pris le fait qu'il souhait
déclasser les Archives françaises du Sud
Maroc ou du du Sud algérien ça dépend de
quel côté on point oui ben écoutez
qu'est-ce que vous voulez je je ne
connais pas j'aime pas trop m'exprimer
sur des sujets que je connais pas bien
est-ce qu'il y avait urgence à faire ça
je n'en sais rien en tout cas ce que je
pense c'est que c'est une erreur
fondamentale que d'avoir pris position
là-dessus puisque euh donc alors certes
on est bien vu au Maroc mais le Maroc
est très très proche des États-Unis hein
euh et en revanche c'est la guerre
ouverte avec l'Algérie ce qui est quand
même pas très bon bon tout ça parce que
Macron ne s'entend pas avec le Président
tbun je dis pas que le président tboun
est quelqu'un de très facile j'en saisen
mais en fait on s'en fiche c'est des
trucs de c'est des trucs de gaminerie
c'est comme si vous voulez je pense et
ça c'est qu' c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation je pense notamment pour
que les les Français choisissent un chef
d'État c'est la même chose sur un sujet
encore plus explosif que le sujet
Israël-Palestine voilà moi je je
j'essaie de tenir et et je sur la scène
politique français il y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui disent ce que je dis
c'est-à-dire j'ai dit je suis invité
aussi bien sur des radios communautaires
style Beur FM et des choses comme ça que
sur Israël 24 news je suis d'ailleurs
plus souvent invité sur Israël 24 news
que sur BFM soit dit en passant bon euh
j'ai été invité coup sur coup deux fois
en un
mois et moi je dis toujours la même
chose à tout le monde ça c'est aussi une
de mes caractéristique parce que le le
politicien lambda c'est vous savez c'est
le
caméléon ça c'est c'est typique le
politicien qui dit à chaque public ce
que chaque public veut entendre voilà
hein c'était Chirac par exemple qui
allait voir des gens dans des quartiers
et cetera qui se plaignaient
d'immigration et de général qui disait
oui et puis il y a les odeurs vous
rappelez le scandale qu'il avait fait et
puis je sais pas le lendemain il
rencontrait des des Français d'origine
immigré et puis il éta dit oui là je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est scandaleux
la chasse aux faciesse et cetera donc
voilà Chirac c'était systématiquement un
changement il y en a beaucoup bon et le
problème c'est que vous savez comment
meurt un un un un caméléon ben quand
quand on le pose sur un tissu
écossais parce que là il sait plus
quelle couleur prendre si t il bug de
l'intérieur donc c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'il y a toujours un moment où il
y a une preuve de vérité donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut beaucoup mieux dire à mon
avis toujours la même chose à tout le
monde et moi je dis par exemple sur ce
conflit
israëlo-palestinien je dis que en France
il y aà aussi c'est les statistiques
mais on sait pas très bien mais en gros
puisque les statiques ethniques ne sont
pas autorisés en France mais il y a à
peu près 500000 à 750000 Français juifs
et il y a 5 à 7 8 9 millions sortez vous
les sortez d'où les chiffres bah
regardez regardez partout tout allez
vous renseigner sur l'INC sur les sur la
sur Wikipédia et cetera ou aller sur des
organismes communautaires donc et et il
y a en gros on estime entre 6 à 8 9 10
millions de Français
musulmans ça veut dire qu'au passage il
y a 60 millions ou 59 millions de
Français qui ne sont ni Juifs ni
musulmans dont je suis d'ailleurs et
quand vous voulez être à la tête de
l'État et que vous voulez la paix civile
entre les
citoyens vous évitez de prendre des
positions qui sont outrageusement en
faveur d'un camp contre
l'autre c'est c'est le béabas c'est pour
ça que personnellement je renvoie dos à
dos un Zemour ou un ou un ou un Émeric
Caron ou un Mélenchon parce que alors du
coup tout le monde me critique je par
quand je suis allé sur Israël 24 news
j'ai vu il y avait des des gens de LFI
qui disent oui c'est scandaleux vous
allez c'est une radio du Liou c'est
radio chéocidaire c'est une honte
d'aller là bon et puis quand j'étais sur
Israël 24 news moi j'ai dit ce que je
pensais et j'ai dit que c'était pas la
politique de d'abord il y a énormément
de Juifs qui sont pas d'accord avec
netanah netaniaou il avait failli tomber
avant avant l'affaire du 7 octobre qui a
quand même beaucoup et pas rien
etoudolmer ancien Premier ministre a dit
que le piremi d'Israël c'était pas
l'Iran c'était pas le Hezbollah c'était
netanahou excusez du peu et je le dit je
dit
personnellement et après personnellement
j'ai dit j'ai dit j'ai cité le cas de de
de amnestie international j'ai dis le
dossier amnisiee internationale quand
même qui dit qu'il y a un responsable de
crime de génnocide alors évidemment ils
étaient furieux qui bah les les les les
personnes avec qui je débattais sur
Israël 24 news mais je suis allé le leur
dire parce que je pense que c'est rendre
service aux gens que dire attention
est-ce que vous rendez compte de ce que
de ce que la l'image que l'État d'Israël
est en train d'avoir maintenant dans le
monde entier après néanou c'est alors
j'ai donc été critiqué par des juifs
extrémistes qui m'ont dit c'est ça vous
êtes antisémite je vous savez si j'étais
antisémite je je dirais que c'est
formidable ce que fait
naniaou réfléchissez à ce que je dis ok
comme disait deg là mais comme disait
deg les Américains devraient comprendre
que leurs meilleurs alliés sont leur
meilleur alliés est celui qui sait leur
dire non voilà et quand vous êtes un bon
copain quand vous avez des amis qui fait
une connerie vous dites non c'est pas
bien le deuxième danger le plus
important pour Israël c'est qui après
netaniaou selon
vous je pense que l'État d'Israël
devrait quand même faire attention à la
dégradation de son image mondiale il y a
plus grand monde qui le soutient dans le
monde alors évidemment ils sont soutenus
par les États-Unis enfin les États-Unis
sont quand même en déclin et vous avez
des grandes puissances émergentes qui
sont quand même il devrai faire
attention c'est quand même un pays qui a
40 km de de profondeur
stratégique qui est en je dire le grand
danger c'est c'est l'extrême droite
israélienne je pense des gens comme
bezales motrc là le le ministre qui veut
recréer le Grand teret Israël mais vous
rendez compte vous savez ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire le sud de la Syrie
l'ouest de l'Irak après le le TIGR et le
frrat donc toute la partie ouest le nord
de l'Arabie Saoudite la Jordanie et tout
l'est de l'Égypte l'est du Nil
mais c'est une c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est incroyable en fait c'est pas et ce
sont des ça serait des conversations de
comptoir à TelAviv c'est des ministres
du gouvernement israélien c'est quand
même très très grave c'est quand même
très grave donc je pense qu'ils doivent
faire il doivent faire attention mais je
suis il y a pas que moi qui le dit c'est
et alors tout ce que je dis là je ne me
connais pas bien sûr le le le terrorisme
parce que je sais qu'il y a aussitôt des
gens qui vont dire ou là là vous
reprenez les non il faut essayer moi je
je je suis
j'ambitionne de diriger un jour la
France président de la République
française il doit oui le président de la
République française vous aurez quel âge
en 2027 ben j'aurais 69
ans toujours 9 ans de moins que Trump ça
sera l'âge de de Grou d'ailleurs en 58
donc c'est bon c'est pas tellement l'âge
qui compte c'est simplement la vivacité
d'esprit la connaissance des dossiers
c'est ça qui compte François comment on
fait pour arrêter la trè guerre mondiale
selon françoislinou en 2027 pour
l'instant on va brûler un sierge à Saint
Rita la patronne des causes désespérées
en espérant qu' rien ne se passe de
grave avant
avant non avant que Trump non avant
c'est Trump avant que Trump arrive
arrive le 20 janvier on a plus que un
mois à tenir quoi mais actuellement je
vous ai dit des cinglés comme Victoria
noollande la sous-secrétaire non non pas
pas de petit nom d'oiseau comme ça alors
madame Victoria noollande qui était
sous- secrétaire d'État américaine qui a
été la elle est marié avec Paul Kagan
c'est vraiment le noyau dur des né
conservateur américain elle a été la Une
des responsables vraiment elle a été à
la manœuvre pour le Maidan par exemple
elle était même allée vous savez
distribuer des des des des croissant et
des boissons chaudes pendant la
révolution du Maidan en Ukraine c'est
elle qui avait téléphoné à l'ambassadeur
des États-Unis à keV qui s'appelait
jofrey pot dans cette conversation qui a
été captée par les Russes par les
satellites russes et qui a été qui a
fait un scandale planétaire qui
d'ailleurs a été dévié le scandale parce
que
le scandale c'est que elle elle a
téléphoné à jofrey payat donc son
ambassadeur l'ambassadeur des États-Unis
à Kiev en disant voilà ce qu'il faut
comme nouveau gouvernant alors elle
avait écarté Klitschko elle dit non non
pas lui c'est sa c'est c'est celui qui
fait de la boxe voilà c'était celui qui
non non lui B il est pas très facile
donc elle préférait je sais plus comment
il s'appelait donc elle avaitelle
faisait son choix et à un moment il y
avait que l'ambassadeur à des États-Unis
à Kiev qui disait oui mais alors le
problème c'est l'Union européenne et à
ce moment-là elle l'avait interrompu
elle Ava dit u voilà ça veut dire que
l'Union européenne aille se faire
et dans les médias français où cette
affaire a fait quand même scandal on a
monté en épingle ce morceau de
phrase mais c'était le c'était le moins
intéressant se faire voir oui ça c'était
c'était pas intéressant ce qui était non
mais d'accord mais c'était pas
fondamentalement intéressant ce qui
était intéressant c'était que Madame
Victoria NAND fixait qu'elles étaient
les membres du gouvernement ukrainien ça
c'était très intéressant on l'a pas fait
des fois non c'est mais euh je sais
alors il y a des gens qui disent oui
mais voilà vous avez fait si vous avez
fait ça mais là je suis comme vous
enfant faut regarder quand même un petit
peu l'avenir on en est plus là hein on
en est plus là mais euh ce que je dis
donc pour pour pour moi ce que j'espère
c'est que actuellement madame Victoria
Noland elle a été exfiltrée vous le
savez cétait il y a un an environ euh
parce que on a découvert un trou de 1
milliard de dollars comme une grande
elle a elle a elle a elle aurait
détourné pas pas un million ni 10
millions
1 milliard de dollars c'est quoi cette
histoire bah allez vous renseigner taper
Victoria neand voilà qui a quitté je
peux pas tout vous dire sinon on va
passer 3 jours ça va être un je sais pas
le Nouvel An hein oui oui on peut faire
un truc ça serait une espèce de Marathon
bon elle a elle a le Téléton un Téléton
voilà un Téléton je suis je suis
d'accord avec ça est-ce qu'on va être
obligé de faire un franceeton bientôt
faudraiter euh donc elle a été écartée
elle a été chassée c'était sous Biden
discrètement mais bon elle a elle a
quitté son pote de sous-secrétaire
d'État elle était auprès de blinken il
est vrai que en plus de ça avec blinken
s'entendait pas c'était elle qui tenait
un peu la la la la culotte ce si si si
on peut dire elle avait beaucoup de
beaucoup de poids dans l'appareil du
ministre de
et bon enfin bref donc elle a été
exfiltrée on n entendait plus parler et
puis on en a entendu parler il y a 3
semaines je sais pas si vous avez suivi
elle vient d'être nommée directrice
générale de la NED la National
democracy qui est ce ce fauné de la CIA
allez vous renseigner mais c'est des
suutations ou mais non alors mais non
alors là c'est une notoriété publique
c'est que allez allez vous renseigner
sur sur Wikipédia ou sur toute autre
chose tout le monde sait ce que c'est
que la ND et donc elle est beaucoup
d'analystes géopolitiques dont je fais
partie disent que elle est elle est à la
manœuvre en ce moment pour essayer de
pourrir au maximum les débuts de la
présidence Trump donc c'est comme par
hasard au même moment vous avez une
espèce de flambé de manœuvre de
déstabilisation vous avez la Moldavie
vous avez la Roumanie vous avez la
Géorgie vous avez la Syrie vous avez
donc c'est pas très clair Franois je
vous arrête quoi vous avez passé l'âge
de brasser l'écume des choses vous
trouvez que c'est l'écume des choses
toutes ces manœuvres de déstabilisation
ça vous fait pas penser un peu à votre
jeunesse ces stratégies de guerre froide
oui ben on est dans une nouvelle guerre
froide sauf que la
peu chaud ce M oui la différence qu'il y
a et ça c'est très inquiétant je trouve
c'est un c'est un
sujet énorme en fait c'est
que on a l'impression que l'Occident au
sens
large c'est les États-Unis d'Amérique le
Canada l'Amérique du Nord et puis
l'Europe
c'était l'Occident a inventé le monde le
monde européen a inventé notamment la
France bon avec Descartes descart il a
inventé un truc qui s'appelle le doute
méthodique la méthode cartésienne le
discours de la méthode c'est la phras
oui je pense donc je suis et cetera bon
donc c'est très important c'est que le
monde occidental la civilisation
occidentale a mis à jour quelque chose
qui est une vraie avancé dans la pensée
de l'humanité c'est l'idée que on peut
tout examiner au crible de sa raison et
donc c'est une espèce de
relativisation alors que ça sort au
monde dogmatique d'ailleurs ça n'est pas
pour rien que ceci va c'est à quelques
années près en fait de ce grand
mouvement de la pensée qu'on trouvera en
Occident alors là moi j'ai parlé de
Descartes qui d'ailleurs est obligé de
s'enfuir d'aller aux Pays-Bas pour
pouvoir publier son truc mais c'est à
oui j'ai vu mais c'est à quelques années
près euh de la Révolution ce qu'on
appelle la révolution Copernico
galiléenne c'est-à-dire que fin vers
1580 et quelques à kracovi vous avez le
moine copernque qui bénéficiant des
nouvelles l'amélioration de la
fabrication des veres optiques qui sont
beaucoup moins granuleux et cetera on
fait début d' comment ils font des
lentilles et Copernic observe le ciel il
fait des abaques et il en conclut que en
fait c'est pas possible que le soleil
tourne autour de la Terre que c'est
l'inverse or ça ça revenait à remettre
en cause toutes les sous enseignement de
l'Église depuis Saint Thomas d'quin
Saint- Thomas d'quin qui donc vivait au
13e siècle et est un qui est un des
docteur de l'Église qui a été fait
docteur de l'Église il y a une dizaine
de docteurs de l'église Saint-Thomas
d'quin il a donc au 13e siècle il avait
redécouvert les classique grec et donc
la la la la cosmogonie de de
ptoléé qui parlait du monde avec la
terre puis les le soleil et puis les
sphères armilières où il y avait des
étoiles qui étaient voilà qui tournaient
autour de la Terre et et comment dire
Saint-Thomas d'quin découvre au 13e
siècle ce classique grec c'est la grande
retour grand retour aux études
classiques qui d'ailleurs souvent on été
transmis par les par la civilisation du
du du califat de de de de de de Damas
des khalifas omeyad puis Khalifa
Abasside qui ont conservé des textes
grecs alors que dans l'Occident du
Moyen-Âge tout ça avait disparu et donc
la redécouverte de sa saint Thomas
d'quin s'aperçoit que ça correspond
exactement au récit de la Genèse dans la
Bible donc il dit voilà c'est bingo
c'est ça ça correspond au réc de la
jeunesse c'estàdire que la terre est au
centre du Soleil et c'est devenu un
dogme de l'Église catholique qui a été
officiellement officiellement abandonné
par par Jean-Paul i terminé laissez-moi
terminer
donc à partir de de
Copernic il découvre que c'est pas
possible et là il y a quand même un
problème bon quelques années après c'est
Galilée alors lui qui est florentin mais
qui est copain avec avec le cardinal
barmin qui est la Sainte
Inquisition Galilée découvre les mêmes
choses il dit ça n'est pas possible en
fait c'est c'est pas la terre qui c'est
pas le SO qui tourne la terre c'est
l'inverse c'est un sacrilège en fait ça
revient à dire que saint Thomas d'quin a
tort que le dogme de l'Église catholique
est faux mais aussi que la Bible est
fausse que la terre n'est pas au centre
du monde c'est c'est on découvre ce
qu'on appellera l'héliocentrisme puis
après il y a toute une et alors ça c'est
très important dans la comment nous a
menti dans la pensée dans la pensée
occidentale S c'est c'est génial le le
peuple enfin les peuples d'Occident à
cette période de de l'évolution de
l'histoire de l'humanité donc entre le
fin 16e début 17e siècle invente la
capacité de douter et de remettre en
cause voilà et donc le triomphe de la
raison avec un grand terre or ce que
nous sommes en train de vivre à notre
époque c'est en fait le la folie la
déraison vous ne pouvez même plus
maintenant je vois on ne peut plus
discuter quelqu'un comme Nathalie
l'iseau c'est quelqu'un on peut plus
discuter avec Nathalie Loiseau elle est
folle Macron non c'est gratuit bon alors
elle est elle est insanne elle est mais
non mais quand écoutez ma question mais
quand vous dites quand vous dites quand
vous dites ma questioniss TER quand vous
dites je laiss beaucoup quand même quand
vous dites quand vous dites quand vous
dites que par exemple que Nathalie
Loiseau elle a fait un discours au
Parlement européen mais attendez elle a
fait un discours au Parlement européen
où elle explique mais là on est en
pleine actualité une bouffe si vous
voulez non elle a fait un discours au
Parlement européen on est en pleine
actualité selon lequel c'est TikTok qui
a manipuler les élections en Roumanie
qui ont justifié que la Cour
constitutionnelle roumaine
sur pression européenne et surtout le
fils Alexandre Soros qui est allé sur
place est arrivé 40 minutes avant allez
vous renseigner la Cour
constitutionnelle roumaine attendez elle
a renversé sa jurisprudence est- qu'on
lui a posé des questions du genre a
c'était quoi le volume de trafic il y a
combien sur mais surtout mais surtout en
quoi en quoi le fait de faire une
vidéoou 15 vidéos ou 100 vidéos sur
TikTok manipule l'élection vous les avez
vu les vidéos en question non
en quoi ça les gens ils sont ils restent
ma quand ils vont voter mettre le
bulletin qu' veulent surtout que le père
Georg escou là celui qui a été élu enfin
qui est arrivé en tête oui oui mais au
même moment vous aviez à la télévision
rouaine il était invisibilisé qu est la
différence entre un réflexe de Pavlov et
un réflexe de
lawence je vous laisse avaler votre
salive et je vous repose ma question
quelle était ma question sur la guerre
sur l'écume des choses voilà la
question oui oui parce que je vais
revenir parce que parce que ce que je
pense c'est que pendant la guerre froide
non parce que
pendant pendant la guerre froide il y
avait de part et d'autrre des gens
rationnel et des idéologies il y avait
des idéologies mais il y avait des gens
rationnels je ne suis plus certain que
le camp occidental soit rationnel c'est
ça l'inquiétude que j'ai c'est ça
l'inquiétude quels sont les éléments
pour quand vous avez la France qui a le
doute vous
habite quand vous avez la France qui a
une armée une armée bonzaille comme on
dit c'estàd qu'on a des trucs qui sont
formidables mais on en a de trois
exemplairesée bon oui c'estpression oui
c'est très bien mais on en presque rien
c'est joli oui c'est joli ça dure
longtemps oui enfin oui ça peur des
courant d'air c'est assez fragile les
bonill
endurc vous rendez compte que la fr vous
rendez compte que quelqu'un comme
Jean-Noël barreau il dit qu'il faut
aller balancer des missiles sur la
Russie d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'on
est dans le domaine de
l'irrationnel on est dans le domaine de
l'irrationnel parce que le jour où
j'espère que ça aura pas lieu mais si
demain vous savez ça mettra 14 13 à 14
minutes un missile orchn d'arkangelsk
pour taper tiens le viaduc de mot dont
on parlait tout à l'heure non pas le
Rockfort
alle 3h du matin PAF
on voit pas le truc venir 3 km5 à la
seconde en plus on a ça tombe au milieu
du Larzac il y a pas de mort non mais a
quelques brebis mais a pas des
militaires aussi dans bah le C non il
avait été un peu mis de côté je crois
j'espère pas mais vous voyez ce que je
dire c'est une métaphore que je dis bien
sûr c'est voilà c'est que on fait quoi
on ouvre une clairette de
D et on attend on a à faire avec Poutine
qu'on le veille ou non
c'est un joueur d'échec et Shin ping
c'est un joueur de go c'est pas la même
chose jou aux échecs oui j'ai joué j'ai
plus le temps non non je su pas du tout
classé pas du tout mais je sais jouer
aux échecsz bouger un
cheval non puis je sais quand même qu'il
faut réfléchir deux tris coups à
l'avance essayer de voir les différentes
hypothèses par sur les chiqu quel est le
côté le plus
intéressant vous savez que ça dépend ça
dépend des des joueurs vous avez j'ai
toutes des joueurs qui vous disent on va
faire une expérience de pensée en ce
moment entre entre vous et admettons
vous avez beaucoup parlé he bon ben je
vous laisse parler admettons l'Ukraine
c'est le centre de l' chi bien pris un
verre d'au et ben non et encore encore
on vous a mis le chauffage aujourd'hui
on va vous trouver ça
et si tu veux bien tu touches plus la
caméra on ne bouge plus parce que notre
cadreuse préféré va aller vous chercher
ver c'est elle qui va le chercher parce
que c'est elle qui est à côté de la
porte et revenons revenons le centre de
l'chikier c'est l'Ukraine pourquoi ce
serait le centre de l'chiquier l'Ukraine
maintenant pourquoi aujourd'hui une
Ukraine ouais pourquoi il y a 15 ans
aussi c'était le centre de Les
chqu B pour toute une série de
raisons qui sont
que si vous avez
luignski un petit peu qui d'origine
polonaise qui américain qui a été
conseiller diplomatique du président
Carter puis du président Obama mais
moins et qui a écrit qui a écrit son
livre sur le grand échiquier de great
chesbord il expliquait dans son livre
bon c'est c'est c'est c'est son analyse
elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut mais elle est
intéressante quand même pour quelqu'un
qui a été conseillé voilà il expliquait
que merci c'est extrêmement gentil
voilà il expliquait
que
la il fallait absolument que la que les
États-Unis
profite de l'affaiblissement de la
Russie pour refouler la Russie au plus
profond de l'interlande eurasiatique
l'interlande vous savez ça a été inventé
par les géopoliticiens mckinder
allemands au 19e siècle et cetera euh et
il y avait euh il développa cette idée
voilà cette idée selon laquelle il
fallait refouler la Russie au plus
profond de rasie et lui arraché
l'Ukraine il l'a dit il a dit que si la
les États-Unis parvenaient a arraché
l'Ukraine de l'influence russe çaen
était fini de la Russie qui ne pourrait
plus être une grande puissance menaçante
enfin concurrente des États-Unis
d'Amérique voilà donc c'est vraiment une
pensée qui a qui est dans la voilà qui
est dans la la pensée la pensée la
pensée des géopoliticien américains donc
ça c'est un premier point deuxième point
c'est aussi la frontière entre entre le
l'UTAN et et et la Russie donc l'idée de
d'imposer progress ement que l'UTAN
arrive jusqu'aux portes de la Russie
fait que l'Ukraine est un pays qui
naturellement est un pays que sur lequel
les États-Unis ont dé visisé d'autant
plus que à la différence de la
Biélorussie qui est plus petite la
Biélorussie elle est ethniquement
homogène elle est proche de la Russie
alors que la l'Ukraine est un pays
composite qui a été créé par Staline au
début du 20e siècle en plusieurs années
en prenant des petits morceaux il a
piquer un petit morceau de la Pologne un
petit morceau de la de la ruténie de la
Hongrie un petit morceau de la Roumanie
qui fait d'ailleurs que dans le
processus de paix qui va arriver il
n'est pas
exclu que les Russes aient à cœur de
donner un petit quelque chose à la
Pologne à la la Hongrie et la Roumanie
qui serait peut-être très contente de se
partager les dépouilles de l'Ukraine je
vous trouve je vous trouve bien ça vient
d'où ça c'est ces suplutations de plan
de paix ben ça fait que actuellement il
y a des négociations secrètes entre
guillemets qui ont lieu entre les États
secr vous êtes tenus au courant comment
écoutez ne me croyez pas il y a
actuellement des négociations vous savez
que Trump il a nommé un type qui
s'appelle kog comme les cornflakes K
deog c'est vrai vous renseigner kog il
l'a nommé qui est le représentant
personnel de Trump pour aller discuter
le bout de grain avec les équipes de de
Poutine il les gens se ren compent
par-il au bord du la Clément donc en ce
moment dans voilà ils sont en train
d'essayer de trouver un système qui
permettrait de je crois que ce que
veulent les États-Unis euh et Trump
alors pas tout le monde l'état profond
eux veuillent au contraire aggraver la
situation mais euh Trump enfin Biden il
est quand même tout à fait en bout de
course et ce que souhait certainement
Trump et ses équipes c'est une espèce de
ce que les Américains appelle face
saving device c'est-à-dire une un
procédé pour sauver la face voilà euh
donc euh pour ne pas montrer que l'UTAN
les États-Unis d'Amérique ont été battus
il y a quand même 50 pays coalisés
contre la Russie la Russie elle peut
compter sur le S Stien de la Corée du
Nord un peu de l'Iran et de la Chine
mais des soutiens matériels s'agissant
des composants électroniques chinois les
des drones iraniens et des quelques
soldats nord-coréens voilà et face à ça
il y a quand même une armada avec 50
États dont notamment les pays de l'Union
Européen et puis les États-Unis
d'Amérique et le Canada c'est quand même
pas rien plus il y a aussi le Japon la
Corée et cetera bon donc il s'agit de
sauver la face voilà et pour sauver la
face ils vont trouver à mon avis mais je
je fais je fais des suputations à partir
de quelques éléments d'information que
j'ai d'un certain nombre de gens que je
connais euh qui on envisagerait un
système où d'abord le système de bon
sens c'est quoi c'est de reconnaître que
la Russie a quand même gagné la Russie
ne va jamais lâcher l'Ukraine la la
Crimée ça c'est impossible ni non plus
que ils appelaient Nova Rossia qui était
vous savez enfin il faut reprendre toute
l'histoire de l'Ukraine là c'est comme
comme tout le reste tout le Sud-Ouest le
sud-est pardon de l'Ukraine a été
conquis au 18 siècle par la Grande
Catherine qui était une une allemande
d'origine mais qui a une des
impératrices les plus farouches de la de
la de de la Russie et qui avait comme
amant le fameux potemkim qui était à la
fois son amant mais un militaire de
génie et qu'elle avait envoyé pour
conquérir la Crimée et ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le donbas qui était peuplé
de population musulmane de Cana K a n a
T qui relevait qui étaaiit des vassaux
de la Sublime Porte c'est-à-dire de
l'Empire ottoman qui était en face hein
c'est au sud de la la mer Noire et donc
on peut dire que d'une certaine façon
c'est un peu leur Algérie 1830 comme
nous lorsque Charles 10 envoie les
troupes française en Algérie la la la la
la Grande Catherine elle envoie poemkin
et il conquiè tout le sud est de ce
qu'on appelit les les plaines pontiques
parce que c'est près du ce qu'on appelle
le ponxin c'estàdire l'ancien nom de la
de la mer Noire qui sont ces plaines que
l'on trouve et puis il y a quand même
des reliefs dans tout le ce qui est
actuellement les républiques du donbas
plus la Crimée et ilouvve notamment en
Crimée il y a cette immense rade
extraordinaire dont ils vont faire une
ville russe qu'ils vont appeler la ville
de Sébastien sébastopole parce que c'est
ça va devenir le plus grand port de
l'armée de la marine russe en eau chaude
c'est-à-dire pas bloqué par les glaces
parce que sinon ils ont quearcel qui est
bloqué par les glace dans tout
l'hémisphère occidental donc c'est un
truc absolument stratégique et ils font
ils fut venir des immigrants comme les
Français ont fait venir en Algérie des
immigrants et bien il y a eu donc des
quantités de Russes qui sont allés
s'installer en Crimée et dans ces
République de donbas voilà et ces
républiques elles ont été conquises pas
sur les Ukrainiens elles ont été
conquises sur des populations musulmane
et puis il y a eu un traité de il a un
traité un nom 1784 de je sais plus quoi
j'arrive jamais à mémoriser le nom mais
qui a été avec entre entre Moscou et et
Constantinople et à partir de ce momentl
donc c'est la Russie qui a mis la main
quand au reste de ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine ça partenait ce qu'on appelait
la République des Deux Nations
c'est-à-dire polono lituanienne c'était
des polonau Lituaniens et ça n'a rien à
voir comme population c'est que les
polono-lituaniens les les les tous les
Ukrainiens du Nord du Nord-Ouest d'abord
ils sont d'église uniat qui est c'est un
peu rattaché à l'église catholique il
regarde vers l'ouest qui sont attirés
vers l'ouest voilà en revanche tout le
sud-est ce sont des orthodoxes du point
de vue religieux et ce sont des Russes
qui parlent Russ rusof et ce et comment
s'appelle-t-il Staline a trouvé malin en
1920 de faire un pays composite
justement pour essayer de faire en sorte
que les polono-lituaniens qui ont
toujours été un peu rebelles à
l'autorité à l'autorité des desza et
bien soit dans une République socialiste
soviétique où il seraiit peut-être
minorisé en tout cas ils de forte
affaire donc c'est ça le problème on a
affaire à un pays qui est un pays
ethniquement divisé quelle était ma
question la question c'était pourquoi
est-ce que l'Ukraine l'Ukraine c'est
parce que c'est le maillon faible je
vous dis la Biélorussie c'est un pays
qui est ethniquement homogène ce n'est
pas le cas de la de l'Ukraine dans
l'Ukraine il y a c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé l l'opération Barbarossa
lorsque Hitler a envoyé ses ses troupes
en 1941 en Ukraine ils sont arrivés dans
la région de Lev ils ont été acclamés
par les populations parce qu'il y avait
eu en plus la période de lolodomor
c'est-à-dire une famille probablement
organisée quoi qu' certains historiens
qui le contestent mais probablement
organisé avec des centaines de milliers
de morts sûrement avec des centaines de
VO et probablement volontairement par
Staline donc il y avait une volonté d'en
découdre de tous les polonau Lituaniens
qui haïsent les Russes ils haïssent les
Russes voilà ça c'est important à
comprendre ils ont acclamé les les les
les les troupes naz dans les premiers
temps on est au 21e siècle François
pourquoi l'Ukraine
maintenant pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
des tas de choses l'Ukraine c'est un
vase d'expansion l'Ukraine c'est un
c'est un c'est un pays également
avec les c'est les meilleures terres
arababes de l'Europe avec la France les
debout le tnosium he c'est les terres
noires comme on dit TNO ça veut dire
noir tchernoby c'est les mêmes racines
charnum c'est des Terres Noires qui sont
extrêmement voilà les grandes plaines
ukrainiennes sont très fertiles donc il
y a ça il y a c'est pas rien parce que
vous savez que Blackrock et vanggard ils
ont racheté plus de la moitié des
hectares de de terre de terre cultivable
en Ukraine c'est un pays qui sur lequel
les Américains et les fonds
d'investissement on fait main basse il
faut bien rembourser l'armement voilà
oui sans doute donc c'est un pays où les
Américains se déplace comme ils veulent
ils auraient créé ça fait partie des des
rumeurs insistantes selon lequel il y
aurait des laboratoires biologiques et
d'armement biologiques interdits
ailleurs c'est quoi vos sources bah
allez voir allez voir taper la Bour bio
mais c'est des sources émanant dans
l'entourage même de de de de de de de
Trump et qui laisse entendre que voilà
il y a des j'ai bien employé le
conditionnel he mais enfin c'est quand
même c'est quand même très très probable
qu'il y aurait eu des euh des essais de
d'armes biologiques en RA
et qu'il est très important vous avez vu
vous avez vu d'ailleurs celui qui a été
assassiné là le général russe là qui é
hier ou avanttiier quelles sont vos
suputations c'est les Ukrainiens
revendiqué d'accord mais pourquoi ils
s'occupai justement des des questions de
d'armement chimique et biologique il
était surtout en charge du
programme nucléaire aussi militaire
aussi mais aussi lui qui était en charge
du fait qu'il le ont balancé un missile
noisette et que bon les Ukrainiens ont
peut-être pas trop apprécié
ouais non je sais pas je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas peut-être réorique de
guerre froide où est-ce que ça va nous
emmener cette histoire je vous dis dis
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que du temps
de la guerre froide c'était des ration
des gens rationn des part et d'autre là
le je suis désolé ça va peut-être il y a
des gens qui vont se scandaliser mais
quelqu'un comme Poutine est quelqu'un
d'éminemment rationnel voilà et nous on
fait de l'ambiguité stratégique nousous
sommes pas
ça n'est pas je vais encore être obligé
de le citer mais rappelez-vous cette
forte parole de De Gaulle qui disait
tout au long de l'histoire de France
lorsque la France a été alliée de la
Russie ça a été des grands moments de
notre histoire ça commençait d'ailleurs
dès le 12e siècle avec le mariage de
Henri de France avec Anne de Kief
justement puisque déjà ça faisait partie
quand même de la l'influence l'influence
russe et tout au long de notre histoire
ça a été ça a été le cas en en en
comment dirais-je excusez-moi j'ai envie
d'éternuer je vous en
prie je peux faire du en attendant
comment vous voulez que je vous gratte
le nez non non non non mais tant pis si
j'étanu tant pis qu'ou euh en lorsquil y
a eu la réunion des des des des trois
empereur c'était en quoi en 1800 1807 je
crois Friedland après Friedland vous
savez que il y avait une très grande
entente entre Napoléon 1er et l'empereur
Alexandre Ier bon et
Napoléon pour des raisons qui je va pas
entrer là-dedans mais il a été entraîné
en fait à entrer en guerre contre la
Russie de GO considérait que le début du
déclin de la France datait de cette
décision c'est-à-dire que la Napoléon
est entré en guerre contre la Russie et
ça c'est comme vous le savez
extraordinairement mal terminé puisque
il a il s'est cassé les il s'est cassé
les dents ça était le début de la du du
déclin de la voilà avec la la la débacle
avec ensuite donc la la l'année 1813 qui
a été épouvantable et puis B 1814 et
cetera
et la ça illustre ce que disait de
Gaulle en en en
1914 la France en 1894 il y a le voyage
de de Nicolas 2 Alexandra ferodovna qui
viennent en France pour aller voir
féélix fort c'est la grande entance
franco-russe ça nous a énormément servi
pendant la guerre de 14 vous savez que
s'il y avait pas eu au tout début de la
guerre en 1914 s'il y avait pas eu une
offensive des rues
côte sur le flan est de l'Allemagne de
la Prusse ça a été les Prussiens ont été
obligés de retirer des divisions qu'ils
avaient prévu pour envoyir la France
pour aller se battre contre les Russes
et du coup ça a permis l'épisode des des
taxis de la Marne pour aller ça a sauvé
Paris les Russes nous ont sauvé les
Russes nous ont sauvé quand même en 1943
44 45 c'est eux qu'ont cassé Adolf
Hitler les Russes ils ont pendant Laprès
Seconde Guerre mondiale ils nous ont au
moment il y a eu des années terribles en
vous connait pas bien les années d'après
Seconde Guerre mondiale en 47 48 il y a
eu la France était quasiment au bord de
la famine en France et il y a eu les
Russes qui nous ont envoyé alors même
queex-même étaient pas cétait pas
reluisant ils nous on envoyé des des
cargaisons de de de blé pour donc
euh voilà donc il y a eu et et deg était
absolument convaincu que il était pas
communiste mais c'est lui qui a lancé la
la politique de détente en
1966 pour faire contre-poids à la
puissance aux puissances de d'Europe
centrale les états centraux c'est c'est
ça toute la pensée géopolitique
française depuis excusez-moi depuis le
12e siècle et donc actuellement
actuellement on a quand même on a quand
même des olibrius qui ne connaissent
rien à l'histoire et qui nous mettent
dans la main des Allemands contre et des
Américains contre les Russes ces
olibrius ils sont bien conseillés ils
ont bien des gens très intelligents qui
sortent de notre système scolaire
unersitaire
scientifique non qui postule qui arrive
à conseiller nos ministres non
c'est pas possible on revient au débat
que j'avais au début de cet
entretien vous avez dans la haute
fonction publique vous avez des gens qui
ont en qui qui vous savez y a une
qualité r une qualité rare sort de ce
corp il y a une question internetz j'ai
pas répondu il y a une qualité rare
qu'il faut avoir son Frid quand on
faitoui déation oui mais pas seul pas
seulement quité R qu'il faut avoir quand
vous voulez être géopoliticien ou chef
d'État c'est penser contre soi-même
c'est penser
l'impensable question internet
c'est-à-dire c'est toutes les grandes
des grands désastres nationaux c'est
quand on on a eu des responsable qui ont
refusé de penser l'impensable lorsquil y
a eu la dépêche d'Ems Bismark t un piège
à Napoléon I Bismark avait dit de
Napoléon 3 c'est une grande incompétence
méconnue c'est pas mal mais Bismark il
l'incompétence qui était é grande oui il
était d'une grande incompétence méconnue
disait Bismark de Napoléon 3 Bismark
c'est un type extrêmement intelligent av
un bateau d'ailleurs qu'on a coulé l
Bismark il fait une dépêche y a une
manipulation en fait dépêche d'Ems entre
l'ambassadeur de France qui va il y a le
le le le le comte prince le comte prince
qui je crois va prendre les EOS à à hems
bad hems et puis y a une espèce
d'embrouille qui est qui est comment
dirais-je exacerbé par l'entourage de
Bismark à Paris on apprend qu'il aurait
eu une espèce d'atteinte à l'honneur de
l'ambassadeur de France ou près de la
cour de l'empereur bon et du coup les
esprits s'échauffent il y a des gens qui
disent voilà il faut aller en guerre
contre la contre la Prusse il y a
quelques rares personnes dans
l'entourage de Napoléon I qui disent
mais attendez attendez ils viennent de
gagner les Prussiens viennent de gagner
la bataille de sadova de 1866 c'est une
date fondamentale dans l'histoire du 19e
siècle ça va ouvrir la voie à la
création de l'Empire dans l'Empire
allemand la bataille des
Détroit ils ont une armée ils ont une
armée qui qui prêt ils ont 50 % de
soldats en plus ils ont un matériel qui
qui ils sortent de victoire en victoire
et les Français nous on a quoi on a on a
une armée qui est très inférieure on a
un seul atout c'est le fusil chassep
c'est la seule chose qu'on est mais il y
a des gens dans l'entourage de de
Napoléon 3 pour flatter sa majesté
impériale qui disent maisant on est prêt
jusqu'au dernier bouton de guêre vous
connaissez cette expression on est prêt
on est prêt et il pousseent Napoléon I à
déclarer la guerre ça a été rétamé vous
savez vous savez on déclare la guerre en
quelques semaines ça s'est terminé par
le désastre de de de Sedan la fin du
Second Empire c'était quoi c'était
justement on ne pensait pas l'impensable
c'est qu'on pouvait être battu c'est ça
le truc et tout au long de notre
histoire c'est ne pas penser en
1940 c'était quoi le truc c'était que de
toute façon on avait la ligne magino oui
sauf que il y a eu l'fossif de Guderian
qui est passé par la Belgique et qui a
contourné la maginau on y avait pas
songé et là vous avez les mêmes vous
avez des Nathalie Loiseau des Jean Noël
barreau des je sais pas quoi des
Benjamin Hadad des Emmanuel Macron des
je sais pas quoi des bornes des
séjournés des trucs comme ça et
qui se sont mis dans la tête que les
Russes étaient très faibl d'ailleurs on
ça fait on nous a B sont quand même
rentrés en Ukraine oui on nous a dit
vous avez Gén un typ qui s'appelle le
général yovle il y a un truc qui
s'appelle le droit international aussi
non de quoi les Russes ils ont quand
même déclaré la guerre à l'Ukraine oui
pas vraiment déclaré la guerre ils sont
entr une opération militaire spéciale
d'accord oui mais il sont rentr avec des
tanks moi il y a quelqu'un qui rentre
avec dans un tank qui rentre chez moi
avec un
tank je suis je suis à la fois d'accord
et pas d'accord je suis d'accord pas
d'accordoc oui je sais bien je suis
d'accord parce que figurez-vous que
j'aiétaé invité encore d'ailleurs sur
Israël 24 news c'était le 15 février ou
le 12 février 2022 avant ou après la
Saint-Valentin avant l'invasion qui a eu
lieu le 20 22 février 2022 je
crois 24 février 2022 une douzaine de
jours avant j'aiété invité par Israël 24
ça vous pouvez le trouver sur internet
et on parlait beaucoup de bruit de botes
il y avait les armées russes qui étaient
proches et on m'a posé la question dit
si les Russes interviennent est-ce que
vous condamnerez je l'ai dit j'ai oui
j'éta le premier à dire oui je
condamnerai parce que effectivement
c'est pas bien c'est je pense qu'il vaut
mieux régler ça par la Cour
internationale de justice par les
organismes appropriés de des Nations
Unies bon euh donc je ne vais pas dire
le contraire mais il y a quand même un
mais c'est que dans le droit
international public il est aussi prévu
que le concept lorsque de de d'avoir une
espèce de lorsqu'on est menacé de mener
une espèce de guerre préventive les
Occidentaux ne se sont pas dilleurs
gênés pour le faire dans beaucoup de de
théâtres récents d'opération et donc par
exemple par exemple ce ce ce genre de
chose et euh et par ailleurs euh si vous
voulez il y a toujours quelque chose qui
me gêne dans les débats actuels c'est le
le c'est à partir de quand on commence à
regarder l'histoire si le le problème
par exemple du 7 octobre les attentats
du Hamas c'est horrible mais l'histoire
n'a pas commencé le 7
octobre VO on a quand même en France
toute une série de gens qui voudraient
faire croire que tout allait pour le
mieux dans le meilleur des monde d'un
seul coup il y a les horribles personnes
du Hamas qui sont venus faire un
attentat ce qui est vrai que c'était
horrible mais il y avait quand même il y
avait des années
mais c'est pareil pour l'Ukraine les
trucs n'ont pas commencé le 24 février
2022 c'est qu'auparavant il y a eu des
années et des années auparavant
notamment depuis le maïan où dès que le
régime de de Kief a été abattu comme je
disais tout à l'heure par Madame
Victorian Hollande dans les jours qui
ont suivi ils ont installé une dizaine
de bases de la CIA le long de la
frontière russe les les Russes le
savaient il s'est passé les accords de
Minsk 1 et Minsk 2 rappelez-vous ce qui
s'est passé dans la capitale biélorusse
avec les Russes les Ukrainiens le
nouveau régime les améri américains je
crois en tout cas il y non il y a pas
les Américains mais il y avait en tout
cas madame Angela Merkel et et François
Hollande qui étaaiit là et il y a eu un
accord parce que ce que demandait
Poutine et honnêtement honnêtement c'est
quand même raisonnable il demandait que
les populations russophone et russophil
du sud-est de l'Ukraine je vous ai
expliqué tout à l'heure ne soissent pas
l'objet de persécution permanente parce
que c'était de ça qu'il s'agissait il y
a eu rappelez-vous ce drame de la maison
des syndicats à Odessa où des gens
étaient brûlés vifs il y a eu des
bombardements systématiques de ces
populations à partir du changement de
régime parce qu'avant lorsque l'Ukraine
est devenue indépendante en
1991 enfin vous savez toute l'histoire
de l'Ukraine l'hoire récente c'est que
la Crimée n'a jamais été ukrainienne
c'est en
1954 que krouchov pour des motifs peu
clairs on dira ça comme ça pour des
motifs peu clairs krouchov en 1954 pour
le 300e anniversaire du Traité de
peryoslav de 1654 qui avait rattaché
tout l'est du nièpre à la Russie avec
notamment la ville de Kiev c'était la
rousse de Kiev comme on dit c'est à
partir de ce momentlà qu'on parlera
d'ailleurs de l'empereur de toutes les
Russies à partir de ce moment-là donc
une grande partie de l'Ukraine est
rattachée à l'Empire darist en 1954
crruschof décidé de faire don de la
Crimée avec le port de sébastopole à
l'Ukraine c'est une histoire incroyable
à l'époque c'était l'URSS donc tout le
monde pensait que ça serit pas c'était
pas très grave sauf qu'en
1991 comme comme la cession de
territoire avait été fait dans des
termes traité en 1991 lorsque l'Ukraine
est devenue indépendante elle est partie
avec la avec la Crimée où il y avait le
port absolument stratégique pour l'armée
russe donc ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les premiers dirigeants de l'Ukraine
indépendante ont eu la sagesse de
comprendre qu'ils avaient une
souveraineté un petit peu limité
voilà ben notamment voilà et puis avec
les populations russophones on tire pas
le les les moustaches de l'ours rus qui
est juste à côté voilà ils ont dit c'est
comme le Canada le Canada va pas
installer des bases russes le long de la
en Alberta le long de la la frontière
avec les États-Unis vous imaginez ou le
Mexique il peut pas non plus installer
des bases militaires chinoises le du Rio
Grande face à la Californie à l'Arizona
c'est un simple principe de bon sens
donc les les dirigeants Ukrainiens des
premiers temps ils ont donc intégré la
la la Crimée qui était une province
Ukraine devenue une province ukrainienne
peuplé à 99 % de russophone vent
d'autant plus qu'il y avait des Tatars
de Crimée mais qui avaient été déporté
du temps de Staline pour collaboration
avec les nazis soit dit en passant et
les les les les dirigeants de Kiev ont
signé un bail anfitéotique de mise à
disposition de la base militaire auprès
des Russes voilà c'est-à-dire que bien
sûr ils auraient pu ils auraient pu ne
pas le faire mais ils ont ils ont bien
compris qu'il fallait qu'ils le fasse
voilà on ne peut retire pas au russes un
pays de 17 million de kilmè Carr et
cetera qui a la deuxème puissance
militaire mondiale on lui retire pas lui
retire pas sa base militaire stratégique
de la marine russe donc les les premiers
dirigeants yanusenko et cetera c'était
des des des Ukrainiens mais qui avaient
trouvé un modus vivindi avec avec la
Russie donc il et tout le problème vient
lorsque il y a eu des perspectives
d'entré dans l'Union européenne et qui
ont zappé puisque il faut bien
comprendre que vu du point de vue Moscou
l'Ukraine entrant dans l'Union
européenne et dans l'OTAN c'est le
triomphe de la stratégie
deinskski dont je parlais tout à l'heure
donc c'est INAC c'est un chiffon rouge
al on peut le regretter il y a des gens
qui disent c'est
scandaleux les Ukrainiens sont
souverains bien sûr que les Ukrainiens
sont souverains pourquoi quoi pourquoi
depuis les 15 dernières années ben parce
que les Américains ont décidé de de
renverser le régime avec l'affaire du ma
c'est une révolution de couleur qui a
été entièrement manipulée par les
Américains alors pourquoi ils l'ont fait
mais ça s'inscrit sans doute dans la
recomposition enfin j'ai pas arrivé par
exemple le projet pour un New
Century comment for new American century
oui c'est ça mais il y avait la
recomposition de tout le de tout le de
tout le le Moyen-Orient par exemple avec
des des cartes qui ont circulé vous
lisez ça vous ah bah oui quand même je
me renseigne mais vous avez le truc pour
le nouveau le nouveauent je dire c'est
tout bête ce que je dis il y a des
cartes qui circulé dans la dans la la
revue des vétérans américain vous savez
qu' aux États-Unis les vétérans les
anciens combattants sont vraiment très
très très mis en avant mais on un pays
très patriotique sur le trottoir oui
mais quand même il y a quand même tout
un ils on d'ailleurs des anciens
combattants récents avant parte vers une
trajectoire encore alors attendez je
termine mon propos et bien dans ce dans
ce dans cette revue des anciens des
cette revue des anciens combattants
américains en 2002 ou 2003 il y a eu un
un une carte du nouveau Moyen-Orient tel
que le conceva les États-Unis et
qu'est-ce qu'on apprenait là on
apprenait que il était prévu que la
Turquie perde l'Anatolie de l'Est pour
former un Kurdistan on apprenait que
l'Arabie Saoudite serait coupé en
morceaux avec un état sacré qui serait à
l'Est comportant les villes de Médine
donc là où il y a la tombe du Prophète
et de la Mecque et il y aurait un état
de l'Ouest qui est lui serait l'état où
il y a les champs de pétrole et de gaz
bon vous êtes Erdogan ou vous êtes
Mohamed Ben Salman péle mais vous êtes
fur quand vous voyez ça vous dites
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça donc vous
prenez vous prenez vos distances avec
les États-Unis c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est ce qui se passe normalement
l'Arabie Saoudite et la Turquie étaient
des alliés très fidèles des États-Unis
vous savez bien ils jouent un double jeu
mais voà question
Internet vous pourriez lui demander s'il
a déjà changé d'avis je vois un homme
plein de
certitude vous pouvez l'inviter à penser
contre
lui-même est-ce que vous pensez contre
vous-même de temps en temps ben oui mais
le problème si vous voulez c'est que
alors déjà c'est mal me connaître parce
que je suis quelqu'un qui justement oui
j'ai bien compris
euh mais
eu j'invite cette ce ce cette personne à
aller regarder d'abord à lire la charte
de
lupè qui a été écrite il y a elle est en
ligne depuis 17 ans mais enfin depuis le
mars 2007 2007 vous étiez encore blond
mais allez qui la regarde la chart de
lupère vous étiez blond avant non j'ai
châtin jamais été blond j'étais châtin
c'est difficile de vous déconcentrer
hein non mais parce que vous me posez
des questions ça me tient à cœur parce
que la dernière fois que vous avez pensé
contre vous c'était
quoi la dernière fois que vous êtes
trompé c'était quand et c'était sur
honnêtement ça peut m'arriver d'ailleurs
j'ai dit que je mis je métais un peu
leuré c'était sur la personnalité de
Barnier je pensais que Barnier alors je
sais qu'il y avait des gens qui
m'avaient dit que c'était un con
on on ne collepte pas la
calomnie en tout cas que c'était
quelqu'un de très moi je ne pensais pas
il se trouve que je l'avais connu un
petit peu honnêtement je pensais que
dans ma tête je pensais qu' son son
intérêt personnel qui qui était
l'intérêt de la France en même temps
c'était que il se démarque totalement de
Macron les Français ils ont pas élu ils
ont pas voté pour avoir marnié Premier
ministre ni
Beyou ils ont voté pour se débarrasser
de Macron les Français ne Macron
excusez-moi cette expression les debect
voilà ils ne ils ne veulent plus en
entendre 80 % des Français ne veulent
plus en entendre parler c'est quo la
source de ce
chiffre les sondages de popularité ou ou
les votes d'ailleurs aux européennes
regardez la liste de Valérie à combien
elle a fait aux européennes en nombre
d'inscrits je crois que le nombre
d'inscrits il y a dû avoir 13 % de gens
qui ont voté pour la liste Val aux
européennes en nombre d'inscrits en
nombre de votants ça va être 17 18 %.
donc les Français ils ont voté et donc
je pensais que quelqu'un comme Barnier
je pensais qu'il avait il a quoi 73 ans
honnêtement je me disais il a il a plus
grand chose à perdre à 73 ans bon et
donc il avait l'occasion de de vraiment
de marquer un grand coup de d'essayer de
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui épargé
qui a été toujours un peu dans la même
famille politique bon il a déjà
travaillé cet hommeel avant comment il a
déjà travaillé avant bah il a été il a
fait un cursus de de de de politicien il
a il a eu il a eu nombreux postes alors
travailler dans une entreprise je suis
pas sûr même pas du tout je pense mais
il a été président du conseil général de
de de la de la Haute Savoie il a été
ministre Affaires étrangères les
affaires européennes commissaire
européen vice-président de la Commission
européenne négociateur du brexit enfin
il en fait des truc et là je me suis
trompé je l'ai dit effectivement j'ai
surestimé je ne pensais pas qu'il a
qu'il avait fait ça donc je reconnais
volontier que j'ai pu me tromper mais
c'est pas des certitudes ça c'est et
parce qu'il y a quelquees jours de
polémique dans la question que vous
m'avez posé euh c'est que de polémique
de vous demander si vous dire que j'ai
des certitudes parce que c'est pas des
certitudes c'est comme des gens parfois
il y a des gens qui me disent je suis
pas d'accord avec vos
idées accordons-nous sur ce désaccord
oui mais non parce que je dis mais c'est
pas des idées ce sont des faits quand
j'explique par exemple qu'on peut pas
changer les traités européens puisqu'il
faut la l'unanimité c'est pas une idée
c'est un fait lors ceque j'explique que
vous avez des responsables politiques
qui vous promettent Mons et merveilles
tout en restant dans le cadre européen
et que c'est que ce me des Français ça
n'est pas une idée fait qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est-ce que vous nous promettez
vous je promets la première chose que je
promets son des larmes oui peut-être
mais non ce que je promets déjà c'est
tout faire c'est ce que je fais quand
même depuis 17 ans c'est de tout faire
pour d'abord pour sauver mon pays parce
que honnêtement la France est
honnêtement très mal partie je pense
vraiment ça va se terminer qument j'en
sais rien mais vraiment elle est très
mal partie et du fait il faut que les
Français se ressaisissent c'est une
catastrophe et ce que je me suis promis
c'est d'essayer toujours de dire ce que
je crois être la vérité c'est-à-dire la
réalité parce que les gens disent oui
vous savez la vérité non c'est la
réalité c'est la réalité lorsque je vois
des d'ailleurs je suis la personne en
question qu'elle aille voir par exemple
toutes mes conférences qui sont en ligne
depuis 17 ans et qu'elle voit si ce que
j'ai dit a été démenti ou non par les
faits ce qui fait que actuellement il y
a de plus en plus de gens qui nous
rallent ou qui qui nous copient c'est
parce que avec les analyses que je
fournis depuis 17 ans ils se rendent
compte que non seulement ça explique ce
qu'ils ne comprenaient pas mais que ça
leur permet de prévoir ce qui va se
passer ça leur permet de prévoir et donc
c'est ça qui est le plus c'est ce que
Nietzsche appelait les faits et le
formidable éloquence moi ce que je dis
ce sont des faits ce sont des articles
des traités rappelez-vous d'ailleurs
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
2017 j'ai arrivé de citer des articles
destaités gen l'article machin l'article
truc voilà et vous savez ce qui s'était
passé c'est que on ricanit de moi il y a
des journalistes qui m'avaient dit que
j'étais une espèce de professeur Nimbus
oh oui mais c'est le mec qui cite des
articles des traités c'est-à-dire que
c'était compté à mon détriment c'est
incroyable c'est que on a l'impression
que les Français il voudrai en fait
qu'on leur raconte des des boniments je
veux dire quand vous allez chez un
médecin ou chez un avocat par exle vous
avez un problème avec votre patron et
vous
voulez avocat vous préférez avoir un
avocat qui connaît parfaitement bien le
droit du travail qui vous dit voilà les
arétat alors qu'un autre qui dit ouais
je sais pas mais je vais regarder enfin
c'est quoi il faut il faut c'est c'est
là où j'en reviens à cet enseignement
que donnait deg don c que je CIS tout à
l'heure il faut aller au fond des choses
il faut aller au fond des choses
qu'est-ce que vous promettez je
promets'estce que vous promettez sur la
dette qu'est-ce que vous promettez pour
les impôts qu'est-ce que vous promettez
pour la
réindustrialisation on ne pourra
pas réindustrialiser la France vous
tenenez pas vos promesses qu'est-ce
qu'on vous fait oh mais moi j'avais dans
mon programme j'avais j'avais prévu dans
mon programme et qui n'a jamais été
diffusé d'ailleurs par les médias mais
tout le monde peut le trouver en ligne
al il y a des gens qui disent oui j'ai
vu ça aussi il y a des gens qui
disentino mais le le type il est
monoménal qui veut sortir de l'Europe
c'est c'est tout son programme mais pas
du tout j'ai un programme taper aselino
programme présidentielle 2022 c'est
quand même pas compliqué asino vous
tapez ça sur GO PASF vous tombez dessus
avec un Z
aslino vous tombez dessus il y a il y a
27 chapitres voilà plus 1 d'ailleurs
c'était un clin d'œil avec les 27 état
plus he et on il y a un programme sur la
culture sur l'éducation sur la sécurité
sur les impôts sur la réduction des de
la de la dette et des voilà il y avait
tout un programme notamment de réduction
des dépenses de l'État
je peux ici le développer on sort de
l'Union européenne on économise bon
Malan à peu près 20 milliards d'euros on
fait défoncer notre dette sur les
marchés non parce que les marchés
financiers il faut arrêter ça cette
histoire là les les responsables
financiers ENF les gens sur les marchés
conissez B j'en connais j'en ai connu
bon c'est pas une entité
mystérieuse il y a ce qu'un financier
déteste le plus c'est
l'incertitude c'est ça actuellement il y
a une très grande incertitude sur la
situation de la France c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que le spread la différence
entre les taux d'intérêts sur
l'obligation assimable du Trésor à 10
ans français et le bound d'allemand à 10
ans ne cesse que de s'accroître bon il y
a une très grande incertitude c'est la
raison pour laquelle aussi vous savez
que les Allemands seront peut-être les
premiers à sortir de de l'euro aussi on
en parle jamais en franceve que
alternative vous savez qu'il va y avoir
élections législatives le 17 février
prochain je crois en Allemagne
alternative F qui un peu l'équivalent du
R eux ils ont maintenant inscrit dans
leur programme le dexit la sortie de
l'Union européenne bon c'est sans doute
pas eux qui arriveront au pouvoir c'est
probablement monsieur Friedrich mer de
la coalition cdou csou mais qui sait et
je peux vous dire que dans la dans dans
l'établissement
allemand il faut lire un journal qui
s'appelle la phase la Frankfort ALG
c'est le journal général de Franfort
c'est le siège de la BCE là vous avez
toutes les élites économiques et
financières de
l'Allemagne il sont extrêmement inquiet
de la situation de l'euro je peux vous
ouvrir une parenthèse François oui bon
on va bosser vous et moi ensemble sur le
cas de l'Allemagne tout de suite
d'accord
admettons le parti en question arrive au
pouvoir oui il nous f Il nous font un
dexit un Dutch exit dans l'état actuel
des choses en Allemagne vous pensez que
ça va leur faire tout drôle ou tout tout
tout tout drôle ils ont plus d'énergie
ils ont plus de centrale nucléaire ils
ont une coalition bitnique qui ne
s'entendent plus ils peuvent pas faire
de la dette il ils sortent de
l'euro et les Allemands il faut prier
pour eux maintenant ça va mal se passer
pour eux oui mais
écoutez vousêtes d'accord ouêes pas
d'accord Oui mais ou est-ce que ça ira
mieux pour eux on revient à un débat que
qu'on a esquissé tout à l'heure question
simple oui ça va être bien pour les
Allemands ou ça sera pas bien pour les
Allemands il y a dans la vie euh des
grand choix à faire ou
la souveraineté nationale l'indépendance
nationale c'est un absolu on ne peut pas
avoir un pays en tout cas pas les
Français qui où le peuple ne soit pas
maître de son destin c'est aussi simple
que ça c'estàd que les gens qui pour
l'Allemagne ou pour la France invoquent
des questions conjoncturelles j'ai
jamais dit que sortir de l'euro sera une
Valé de rose bien sûr mais c'est pas de
ma faute hein moi j'ai voté non à
Maastricht j'ai voté NON à la consti
européenne moi j'ai soutenu des gens
comme Philipp sin comme Charles Pasco
donc c'est pas de ma faute voilà oui
mais on en a si vous voulez comm il vaut
mieux la fin du malheur qu'un malheur
sans fin il faut il faut mieux regardez
regardez ce s passé avec la Russie par
exemple on est dans la même situation
que la fin du RSS il y avait des gens
qui disaient on peut pas sortir de de la
construction du socialisme ça serait une
épouvante mais ça s'est effondré parce
que ça n'était pas viable et
effectivement les anné qui ont suivi la
fin de l'Union soviétique ça était assez
gratiné vous avez des pays que des des
républiques qui sont devenu
indépendantes qui ont vu leur PIB
intérieur qu effondré le 40 % c'est vrai
d'illeurs ils ont tous recréé ils ont
tous créé leur propre monnaie soit dit
en passant ils avaient une monnaie
commune c'était même une monnaie unique
puisqu'il y avait simplement une banque
centrale non c'est une monnaie mais il y
avait une c'était le rouble soviétique
ils ont tous créé leur propre monnaie
les oubecs ont créé le Somon la la
l'Ukraine a créé la rivnia et cetera le
bon la Lettonie a créé le lats et cetera
ils ont tous créé leur monnaie ils en
ont bavé pendant quelques années mais
allez voir maintenant des Russes ou des
pays personne ne veut revenir dans
l'URSS enfin si il y a des nostalgiques
mais il représente 20 % de la population
à tout cassé ou 15 % donc les gens ils
savent quand même par exemple moi je
suis allé en URSS en sortant de l'EN en
1985 essayz de vous tamponner déjà à
l'époque que vous appelez tamponner
recruter bon j'étais allé avec on était
quelques copains de Lena c'était on
sortait de Lena en 1985 en juillet 95
gorbachov venait d'arriver au pouvoir il
était arrivé au pouvoir le 11 mars 85 et
l'Occident était très inquiet pourquoi
parce que c'était on une série de Géront
il y avait brej nef à la fin il était
très il était sénil lui avait succédé en
dropof qui était pas mal mais qui avait
qui avait rapidement sombré dans la
Séité puis ensuite chernienko alors lui
il avait tenu je crois un an et demi il
était il était quasiment gâteux et puis
d'un seul coup arrive gorbachchov qui a
58 ans il y en a pour combien de temps
pour la petite histoire là bah
c'est 2 minutes
allez vous voulez pas que je raconte des
petites là alors ben on va là-bas et
l'Occident était très inquiet pourquoi
parce que les gens se disent en Occident
waouh c'est un type il a été à la tête
du KGB le KGB c'était la seule
institution en Union soviétique qui
savait ce qui se passait vraiment à
l'étranger qui tiraent la sonnette
d'alarme sans arrêt bon et donc qu'il
arrive on il était présenté dans les les
dans les journaux les médias occidentaux
comme le dur un dur à cuire c'était pas
du tout la molacerie de de de de
charlino c'était vraiment indible dans
la force de l'âge 58 ans à la tête du
KGB donc les gens avaient été très très
inquiets de ça il arrive la première
chose qu'il fait campagne
anti-alcoolique parce que les gens
picolaient voilà parce que on avait
l'Union soviétique vers la fin c'est un
pays un peuple à qui on avait imposé un
avenir la construction du socialisme
était une vérité
scientifique voilà et si vous contestiez
cette vérité scientifique si vous étiez
un altern on dit en russe quelqu'un qui
pense autrement c'était direction
l'asile psychiatrique parce que vous
étiez fous on est dans la même sché dans
le même schéma les gens qui à notre
époque ce que je fais depuis ouvertement
depuis bientôt 18 ans qui conteste le
principe de la le principe de base de la
construction européenne et c'est
considéré comme un fou donc c'est ce qui
se passait en USS le problème c'est
qu'on a verrouillé l'avenir d'un peuple
et qui constatait que les promesses
n'étaient jamais tenues qu'en fait
c'était une dégringola tout simplement
parce que lorsqu'on retire à un à des
gens à des citoyens la notion de profit
individuel se dévouer pour la
collectivité le
stacanovisme il connaissez le stakanovis
savez d'ailleurs que stacanovis était un
mineur russe du
donbas toute la la la la comment
dirais-je les bondieuseries rougge
staliniennees sur le stakanov et le
stacanovi ça se passe au
donbas on disait donc à part ça si vous
voulez ben dans pas seulement en Russie
mais dans dans tout le partout où on a
fait la la la collectivisation des
terres d'industrie et cetera partout
dans toutes les sur toutes les latitudes
toutes les longitudes toutes les
civilisations toutes les religions
toutes les écritures ça a amené en fait
à au fait que les gens à partir du
moment où ils ont plus un intérêt
individuel à travailler ben ils se
laissent aller voilà et donc partout
c'est un affaiblissement du truc et donc
ce qu'avait voulu faire Gorbatchov il
s'attaquait aux conséquences les
conséquences c'est que c'est un peuple
qui avait perdu tout espoir tout était
verrouillé et il faisait quoi il
picolait c'était le jeanfoutisme au
boulot et c'était l'envie d'émigrer
c'était ça et donc Gorbatchov il
s'attaque à
ça aujourd'hui en France on assiste à
quoi on assiste à un peuple qui est
privé de son avenir on est prié de
considérer que la France sauf quelques
cas très dés isolat très particuliers
comme le jeux olympiques et cetera
encore que la cérémonie d'ouvertu il a
des choses à dire dessus mais on a privé
on est les Français sont priés de sont
sommé de savoir que leur avenir c'est
fusionneré avec la Lettonie et Chypre ça
marche pas vous avez jamais fusionné
avec la lonie d'autant plus d'ailleurs
d'autant plus d'ailleurs que la
composition les les
compositions anthropologiques des des
des des pays d'Europe change à tout
allure que la France est beaucoup elle
est beaucoup plus tournée vers les pays
du Maghreb que vers les pays baltes
c'est une évidence donc c'est une
évidence ce que je dis on peut le
regarder mais c'est une évidence bon et
donc les les les les les les les les
Français aujourd'hui il picolent il se
droguent il consomment des anxolitiques
on est devenu les champion du monde
l'augmentation des onxiolitiques des
antidépresseurs à grimpé de 150 % en 15
ans c'est énorme
on est il y a de la consommation de
drogue absolument partout ce qui va
d'ailleurs de pair avec l'augmentation
de la criminalité à travers toute la
France au
passage par ailleurs c'est le G foutis
quand même beaucoup de G foutis un peu
partout et enfin le dernier point les
migration vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
n'envisagent qu'une chose c'est de s'en
aller la petite histoire historique est
passée une comparaison question
internet monsieurlino pouvez-vous nous
présenter une idée originale et concrète
pour la trè guerre mondiale en tant que
France sans recourir à des exemples
historiques ni nous rediriger vers des
sources
externes c'est TR
conc le problème c'est que moi je
suis je suis pas aux affaires ok si
j'étais si
j'étais siétaisc j'arrête immédiatement
tout tout versement à
l'ukrainearrte ction je fais je fais ce
que fait pas du défensif on leur file
quoi on le on leur don on leur donne pas
enfin écoutez il faut arrêter de croire
que ce sont les Russes qui ont attaqué
les premiers oui d'une certaine oui mais
non parce que comme je vous l'ai dit ce
sont les pendant de 2014 à 202 à 2022
pendant 8 ans les les populations du
donbas ont été martyrisé et on tout à
l'heure je parlais de Minsk 2 mais on
s'est interrompu mais Minsk 2 ce qui s
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop mettez-vous du pensez contre
vous-même mettez-vous du côté ukrainien
on va réfléchir ensemble h les
Ukrainiens ils voyaient tout un côté de
leur
pays avec les pieds dans de l'or que ce
soit la terre Arab les terres rares
quelques centrales thermiquees et j'en
passent des meilleurs se russifié d'une
façon non très très agressive avec des
pisomes en vert
et ils sont dit dans quelques temps ces
gensl ils vont n poser des problèmes ils
vont être
sécessionnistes et ils vont se
barrer non envisag c'est pas envisable
c'est une population russe ce sont des
Russes écoutez allez j'avais publié sur
j'ai fait quelle était la question
d'internet donc ce qu'il faudrait mon
pouvez-vous nous présenter une idée
originale et concrète pour éviter la trè
guerre mondiale sans recourir à des
exemples historiques ni nous rediriger
vers des sources exter
si j'étais le président de la République
d' on ne serait pas dans cette panade
premièrement serait pire non non ça me
fait mal au cœur honnêtement je vous
assure c'est d'ailleurs se demander si
c'est pas du sabotage organisé ce qu'il
faudrait faire jour ça oui ce qu'il
faudrait faire aujourd'hui c'est que la
France la France elle est d'ailleurs
jusqu'au bouiste regardez madame Belloni
ou ou monsieur schz même eux même eux ne
veulent pas envoyer d'armement offensif
contre la Russie ils ont fé quand même
des missiles scalp non c'est nous les
missiles scalp comment ça les les Russes
oui mais ils ont demandé que ça soit pas
utilisé et et c'est les les c'est les
Anglais les Anglo-Américains on est
complètement la main des
anglo-américains donc voilà ce qu'il
faudrait faire mais il faudrait pas
nommer nommer des des des ministres
d'affaires étrangères qui n'y
connaissent rien il faudrait dire que on
arrête de faire des sanctions contre la
Russie il faudrait qu'on appelle à des
négociations il faudrait dire que la
c'est C c'est une folie il a 500000
morts côté côté ukrainien et peut-être
60000 morts côté russe combien 60000
morts côté russe non ça doit être
beaucoup plus que ça quand même non je
crois que c'est à peu près un rapport de
ind d'accord les chiffres il viennent
d'où oh ben vous vous en avez qui vous
permettent de dire que c'est pas chat
GPT ça va entre 60 et 250000 mais bon
ils doivent avoir les mêmes chiffres que
vous bah oui en tout cas il y a beaucoup
plus de mors qu' ukrainien il y a aussi
quelque chose qu'il faut sortir de se
sortir de l'esprit c'est que tous les
Ukrainiens ne sont pas d'accord vous
avez vu comment il y a énormément
d'Ukrainiens qui sont partis qui n'ont
pas envie de se faire enrôler énormément
de Russes qui sont barrés aussi
d'Ukraine non de de Russie ah non pas
tellement il y en a sans doute mais pas
tellement pas tellement je suis sui vous
avez suivi le prix des billets d'avion
des pays limitrophes de la Russie oui
mais ça c'est parce qu'il y a plus de
ligne aérienne moi je sais pour aller à
Moscou par exemple là où moi j'y étais
allé quand j'étais allé on avait été les
seuls à avoir été invité en 2015 pour
fêter la victoire de 70e anniversaire la
victoire sur le nazisme j'avais été
invité par Sébastopol et à l'époque
c'est non cétait un vol Paris Moscou
Moscou simferopool allerretour ça
coûtait 360 € sur Air frrance et
aéroflotte vous rendez compte en 2015
mais maintenant je sais pas j'ai pas
regardé mais je crois que ça doit être
faut multiplier au moins par peut-être
par par presque 10 ça 2500 € et vous
passez pas par là vous passez par la
Turquie par je sais pas quoi c'est c'est
devenu très
compliqué question Internet
vous y avez répondu vous voulez
compléter
amender la quelle question sur la
proposition originale pour AR été la 3è
guerre mondiale on continue avoir une
d'abord il y a quelque chose vous savez
qui est important c'est que j'ai reçu à
uper TV on va sortir la vidéo d'ailleurs
demain sans doute j'ai reçu le le chargé
d'affaires de la Biélorussie du Bélarus
qui est quand même le pays de la ville
de Minsk il y a pas d'ambassadeur hein
par parce que l'ambassadeur de France
qui avait été envoyé à Minsk a refusé de
présenter ses lettes de créance à
lukachchenko donc il avait eu un
agrément au bout de 11 mois ils ont
l'agrément est tombé donc il est reparti
bon qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire aussi je ne sais pas ça me
paraît bizarroïde donc du coup les les
relations sont tombées au niveau des
chargés d'affair donc j'ai reçu vous
verrez cette interview qui est
intéressante où j'ai pas ménagé
d'ailleurs mes questions je lui ai
demandé comment ça se passe voilà
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que comment il
voit les choses qu'est-ce qu'il a à
répondre aux gens qui disent que le le
régime est une dictature et ca vous vous
verrez mais ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que ce ce monsieur qui est chargé
d'affair du Bélarus en France depuis je
crois maintenant 2021 il n'a jamais vu
Macron jamais vu le ministre français
des Affaires étrangères jamais vu le
ministre des affaires européennes
jamaisz quoi bon il a peut-être vu des
copains non il est reçu par des des
fonctionnaires du cador de temps en
temps voilà le la rus c'est quand même
un pays qui est quand même dans un TER
de ENF ne serait-ce que ça on touche du
doigt ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur le problème de la rationalité on a
en France des gens qui ne veulent même
pas discuter le principe même d'un
diplomate enfin me semble-t-il c'est de
discuter avec son adversaire c'est c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui veut la paix ne part
pas de par des de fermeture de
principe normalement il faut discuter
avec les gens et mais il faut discuter
avec avec le avec de la bonne foi et
avec de la logique vous avez connu
beaucoup de diplomates français dans
votre vie ah oui j'en ai vu quand même
pas mal oui connu plus en détail bah
j'ai été pendant un an et demi d'abord
j'avais fait mon serviceal comme je vous
l'ai dit mais j'ai été pendant un an et
demi au cabinet de de HERV de Charret
ministre d'affaires étrangères donc là
j'ai vu quand même beaucoup de
d'ambassadeurs non mais vous les avez vu
ok vous avez déjà taper le poker avec
eux bu des coups non je ne pense je avec
leurs femmes non oui ça arrivriver oui
oui et donc la mentalité du diplomate
français c'est quoi c'est de discuter ou
de respecter la voix du patron qui se
trouve à l' liser c'est discuter prendre
du renseignement faire remonter le
renseignement au patron ou c'est
simplement la tête de gondole de la
France à distribuer lesile parce que
vous avez il y a différentes
personnalités qui me viennent à l'esprit
vous avez un petit peu il faut se garer
toujours des généralités vous avez vous
avez des ambassadeurs ça dépend aussi il
y a des ambassadeurs qui étaient
répertoriés comme plutôt de gauche qui
av été nommé parmi Terran d'autres comme
plutôt de droite il y avait des
ambassadeurs
qui
était qui avait une nature très très
très obséquieuse vis-à-vis de son
ministre voilà donc il était toujours de
la vie du ministre il y a une tendance
assez naturelle des ambassadeurs de tous
les pays du monde d'ailleurs souvent un
ambassadeur c'est quelqu'un qui a
tendance à devenir autant l'ambassadeur
du pays où il est à crédité auprès de
ses propres autorités que l'inverse je
m'explique c'est par exemple il y a des
cas de de où il y a eu des conflits
entre la France et un autre état et
l'ambassadeur de France dans l'autre
État venant à Paris allant voir le
ministreen disant attendez vous faites
vraiment des sotises là il y a vraiment
ça j'en ai vu des cas comme ça en disant
voilà et là il était presque il
défendait presque les intérêts du pays
oquel était accrédité mais c'est pas
tous il y en a d'autres qui en revanche
considère que non il faut que la France
doit avoir raison et il y a
malheureusement une tentation qui s'est
développé dans un PI un certain nombre
d'années qui est plutôt de promouvoir
des ambassadeurs qui ont C cet esprit de
de ne jamais dire non au ministrees
c'est ça qui c'est ça qui va pas ou de
démissionner ou d'viter d'écrire des
lettres ça c'est rare question internet
que pensent-t-il de musque moi que je
pense d'
musque alors en
short je pense que c'est honnêtement
honnêtement en un mot c'est c'est un mot
galvodé mais c'est quand même vrai je
pense c'est un génie c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de génial alors il a des
qualités des défauts il a des comme
beaucoup de comme beaucoup de de de
génie mais c'est qu'il a quand même d'un
côté génial enfin rendez compte il est
devenu quand même le premier homme du
monde à avoir une fortune qui dépasse
400 milliards de dollars et avec C la
valorisation de SpaceX et cetera et
alors il y a une particularité des
États-Unis qui est une particularité
sympathique des États-Unis euh c'est que
aux États-Unis il y a une tradition je
vous ai pas demandé ça question internet
c'est très utile de parler de la chute
de l'URSS pour lui demander alors pour
lui dans combien de temps pour l'Union
européenne 1 an 2 ans ou 3
ans alors là je répondrai comme dans les
Saintes Écritures nul ne sait le jour ni
l'heure on a quand même le sentiment
quira qui vivra verra c'est ça non on a
quand même le sentiment moi le le
diagnostic que j'ai porté depuis même
avant la création de de de l'uppr c'est
que ce système n'est pas
viable si je veux faire un peu de de si
je veux prendre de la hauteur de vue
essayer de de de creuser le futur de
d'avoir des idées sur le futur je pense
que nous avons affaire à ce qu'on
appelle un système clos en terme
philosophique une idéologieque c'est un
système close c'est-à-dire que à partir
du moment où vous entrez dedans vous
êtes voilà vous vous n'êtes vous pvez
pas le soit vous vous détachez vous
décrivez le système so vous commencez à
entrer dedans vous n'en sortez pas un
système cl une idé comme celle-là elle a
a une direct propre aux
idées que je chiffre à peu près à tro
générations voilà la construction du
socialisme 1910 non 1917 1991 74 ans des
génération de 3 xis 25 ans voilà donc
c'est parce que la première la première
c'est c'est les
pionniers les les les ceux qui ont
participé à la révolution ils y croient
vraiment vraiment dur comme fait les
deuxè ce sont les ce sont les les gens
qui sont nés là-dedans et qui il croient
encore à moitié les troisèmes c'est
c'est les faussoyeurs ce sont des gens
qui n'y croient plus du tout mais qui
font carrière c'est les gorbachov et
cetera et je pense qu'on est arrivé dans
la on a eu la phase des prionniers les
Robert Schumann alite de
gasperéry et
cetera Jean Monet à la limite mais
c'était un agent américain ou comment il
s'appelle Conrad adener donc là c'est
les pères fondateurs après vous avez la
période des la 2e génération c'est c'est
Jacques Delor et cetera euh oui
peut-être Jacques Delor et cetera et et
puis là on est la 3è génération des gens
comme voilà Macron et cetera ce sont des
gens ils ne font que carrière ils ont
compris ils ont compris c'est le
théorème de de de de mitéran hashira on
peut plus devenir Président si on est
contre l'Europe et donc si si on fait 74
ans 75 ans à partir de 1917 on tombe sur
91 92 si on fait 75 ans
à partir de du traité de Rome de
1957 ça nous fait à peu près encore 8
ans on est dans les temps je pense que
je pense que peut-être alors ça dépend
si on parle à partir de 57 traité de R
ou à partir de la déclaration Chan de 51
ou
quelqu'un si vous étiez élu est-ce que
vous pensez faire une politique à la
tronçonneuse à la
M
alors ce que je pense c'est qu'il faut
avoir pour ça la France est quand même
un pays très particulier hein c'est
quand même un pays qui est considéré
comme le pays un des pays les plus
difficiles du monde à à gérer parce que
c'est le peuple gaulois il faut on peut
ne faire ça qu'à la condition d'avoir
une très forte légitimité voilà mais il
faut et il faut aussi je pense ça c'est
important je pense qu'il faut que les
Français ressentent que leur chefs
d'État
euh d'abord a de
l'autorité et deuxièmement est quelqu'un
de respectable
et pour avoir de l'autorité c'est un
sujet que c'est c'est quoi l'autorité
c'est un mot que je je cite souvent son
étymologie ça vient du latin
actoritas qui a également donné le mot
auctor c'est dire un auteur c'est
important l'étymologie vous ne pouvez
pas avoir d'autorité si les gens sentent
qu'en fait vous êtes un paltoquet qui
appliquer une politique qui n'a pas été
pensé par vous lorsque de Gaul faisait
ses conférences de presse à
l'Élysée il avait aucune note et il
parlait c'était lui qui avait réfléchi
c'était lui qui faisait ses analyses et
les Français le sentaient et sentait
qu'il vibrait pour la France il il avait
fait il faisait vraiment il il s'est
dévouit il dévouait toute son activité
toute sa toute sa toute son tout son
psychisme toute son tout son travail
toute son toute son voilà à au bien-être
et à la grandeur de la France au
bien-être des Français et il prenait des
décisions et ce qui lui faisait
d'ailleurs des scandales parfois il
avait des scandales créateurs ce qu'il
disait sur les Américains par exemple
rappelez-vous les scandales sur l'Europe
il avait parce que c'était lui et donc
il avait de l'autorité parce qu'il était
l'auteur de ses propres pensées comment
est-ce que Macron pourrait avoir de
l'autorité quand tout le monde devine
bien que c'est en fait un bouchon sur
l'océan c'est un paltoquet qui est
dirigé par des forces extérieures qui
l'ont catapulté à l'Élysée donc ça c'est
le premier point et le deuxième point ça
c'est vraiment fondamental c'est que les
Français je crois qu'ils ont besoin euh
de d'avoir euh le le myth des Français
quelque chose qui est important myth
fondateur myth créateur c'est le bon roi
c'est important il y a dans toute
l'istoire de France c'est le bon roi et
le Mauvais roi
euh le bon roi c'est Saint-Louis le bon
roi c'est Henri I le bon roi c'est
quelqu'un
qui qui qui cherche le bien-être de ces
de ces sujets c'est quelqu'un qui va
arrêter les guerres de religion qui va
pacifier il fait PRU de pragmati ça
c'est Henri I c'est le bon roi c'est
quelqu'un comme Saint-Louis qui crée les
les premiers établissements de commun
profit comme on dit c'est les ancê des
établissements publics avec l'hôpital
des 1520 Saint-Louis sous son chène
pourquoi on parle toujours on apprenait
quand j'étais enfant Saint-Louis son son
gène à Vincen pourquoi parce que il crée
une justice qui permet de donner la
justice de faire justice à des pauvres
gens des manant il y a encore du servage
à l'époque contre le féodal c'est ça
c'est ça
donc les Français c'est ça qui avait
parfaitement compris de Gaulle c'est que
les Français ce qu'il veulent ils
veulent avoir un président de la
République je suis persuadé que les
Français ont une capacité d'ailleurs ils
l'ont montré tout au long de leur
histoire ils ont une capacité de système
D extraordinaire ils ont une capacité de
dépassement de même mais à la condition
qu'ils ils aient le sentiment que le
chef de l'État il est là pour les servir
et qu'il n'appartient pas à une petite
Camaria de Mimi marchand et cetera de
ces gens-là de ces milieux terlope c'est
exactement ça les gens qui vont faire la
fiesta au fouets après avoir été élu
enin c'est
scandaleux la bêtise mais c'est c'est
c'est là on vient de voir la bêtise à
l'état natif si vous voulez c'est une
espèce de de truc d'opération de
laboratoire quand on voit que berou il
est nommé pr la première chose qu'il
fait c'est qu'il prend un Falcon à 12000
€ les 52 minutes pour aller devenir MRE
de poau et dire qu'il faut qu'il garde
tous ses apanages il faut vraiment qu'il
n mais qu'il soit qu' N bien compris au
problème de la France voilà c'est ça le
problème berou il devait faire il dire
qu'il renonçait à tous ses mandats il
devait dire qu'il allez il vendait les
la moitié des avions de du du glam il il
coupait les vivres il divisait il
demandait diviser par deux les salaires
de ces minist c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il
fasse tout de suite les Français ah
tiens là enfin on commence à nous
écouter c'est ça le truc alors la
question sur mi il faut bien sûr tailler
à la hache il y a des tas de choses à
faire je le renvoie à mon à mon par
exemple exemp moi je proposé dans mon
programme la suppression des régions
comment oui mais parce que ça parce que
ça me tient à cœur aussi parce que les
gens tous ces gens extrêmement policés
qui ritent ce qu' lui sur un prompteur
ça va bien moi c'est quelque chose qui
me tient à cœur parce que moi je suis
pas né de la cuisse de Jupiter mes
arrières- grandsparents étaient des
pauvres gens moi je suis un fruit de
l'école de la République mon père a été
le premier de la famille des fils
uniques à avoir son son bac et puis il
est tombé sur il y avait des des
hussards de la République comme on a dit
dans les anné 1930 qui avait prévenu mes
grands-parents que c'était un bon élève
et qui l'ont poussé à faire les grandes
écoles mes grand-parents savaient même
pas ce que c'était donc donc moi j'ai
été élevé dans cette et je suis
favorable plus que favorable à lacensure
sociale républicain ça c'est c'est pour
ça que question internet oui serait-il
prêt à rassembler avec les les meneurs
de chaque parti souverainiste pour
discuter d'une alliance pour que le
souverainisme est une chance de percer
alors premièrement et serait-il prêt à
des concessions si les autres sont prêts
à en faire également mais premièrement
c'est un peu un détail mais pas tout à
fait j'ai toujours dit que je n'aimais
pas le mot de souverainisme voilà nous
nous ne sommes pas souverainistes nous
nous sommes un mouvement de libération
national est-ce que vous imaginez les
Viet Kong au Vietnam dire qu'ils étaient
souverainistes non il voulaient chasser
les Américains pour recouvrait notre
alors l'indépendance et la souveraineté
du Vietnam est-ce que le est-ce que le
FLN algérien était souverainiste non
c'était un mouvement il voulait chasser
la France pour retrouver la souveraineté
l'indépendance nationale donc moi je
n'aime pas le mot de souverainisme qui a
un côté un petit peu bon qui par
ailleurs est très connoté accessoirement
comme étant de droite or je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure lorsque je parlais de
la victoire de la CED en
1954 j'ai créé un mouvement politique
qui est un mouvement qui se veut un
mouvement d'union nationale sur un
objectif sur trois objectifs extrêmement
précis la sortie de l'Union européenne
sortie de l'euro sortie de l'autant et
donc depuis 18 ans je prends un j'ai un
souci constant je n'y arrive pas
forcément toujours mais quand même j'ai
toujours le souci constant de dans des
propositions que les gens aent voir le
programme qui est en ligne de proposer
quelque chose qui n fus que qui ne fus
que pas un des deux camps qui y a quand
je pense que des gens de bonne foi qui
sont de droite ne peuvent pas être
offusqués par le programme que je fais à
ce condition qu'il soit de bonne foi
pareil pour des gens de gauche voilà
mais il y a aussi des gens de mauvaise
foi voilà il y a des gens de GA à partir
du moment où il y a 20 ans j'ai
travaillé auprès de Charles pascoy il
veut plus entendre parler de moi je suis
quelqu'un de droit c'est terminé voilà
ça on les laisse mais donc je veux avoir
un un parti qui soit auudessus du
clivage droite gauche donc ça c'est un
premier point il y a quelque chose sur
lequel on ne transisera jamais c'est pas
seulement moi d'ailleurs parce que ces
alliances vous voyez comment chassé le
naturel il event au Galot les gens me
parlent comme si j'étais le roi de
France mais non à l'uppr les alliances
les sujets d'alliance on en a parlé
c'est pas uniquement moi c'est au bureau
politique alors il y a des gens qui
disent oui mais vous faites laapp le
butant non c'est pas vrai on a des vrais
débats et ben je peux vous dire que donc
ce sont des sujets qui sont débattus le
deè si moi je vous rassemble à la
rentrée ou
février mais moi si mois je vous
rassemble c'est-à-dire je prends les les
non mais attendez je termine mon propos
il y a par ailleurs j'ai passe à la
questionnette oui mais j'ai fait que
tout le monde les gens qui m'écoutent il
tapent aselino soirée brexit 31 janvier
2020 c'est sur Internet on a même un
article é en ligne il y avait des vidéos
et cetera j'ai été le seul et unique
responsable politique français à être en
mesure de rassemblé ce jour-là il y
avait tous les souverainistes comme il
comme certains les appellent il y avait
Nicolas duponignan Florian
Philippo George kzmanovic de gauche il y
avait Jean-Frédéric Poisson il y avait
Jacques Cheminade il y avait un
représentant personnel le directeur de
cabinet du compte de Paris que j'avais
vu quelques temps auparavant parce que
je pensais qu'il faut justement il faut
rassembler tout le monde he il compris
les les les les monarchistes je je il y
avait également Dominique jamaet il y
avait Gill Casanova qui est un ancien du
du du MRG et cetera il y avait pierre
léville qui est un ancien du Parti
communiste qui a fait
mieux qu'est-ce que ça a donné et ben
voilà qu'est-ce que ça a donné vous
savez ce que ça a donné vous savez ce
que ça a donné toutes les personnes
presque sans exception qui sont venu ont
toutes chacune annoncé dans leur coin
qu'elle serait candidate à la prochaine
élection
présidentielle Nicolas dupignant
Florient Philippo Jacques Cheminade
George kzmanovic euh et puis
jean-fédéric poisson pas pas le
directeur de cabinet du compte de Paris
quand
même est'est-ce que j'y peux est-ce que
vous avez trois livres à conseiller à
notre
communauté ça dépend sur quel sujet des
livres qui ont été marquant pour vous ou
important dans la construction de votre
capacité à raisonner
alors pour pour l'histoire vraiment
contemporaine ENF ce que je suggère pour
moi c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
quelque chose de fondamental c'est le CT
de Gaulle de perfit est en trois tomes
franchement vous verrez que la pensée
gaulienne est absolument extraordinaire
donc ça c'est très politique en
matière en matière de de
pensé il y a un autre livre c'est un
livre d'histoire mais que je trouve
absolument génial oui oui ok dors non
c'est les conséquences politiques de la
paix de Jacques bville qu' écrit en
1918 c'est génial c'est génial parce que
Jacques benville euh a analysé donc les
les 1919 je sais plus quoi il analyse
les conséquences vous savez les points
de les points de Wilson et cetera il
analyse les conditions qui sont faites à
l'Allemagne et
il dit que il va y avoir dans les 30 ans
qui viennent une nouvelle
guerre vraiment c'est c'est c'est très
intéressant parce que ça permet de de
montrer que des gens à partir d'un
raisonnement historique hein à partir
d'une connaissance géopolitique peuvent
prévoir ce qui risque de se passer et ça
c'est et là on a on l'a sous les yeux
cette affaire voilà ça c'est le deuxème
le deuxème ouvrage et puis alors après
bon il y a une quantité d'ouvrage c'est
pour s'ouvrir l'esprit sur des
civilisations étrangères ça ça me paraît
ça me paraît euh un
exemple un
exemple ENF ça me gêne de le mettre dans
le groupe des trois parce que c'est un
exemple parmi m000 autres mais un livre
qui est très très m connu en France
c'est quand même un des textes sacrés
pour plus d'un milliard d'habitants
c'est le la bagavad Guita de du TI du du
Mahabarata qui est l'un des textes
fondateurs de l'hindouisme et c'est
c'est absolument prodigieux parce que on
a un texte qui remonte à peu près à- 500
avant Jésus-Christ et qui est prodigieux
et surtout qui montre ce que une
civilisation qui n'est pas une
civilisation qui a été passée au moule
de du judaïsme du Christian enfin
religions du Liv judaisme christianisme
islam par exemple la bagavad Guita c'est
commence c'est c'est une entre vous avez
le le Krishna qui est un avatar du
Vichnou qui apparaît un guerrier qui
s'appelle Arjuna et qui ne veut pas se
battre contre ses cousins c'est devant
une bataille s'appelle la bataille de
kurouetra va y avoir des milliers de
morts et la divinité lui dit tu dois te
battre et tu dois tu tes cousins c'est
l'antithèse du Décalogue judéo chrétien
je dois reposer une question parce que
il y a il y a quelqu'un qui du moins ils
sont trois qure à poser toujours la même
je la repose vous la pose faudra lui
demander pourquoi François es lino
sa'abord les invitations de Florian
Philippo et les tentatives d'alliance
entre souverainistes il se prétend de
l'héritage de De Gaulle pourquoi
n'a-t-il pas en tant que tel pas en tant
que tel écoutez je vais pas entrer dans
cette polémique on a répondu 50 fois
d'ailleurs c'est pas moi qui ai répondu
c'est le Bureau politique de l'uppr qui
a publié un document excusez du peu qui
doit faire 18 pages extrêmement
précisément pour savoir quels sont quel
est le quel est le problème que nous
avons avec Monsieur Philippo qui
d'ailleurs n'est pas un problème avec
celino monsieur Philippo il allit
demandé à Monsieur kzmanovic il a publié
un communiqué kzmanovic il ne veut plus
entendre parler de Filippo demander à
Monsieur Juvin Brunet il ne veut plus
entendre parler de Philippo demandez à
Monsieur Philippe muret il ne veut plus
entendre parler donc il y a quand même
un petit problème hein un petit problème
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose
d'impérissable mais dans quel
domaine quoi comme comme règle de vie
comme comme ce que vous voulez
imaginez-vous vous allez bientôt crever
et vous laissz un conseil aux jeunes
générations un truc emprint de Françis l
et ben je dire alors l'un des plus
grands avec le sourire l'un des plus
grands enseignements de la vie euh c'est
être
soi-même Françoise linau merci merci de
m'avoir reçu